foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
draft night is back what is up how you
living how you feeling how you doing
Michael Felder Mike Renner two mics
tonight Felder Renner we're feeling good
it is left go here if you've seen any of
the clips from night one we had fun if
you're back again thank you for joining
us there are big names that go on night
one on night two this is where
championships are won rounds two and
three they'll be going fast and furious
and we're getting all right to it we've
had a night to process our thoughts
Felder after night one where are you
right now big picture what do you think
I think we saw a pretty interesting
night one which means that we're
probably going to see a pretty
interesting night too especially because
there's a lot of guys that we thought
were going to go yep in that round one
we thought they were going to go there
and all of a sudden they're still
available for round two so this is gonna
be pretty interesting your big board
Runner the names that surprise you the
most that were still on there where do
we start I obviously will love us I mean
I have him as qb2 in this draft class I
think he has NFL caliber tools I get how
he falls this far though because
quarterback's such a binary decision a
lot of teams just aren't going to take a
guy so even if you have a high grade on
them you're not going to take them the
other one though is Michael Mayer I mean
he's just good like you just you know
from day one you're getting probably a
top 10 to 12 tight end in the NFL to me
I see again why he falls he's not the
high-end athlete that usually goes in
the first round but I think someone's
going to be really happy here probably
within the first five picks of the
second round to be getting a guy like
Michael Mayer the first five picks we
were talking about this before the show
it always goes fast and furious because
the calls are being made Adam schefter
if we want to throw that tweet up we
know that right now pick 32 normally
that's round one but the Steelers have
it because the Steelers got this pick
from the Chicago Bears right for Chase
Claypool which now that you think about
that whole move is is beyond crazy
especially Chicago with DJ Moore now but
the Steelers apparently mulling multiple
offers for this pick I think everybody
right now is is mocking them at Joey
Porter Jr just because of the storyline
and all that I went back and looked at
the results of round one seven defensive
ends and edges 70 Lyman one linebacker
so 12 of those 31 picks were in the
front seven on defense we had three
quarterbacks two wide rece two running
backs four wide receivers the only two
positions with no draft picks no centers
no safeties I can imagine there will be
safeties coming off of the board Felder
your man crush maybe not who we think
Pittsburgh but yes but do you have one
man crush that you that you cannot wait
to see get draft Brian Branch like
that's it that's yeah the safety of
course of course I'm picking the safety
yeah but like realistically the big
thing for me with Brian branch is he's
not just a safety he's he can do
everything and I think that's the thing
I really love about him is his ability
to do everything he is someone that
we've seen play a little bit outside
corner we've seen him play mostly inside
in that slot or we've seen him play
safety and this is the thing if you're
drafting Brian Banshee Brian branch and
you want to use him as a corner you're
making a mistake that's on you not on
him as a player it's on you so the big
thing for me is when Brian Branch comes
off the board I am going to be super
hyped because this is a guy I think he's
the best DB in this draft I don't think
he's I think he's maybe the sixth or
seventh best corner but I do think he's
the best defensive back uh we are
getting ready for Pittsburgh they
currently do have the first pick of the
second round number 32. it's going to go
Pittsburgh Carolina and Detroit you can
see that on your screen right now also
if we want let's take a look at the
Pittsburgh stream throughout this draft
we know that some of you will be
watching not on the main page but on the
different team streams uh the chats chat
uh the team chats so you can always
weigh in we'll see some of your comments
throughout the night but again round two
is going to pick up this is a Pittsburgh
team they traded up from 17 to 14 took
Broderick Jones the offensive tackle the
other needs that I saw were cornerback
and D Lyman the two that they were
mocked from all the mocks I looked at
were Broderick Jones and Joey Porter Jr
is it too perfect Renner to just have
them sitting here with Joey Porter Jr
somehow still on the board I think it is
a little too perfect like this is a
dream scenario for them when they trade
away Chase Claypool I don't think in
their wildest dreams they imagined this
being a possible outcome for them but I
can also see with this roster you know
one Joy report is great you can flip
this into more picks with how desperate
teams start to get when it's at top
second round when they've had a whole
day now to kind of figure it out where
there aren't a lot of Corners now you
got him you got a guy like Tyreke
Stevenson from Miami if you're looking
for kind of press and man type of
Corners there may not be a lot so you
may see some desperation for teams to
move up for a guy like Joey Porter Jr to
here and so maybe that picked 32 maybe
you get more value for that pick because
everyone's had a lot of time to say look
at their board and say we may not get
the guy we want we're gonna have to go
up and get them so Steelers really in a
driver's seat right now in terms of will
Levis watch because that it's we're
always defined by the quarterbacks so
who do we want boys I love that will
Levis uh Mark Van Reef Mark stop trying
to be problematic we see what you're
doing and I don't like it uh pick five
of the second round as the Rams Matt
Stafford's getting up there I could see
and you mentioned before the Rams and
Kentucky connection 10th pick of the
second round the Titans are sitting
there maybe they're a team 19th pick of
the second round Tampa Bay right now
Baker I don't know if they're going to
roll are there any other teams that you
guys think could make a move to get up
here right now and want to go after
Levis I I truly I don't I don't
understand if we can put away our this
maybe our non-trust levels in general
you like Levis I like Levis that's the
balance that I like right I'll say that
there will probably be teams that would
be if he falls to them I'm not sure the
desperation to go up and get them okay
but maybe if like New Orleans if he
falls to you there okay that pick 40.
pick 40. okay one spot ahead of
Tennessee what I was going to say what
about 41 is 41 another possible Landings
Tennessee at 41 is definitely a landing
okay and I think hennan hookers also win
this mix here the Tennessee quarterback
like I think both those guys are
in other drafts where there's not three
top four type of quarterbacks they're
probably going the first round and
especially if Henry hooker hadn't toward
his ACL so at that point I think they
still come off the board somewhere early
here probably before the you know
probably before like the mid 50s okay
what at 50 Tampa Bay 50 Tampa Bay seems
like
51 51 Miami as well if we're just
thinking about a backup for two
because they really don't have one right
now just maybe some depth that would
also cause a lot that's a lot of
problems you know what yeah you're
creating too many problems that you
don't you don't need that to get them
this hot to get them that high no no no
no no no
you don't do it you know it would be fun
though you know don't do that do that to
my boy don't do that to my boy
um okay I just want to as we get ready
and as as you guys know if you've ever
watched our draft show as soon as the
picks get made and we start knowing
based on Twitter yesterday the MVPs were
Connor Hughes and Albert Breer we will
break the picks we want to be ahead of
the television broadcast uh imagine uh
friarmouth and mayor at tight end that
would be pretty good uh Stenson Bennett
okay and rap just you're being you're
being mean uh I just can we look at some
some Levis footage real quick what are
maybe we not seeing about Levis that you
believe he is still a guy that you
should pursue to me it's kind of the
things that translate to the NFL that
maybe you don't see a lot of in college
for other top quarterbacks and it's
performance Under Pressure having to
operate from tight Pockets which that's
obviously not one right but it's
performed under pressure and it's the
arm talent to work the downfield aspects
yeah that he will work from the pocket
to the intermediate and deep levels even
when things aren't clean around if his
eyes don't drop when pressure comes and
you still see him willing to step into
throws when he knows he's going to take
a hit and that toughness is is a
necessary requirement how many how many
quarterbacks that are successful
franchise guys at the NFL level do you
question their toughness it's another
position on the football field that has
to have that requisite level of
physicality you said yesterday the Rams
at pick 36 are can you explain to
everybody the connection between the
Rams and Levis so 2021 Will loves his
best season at Kentucky Liam Cohen is
his offensive coordinator Liam Cohen
then goes to Los Angeles the next season
to become their offense coordinator now
he's obviously back at Kentucky to be
their offense corner but that was his
best season last year Rick's gorillo
former Broncos OC was his offense
coordinator really fell off had the turf
toe injury but what you saw on tape in
2021 is why I go to bat for him as one
of the better quarterback prospects in
this class so there's familiar the
familiarity there can we talk about the
other side yes what scares you about
Levis I mean and how why do we think
he's here right now I think he's here
right now because I don't think that
teams trust him at nearly as much as
obviously they trusted those other guys
I don't think that Kentucky trusted him
as much as as those other teams trusted
their quarterback and I think that's the
big part for me where yes he did make
some strong throws down the field he
does have a strong arm but when you look
at his net numbers in terms of ability
to push the ball down the field uh
vertically the um the the the production
numbers like I get why Anthony
Richardson went number four because you
can't look at his passing numbers by
themselves right you also have to look
at the rushing numbers of which he had
over 600 with Will Levis you have to
look at his rushing numbers which he had
negative 172 if I'm not mistaken yeah
that's a big difference so that's a 800
yard difference yeah and I think that's
some of the production parts that we
have to pay attention to but the other
thing for me
I never really felt when I watched
Kentucky I never felt that they asked
him to win the game like there was
winning time for CJ Stroud there was
winning time for Bryce young like I
still I think one of the best
performances that I've ever seen is the
end of that Alabama the end of the
Alabama Auburn game where Bryce Young's
like just please get me the ball back
give me the ball back and I'll win and
they and he did and he they got in the
ball back and they went and they won and
I think that's going to be the key for
me I don't see that out of Levis and
that's the part where and I hate to say
the word intangibles or that you can't
teach that because I think you can teach
it but I think the goal for me is I you
have to see some of it to know that you
can get there right and the other issue
being Levis is going to be 24 years old
as rookie Anthony Richland and we just
talked about you know like they're kind
of seen similarly he's only 20 years old
right so you have like four more years
of a guy to kind of develop before he's
talked about like because think about it
if you sign him on a one year first
round contract that's a five-year deal
that means when he's is 29 we're talking
about a renegotiation Lamar Jackson was
what 24-25
Jalen hurts 24 years old you're right
it's a whole other lifestyle okay let's
talk about the Steelers uh Mike Tomlin
somehow guides this team to a 9-8 record
last year uh I don't know how he did it
third in the AFC North uh Kenny Pickett
is the guy Naji Harris they go and they
get Broderick Jones Felder what are you
thinking here for them at 32. I mean I'm
thinking
why not I like
this like if they if somebody especially
if somebody in their division gets him
folks are going to be livid so this is
going to be real it's not just the fact
that he's a legacy guy it's also the
fact that this is a guy who is good at
football he can play football I know
that Micah Parson said yesterday you
worry about if he's going to be a little
bit grabby but at the end of the day
he's gonna he's gonna learn he's gonna
develop he's gonna like you can't just
keep getting penalties and stay in the
game especially when you play for Mike
Tomlin so I don't think that that's a
long-term issue that I that I'm gonna
worry about what I'm looking at is a guy
who
can go out and make plays can go out and
get the job done and it's going to be
interesting to see how this all shakes
itself out I though if I were picking
for the Steelers right now the guy I
would want is Brian Branch you were
ready I love that you already have Mika
Fitzpatrick who played the Brian Branch
role at Alabama yeah because Keanu Neal
is not who you want to go in at the
other safety exactly like he's a pure
box guy he's never been a deep Guy Brian
Branch's versatile can go slot can go
deep and having two guys in that kind of
mold in him and make a Fitzpatrick just
basically opens up your playbook as a DC
to where you never have to not call this
play because I'm worried about this guy
getting put on an island no both those
guys can play on an island how much
higher do you have branch on your big
board than Porter juice I have them five
spots ahead so excuse me six spots head
so Joey poor Junior 24th Brian Branch
18th I just think Brian branch is a sh
sure thing in a number of ways now he's
not the high-end athlete that may be
like a Joey Porter Jr is or some other
guys in this class are but he is a damn
good football player yeah and what about
what about D Lyman are they any
d-linement at this position that have
value that are worth it I don't think so
we just you just talked about 14 going
in the first round there it's it's
copycat League the teams that were in
Super Bowl this year were first and
second in sacks everyone's seeing that
everyone's trying to look into the
roster right now I mean Cameron Hayward
was drafted in 2011. uh and so we're
getting to a point where we have to I
mean remember they had two in all those
years and they've been trying to replace
them but this is a a a defense that look
they somehow finished top 10 against the
rush but they definitely took a step
back as soon as this pick comes out we
will do it it looks like the Pittsburgh
Steelers have made the pick it does not
look like they trade even though they
were mulling all of those options the
pick is in and it is is it Joey Porter
Jr
Joey Porter Jr
makes you feel good in your chest
doesn't it bro let's go are you kidding
me this is exciting
he's so he I think I just think he's
super talented he's so good and I love
the way that he plays the way that he
plays football like I think he's just
such a talented like he's he's truly
look he's he there was a time where when
Joey Porter played for the Pittsburgh
Steelers that defense was dominant and
now Joey Porter Jr will be playing for
the Pittsburgh Steelers second team
All-American First Team all Big Ten 31
starts so he has a lot of experience and
he also with 34-inch arms got 17 bench
reps so like his dad he is a dog runner
the value to get him first pick of the
second round no one bats an eye if they
draft this guy at 17 right so to get him
here is an absolute coup I love the pick
love the fit Corners obviously a massive
need for them to me he's the best pure
press Corner in this draft class the
only problem is like he kind of has to
be a press corner like that is his bread
and butter this past year week one
targeted 14 times against Purdue has
five pass breakups was not tested the
rest of the year people saw that tape
said let's not go his way we don't have
the wide receivers that can beat him
one-on-one and you see here just the
physicality image to the 17 bench press
reps with those longer arms and with
that power behind them wow the kind of
the physicality that when he hits you at
the line of scrimmage you feel it the
comp there Carlton Davis is that's what
you can expect a guy that's just not
going to get targeted a lot because he's
going to take your wide receivers out of
the progression before the play even
starts great we're gonna go with an A
plus for that look at that I you know I
love him we talked before we even got
picked I was like this is what I want
him to do yeah last night I was like
this is what I want him to do at 17.
yeah so this is a this is a this is a
coup for them this is a huge win I love
that they're getting this guy he can
play press he's not afraid to come up
and make a tackle that's what I love
about him too you see him here patient
feet that's Zone coverage right there
and he understands down and distance
playing sticks right to make sure that
guy doesn't get the first down you love
that out of him I think the big key for
me you you've been called from Davis he
reminds me of the length reminds me of
Dre Kirkpatrick coming out of Alabama
remember how long he was crazy long arms
when you look at Joey Porter look at
look he when he's in his stance his arms
are below his hands are hanging below
his knees six two one ninety three no
one else even has close to that
measurables he's huge I love him this is
an easy one for me come on and bring him
back let's go we're going a plus right
here I absolutely love this pick he is
going to be a dog and I think that this
is one of those things can we go to the
chat is that possible absolutely I want
to see what the chest going yeah by the
way he allowed zero touchdowns this
season and in man coverage he was
targeted 26 times allowed just nine
catches for 70 total yards the entire
season and you guys mentioned that
wingspan over 80 inches I don't think
it's a coincidence that we're seeing a
lot of player Sons gravitate towards
defensive back nowadays right okay
that's one Winfield Junior whether it's
Patrick certain whether it's Asante
Samuel because it's a position that if
you're watching the game early on you
get that Head Start The Vision that they
play with that those guys play with
helps you at the defensive back position
just understanding the game and you
really see that on his tape the ability
to just read and recognize is really
good I love going to the chat and
immediately like cursing
16 Seasons never a losing season under
timeline we good bro yeah and this is a
good pick too so I think you're gonna
you're gonna get they're gonna get they
got better right now uh let's go we're
going now to Arizona Arizona's on the
clock I think Arizona made one of the
best moves of the draft yesterday
apparently the reports have come out
they wanted Paris Johnson All Along by
moving down they were able to pick up a
first and third rounder for next year
pretty much swapping second round picks
right here they get Paris Johnson Jr
they got this one the Will Anderson
trade what are we thinking here for
Arizona they have a lot of needs right
this may be on paper the worst roster in
the NFL there's probably only a few
positions I wouldn't address one being
safety one being linebacker because they
keep drafting you know linebackers there
in the first round that's really about
it probably not tackle anymore after how
many they've loaded up now but I think
after that every position nothing else
is off limits here so there's been trade
rumors about both Buddha Baker and
DeAndre Hopkins even though the GM's
saying we are not trading DeAndre
Hopkins is there a player that you think
fits there Felder man
Edge Corner DJ Turner is that a guy
maybe I you know what I hadn't I hadn't
thought about him but yes I like DJ
Turner I also like cam Smith a guy that
I think has been kind of overlooked in
the scenario Carolina Smith from South
Carolina I think he's got a good comp to
J.C horn that's who's been pretty good
in the NFL so far so I really like that
if I'm them I would consider added to me
while adabare because he is a dark side
play you're in a position where the
window if you're a Cardinals fan it
ain't this year it probably is not next
year right it's three years from now so
take a guy who is a swing to where you
have to develop I'm sure but in three
years it could be an impact 3 technique
that is in high-end rusher whereas and
there it is you know who that's going to
be for Willie so if Arizona just traded
with the Titans what the Arizona
Cardinals have done because Kyle merley
Kyler Murray tore his ACL racking up
picks for next season because this is
going to be a throwaway year right and
the fact that they got Houston's first
round pick and now they're going to get
some Titans picks if I can get Houston
and Titans picks for next year please if
the Titans just traded up I'm just going
to say this is most likely going to be
for will Levis would you agree I agree I
I think with that offense the way they
attack the middle of the field
intermediate era in Breaking routes that
that's if there's anything will Levis
did on tape it was that and a guy who in
my opinion is a better Prospect
considerably better Prospect than Malik
Willis was coming out last year
obviously he's reportedly fallen out of
favor
is the guy if they picked at 11. yeah
they said why
he's fallen out of favor let's not wow
there it is there he goes there we go he
waited an entire night he don't got to
wait very long on day two will Levis the
future quarterback for the Tennessee
Titans
Tennessee moving up nine spots from
eight spots from 41 to 33.
there was some hope that Malik Willis
would be the quarterback of the future
for the Tennessee Titans after one
season Tennessee is making will Levis
the future of the franchise two-time
team captain will Levis he's an
interesting dude former OC Liam Cohen
said the team feeds off him his
personality as one of which that guys
will naturally follow now the future of
the titans the thought of getting him at
this point it's a win a huge win no
again no one bats an eye if they draft
him at 11 right and to get him here now
absolutely give up a little bit to move
up but not anywhere near the commitment
it takes that 11th overall pick it
doesn't put that pressure on him start
right away because you have Ryan
Tannehill and to me life's going to get
easier for him in the NFL you watch his
tape at Kentucky his pressure rate was
higher than all but three NFL teams this
past year had his uh what he had to work
with that wide receiver was not what
guys like CJ Stroud Bryce young even
Anthony Richardson had to work with this
past season and what I love
22 of 23 in his career on sneaks that's
a weapon nowadays that's a big thing he
knows how to take it he can run he's a
big dude big athlete comp there is Jake
Locker obviously not a great how about
that Tennessee Titans but he has just
got to fix his accuracy you tell me he
fixes his accuracy I tell you he's a
franchise quarterback but his accuracy
right now is a worrisome issue so this
one's got to be an A plus for me too
this is just the accuracy was there on
third down it's a completion percentage
of nearly 72 percent on third Downs in
2022 43 touchdowns in two seasons fifth
most in Kentucky history we heard the
positives sure can I get uh some hard
truths about why he went here at 33. 19
and 10. 19 and 10. I mean this is it's
20 23 19. we got guys that are throwing
47 touchdowns we got guys that are
throwing 50 touchdowns like it's it's
one of those things where you check his
production you figure out what what what
he does well and yeah he can't throw the
push the ball vertically down the middle
I mean that's a
to me that's an amazing catch that was
on the wide receiver that was a wide
receiver making a play that's a great
play call right there so I just I'm I'm
I'm I'm I want to watch I don't want him
to not succeed I
root for all these guys but to me like I
look at that that's a that's a bad ball
and so he gets stats for it but that was
a bad ball
he does need to improve his touch throws
too he is lasers only and I think some
of it's because that short arm release
but that's also like a selling point of
his is that that arm strength paired
with as tighter release as you'll see in
this draft class it just the windows get
smaller at the NFL level and so you have
the ability to attack windows that other
guys in this class don't because of that
but again the touch has to improve
here's what I'm going to do
I'm gonna go b-plus okay I'm gonna go B
plus because the value
I'm not in love with the pick yes but
the value is clearly there if some
people had him mocked at number one some
people had him going in the in the top
ten stuff like folks had him in the top
15. if he ends up going at number what
is this what is this 33 33 okay fine I'm
not I'm not nearly as bothered by that
you know what I'm saying here are the
details so they give up 33 and 81 for
41.72 so pretty much swapping second and
third round picks and then they add in a
third round pick for next year next year
which doesn't feel like a lot
does it feel like a lot to you that
feels like a lot breakdown why it feels
like a lot because to get a third I mean
that's because they only moved up eight
spots right they stuck around once you
move eight spots in the second round a
normal trade eight spots in the second
round is gonna net you
probably one-third in like this year's
draft but they move up also in the third
round and then I would get a third next
year's draft when Tennessee obviously
may not be that good next year I guess
the reason it doesn't feel like a lot to
me is because of the position yes if
you're giving up a third rounder for a
quarterback it doesn't feel like a lot
if he ends up being the guy
comparatively to like what we saw the
Texans for Will Anderson yes absolutely
uh Detroit has had a wildly interesting
draft and now they are going Sam laporta
after they went a running back at 12 and
then
let's see Sam laporta the pick is in at
pick number 32. all Iowa drafter Iowa
tight and Sam laporta they have put some
prospects into the draft in recent years
of course Hawkinson of course fan 6-3
245 San laporta First Team all Big Ten
led the team in receiving only tight end
and FBS with 20 or more forced missed
tackles so the dude can break some
tackles what do you think at 34. yeah
they legitimately threw this guy's
screens I think this is a good value
pick I think this is where I would have
taken him now he's only six foot three
he's not like the big wingspan protested
catch short a guy he's not a Hawkinson
you would say but he is an athlete 459
the ball in his hands he can create on
his own he can get open on his own he's
just you know going to be a little bit
different he's not a great inline
blocker like you expect out of Iowa
tight ends but athletes like this at the
tight end position are what wins you
just see him after the catch yeah look
at that power he can win this he's the
guy that you're just not going to
complain about at that position to go
from TJ Hawkinson to him he's he's quite
a bit more Dynamic than even TJ
Hawkinson is even if hawkinson's more
prototypical size wise so I'm going a
with this pick NFL scout Felder said
listen he's not Noah fan or Hawkinson
but he's tougher than them and we go
back to Dan Campbell that's what he
wants this guy's gonna eat a kneecap he
kneecaps he's gonna eat a kneecap uh I
love him I think he's a fantastic
football player the big thing for me
again he's not the best inline blocker
but guess what he can give you this and
that's a play where you buy time you buy
space and he's able to look at him line
up outside he's lining up outside wide
and like I mean he's not as tall as a
guy like Tyler eifert right but he gives
you some of that same juice in terms of
where you can move him around and what
you can do I understand he's not as tall
and don't listen I get it but he does
have that offensive juice and that's
what I like about him he is such a
talented player I was talking to Joshua
Perry Joshua Perry was like he's my
favorite he's my favorite tight end and
I was like he's your favorite he was
like yep I like him the most this is a
guy this guy's a true weapon so for me
I'm gonna go with an A minus on this one
um I think there are other players maybe
a little bit higher on the board but at
the end of the day you get you again we
keep we keep talking about this with the
Lions right
they're picking what they want yes no
they have a very interesting tape uh 459
155 and Sam laporta by the way one
penalty is career is a TD celebration my
only question there is if you want a
tight end Michael Mayer's there but the
Raiders are trading up what do you got
on your mind Renner I was gonna say
about Laporte versus mayor in that
offense with what the Detroit Lions do a
lot of tight end production is like in
the flats right Crossing routes shallow
Yak stuff if you're going Yak receivers
in this class Titan position Laporte is
one he's number one so that that makes
sense for them and what they want even
if Michael Mayer may be a better more
well-rounded Prospect all right who
could the Raiders not be patient about
the pick is in oh so I was gonna say
they just traded away tight end look at
that we got it tied in wow the run
another one yeah the mayor comes off the
board the Las Vegas Raiders earlier this
off-season got rid of Darren Waller and
they need a new tight end for Josh
McDaniel's offense the Mayor Michael
Mayer a team captain the most prolific
tight end in the history of Notre Dame
an NFL scout said he is built out of
vibranium we thought he was going to be
going a lot earlier than this your
values got to be crazy this is an A plus
pick he was top 25 21st ranked player on
my draft board again it's just because
of the certainty he's already great
inline blocker he already can separate
on his own he has that innate shiftiness
the comp is Jason Witten and they each
like have the same running shuffly
running style yes that's just you can't
predict which way they're going to go
because their feet never really leave
the ground so to me you're just getting
a darn good football player and in that
offense now that has so many weapons on
the outside this gives you a fourth guy
now alongside Jacoby Myers alongside
Hunter Renfro alongside Devonta Adams
that Jimmy Garoppolo can just distribute
he doesn't have to get locked in
anywhere and the thing I love about
mayor he's only a true Junior coming out
there's some meat on the bone develop
mentally with him whereas Laporte is a
senior Kincaid's a fifth year guy coming
out was there any 22 yet that next step
for Michael Mayer uh great
a plus yeah I figured that uh Felder I
got one more thing for you so you're
talking about like where he plays 62
inline 38 attached can kind of do
everything broke Tyler eifert's career
receptions record in just 30 Games we're
talking about good tight ends hey man
look at that I brought up Tyler already
how about them apples No I um I like him
a lot I think he's really good my
favorite my favorite clips of him are
when he goes out and out out to get back
in and I don't know if we have one on
here but he does this he has this great
subtlety to his game and you mentioned
it Renner the idea that he can has those
little chop steps where he you don't
know which way he's going to break you
don't know what he's going to do and
when he goes when he takes a half step
out and the guy over expands he comes
back inside and he's able to catch that
ball on the seam I love that great ball
skills obviously he can do a little bit
after the catch as well I copped him to
Heath Miller Heath Miller played a long
time with Steelers he's a heck of a
football player so for me I also have to
go a plus this is a guy that just he's
gonna get the job done again we talk
value this is someone that we thought
could go in the top 20 top 25 you're
getting them at this pick at pick number
35 you're winning that all they did to
move up from 38 to 35 was a fifth round
pick I know that you can find fifth
round picks but when you can get the guy
that you can now sit here and go we got
Tyree Wilson and Michael Mayer Bingo you
just left with impact guys on both sides
of the line that can help kind of like
with the running game on both sides but
are also super versatile on both sides
that that was that's an easy trade in my
opinion the fifth rounder is that's you
make that trade every day I see so third
rounder a bit High fifth round okay yeah
Easy Money uh man you know it's it's
something that um Micah Parsons was
talking a lot about recently when he was
talking about Jalen Carter replacing
Javon Hargrave when you get rid of
Darren Waller and you think of what that
contract would have been and now you get
Michael Mayer for the next four years
you that's how you can build a franchise
and rejuvenate after losing a play maker
like that yeah and they need to hit in
the draft right I mean the mayak Ruden
era was a malpractice in scouting in the
first couple of rounds unfortunately and
that really left the you know it's
depleted right they just didn't have
young talent coming through all the
talent they had was paid or traded for
and so they needed a draft like this
where it was just solid pick solid pick
guys you know that can make an impact uh
I have a question I think we're on pick
35 are the Colts up next we are on 30
36. so it went so it went Steelers Joey
Porter Jr Tennessee traded out with
Arizona to take will Levis did Vegas
just trade out with the no the Lions
that's what I got Ron then the Raiders
with the Indy with mayor for mayor and
now it's the Rams do we see another
tight end here I mean we got Luke
Musgrave Darnell Washington I expect
within the next 15 picks yeah that's the
Oregon State tight end George tight ends
we could see a note so we could see
another one I'll like Musgrave a lot too
I think he is like a he's kind of like
knock off Dalton Kincaid I was shocked
to look at how bad the Rams roster has
become it is shocking Steve Avila guard
that is our first our first true
interior offensive alignment of the
Draft is officially off the board at
pick number 36 we have a guard everybody
it is Mr Avila of TCU uh getting drafted
here by the Rams 35 starts and the man
is versatile 17 at Center 15 at left
guard two at right tackle one at Right
Guard and it fits because the Rams have
had offensive line issues now for the
last few years what do you think of him
going here at 36. he's a versatile
interior offensive lineman which they
need with all the injuries that they've
suffered of late uh to me he really made
himself some money in that playoff
stretch going up against mozzie Smith
going up against Jalen Carter his get
off for a 330 pound guard is special the
way he's able to pop off last rimage his
short sets and pass protection are the
best of any guard in this class really
powerful dude I think I probably like
him at guard but he played center to you
years ago back in 2021 to me it was neck
and neck him and Osiris Torrance were
talking to your offensive lineman in
this class and I had them both right in
this range of where they come off the
board so that one all that I got to give
it a name didn't give up a sack in 2022
Felder in that Championship run Bingo no
sacks none none that includes against
Georgia yes that includes against
Michigan yes this guy can play football
he is very good he is super physical
that's the thing I've always liked about
him and I saw your will Henderson comp
that's that's fantastic because it's a
guy who's a big Bruiser that can move
bodies out of the way gets people he
moves you that's the thing I want that's
what I want out of my guard to be able
to move this defensive tackle or to be
able to climb to the second level and
put take on a linebacker or move to
safety so I like that I like that
ability he's also pretty he's not more
athletic than I think those are going to
give him credit for because he has the
ability not just to root people out like
look at that just rooting a guy out to
Great Space for that first down he's
also got the ability to pull and I think
that's another great element to his game
so yeah especially the McVeigh offense
yes exactly you've got to be able to
move so for me I am going to give this
one an a he is absolutely
um just so he's super talented he has
the ability to do everything that you
want out of that position and again
versatility this is a guy that can play
left guard Center Right Guard so early
on he can be your swing guy early on you
know what he can also be he could be
your unbalanced guy well you bring if
you bring one if you want to bring in an
extra tackle bring him in yeah put him
in the game kick your tackle out wide
put him at a guard right next to him and
let's let's get big and run to me I call
this picks like this eating your
vegetables you may not love it it may
not be the sexiest thing but in the long
run it's gonna pay off because the Rands
ignored that offensive line for too long
I mean they didn't have the picks to
replenish that offensive line yes try to
do it last year when they drafted Logan
Bros with that first pick he obviously
gets hurt misses entire rookie season
but I think you now have your two
starting guards for the foreseeable
future with him Logan Bros and again it
may not be the sexiest but you have to
invest for the long term here because
it's going to be bad before it gets good
in La two things that the Rams offensive
line has been lacking durability and
versatility yeah over a thousand snaps
this year and he's played every position
on the line like you said man it's like
broccoli you just got to get it done
okay so that was the first pick of the
draft for the Rams they make their first
pick now we have another Seattle
Seahawks pick Seattle arguably got the
number one wide receiver and the number
one cornerback yesterday in Devin
Witherspoon and Jackson Smith and jigba
and now another pick that they got
because of the Russell Wilson trade
right crazy they're the ones that gave
up Russell Wilson and they're the ones
with all of the great picks uh Derek
Hall is the pick initial reactions
go ahead a little early a little early
for me I I think he's a heck of an
athlete and long arms 34 inch arms for a
6-2 guy you can see him there they're
like hanging down below his knees coming
off the line but his get off is electric
explosive but a linear dude you see when
he wins it's a lot of inside moves a lot
of bull rushes a guy who really
struggles to bend the edge and I think
you saw his production sort of stagnate
at Auburn because of that if he gets a
long arm though in his repertoire that's
more consistent he can be an impact pass
rusher he's just too good of an athlete
though that's going to last too long in
this draft so that's why it goes at this
point but his tape to me was just a
little little lacking left me wanting a
little more and he goes on the Senior
Bowl where kind of the great equalizer I
thought he struggled over that weekend
31 starts 19 and a half sacks that made
him seventh all time on Auburn sacklist
one behind D Ford what's incredible
about his story he was born at 23 weeks
two pounds nine ounces they go to his
mom and they say he's technically
illegally dead do you want to sell out
this child they never expected him to
walk or talk
and now he is being drafted the top of
the second round as an NFL player which
is incredible a testimony to him what is
your grade for Derek Hall at this point
I'm going to go with a B yeah
B for uh baby okay uh jeez all right
well no sympathy for Runner but that's
why we love you no I I love I I think
this is a good pick I think he's got a
guy that's going to fit into that locker
room I think he's got I think coming
from Auburn in the way that they play
football that they play Angry violent
football yes and that's what the
Seahawks want to do as well you look at
this effort that you're going to get
right here and the little bit of
violence to wrap it up too I think that
he I don't love him hand down I do think
he's better and as you saw right there
him been the edge he's being hand down
does help him Bend better because it
keeps him lower but he's a more violent
player when he's standing up and can use
his hands
um reminds me a little bit of uh Dante
Fowler a guy who had violent hands was
always disruptive always gave you good
effort so that's who I'm gonna go with
for him I think it's a good pick
honestly and obviously overcoming all
that is important as well but the big
key for me is he's someone that I was a
little bit higher on than other people
is what I've realized and so for me I am
going to give this pick an a because I
think that he is someone who is going to
continue to grow but again I loved Dante
Fowler coming out of college yeah he
didn't live all the way up to what we
thought he could be but at the end of
the day this isn't about what he this is
about what I think this guy can grow
into I think he can grow into a quality
NFL player I love the violence that he
plays with that's the part that I really
love because if you can play violent if
you can shock the offensive lineman yeah
you've got an opportunity to to make
plays at the next level they could teach
you some of this other stuff the Finesse
moves the bonus moves but they cannot
teach you how to be that violent I'll
say this about Seattle now drafted boy
Mafi in a similar range last year
Minnesota Edge Defender they're similar
dudes I mean they are just high-end
explosive get off athletes
just kind of need to figure it out we
just kind of need to figure out past
rushing plans at the next level but
they're the athletes that you bet on you
see this guy up close in person he's the
most physically imposing I mean the guy
is diced up 255. we have a trade Detroit
had moved back with Vegas five spots
when they went up and got Sam laporta or
excuse me uh
Vegas Scott Michael Mayer well Detroit
is now making another trade uh Detroit
Detroit is moving back with the Falcons
the Falcons are moving up right now the
one pick for the Falcons right now is
Bijon Robinson where could they be going
I always had mocked them Cody mock the
North Dakota State offensive tackle
because it is pretty crazy Matthew
Bergeron so you were right on the
position just a different a player this
is the Syracuse offensive lineman this
is an Atlanta Falcons team that a lot of
people were hyping up their offensive
line well this kid is an interesting
Prospect Matthew Bergeron second Team
all ACC 39 starts 31 at left tackle
eight at right tackle grew up in
Montreal and they were like listen bro
you need to start playing football and
now he's a top uh one of the top picks
in the second round is this about where
you thought he would go yeah this is I
had him just around 50 on the draft
board I I think he's a guy that was
probably more of a guard than an
offensive tackle if you would Captain
Matt tackle where he played at Syracuse
I think you were just going to have to
deal with some pass Pro concerns but I
think he could be a high-end guard at
the next level and you look at this
Falcons roster there was really one spot
on offense that was missing and it's
left guard and now you have a guy that I
think is a plug and play in that regard
you just may not get high-end play out
of him but he is a day one type of
starter extremely experienced very
steady a guy that's not going to have a
lot of ugly loss is a guy that's not
going to be flat on his face on the
ground love his balance I think again
you're the Atlanta Falcons we talked
about it yesterday when they picked
Bichon it's a commitment to the ground
game there this is just amplifying that
and basically committing to it wholesale
and completing what they think is now an
offense that's built for Desmond Ritter
we're gonna go within we're gonna go a
minus with that so Bijan and then
Bergeron yeah we gotta run the ball
let's run the ball and obviously we
talked about that with Arthur Smith a
day ago they wanna they wanna run the
football you better have the pieces to
do it and when you look at Bergeron he
is someone look Sean Tucker had a heck
of a football season and Bergeron was a
big part of that and you look what
they're able to do I think that he's
going to be better because he mentioned
the pass Pro some of those feelings but
look at the way he can climb to the
second level and absolutely control that
that safety he's got the athleticism to
do that I think part of the pass Pro
issues for him came with him them always
being in three-point stances not being
in a two-point stance so it was a little
bit slow on the on on his kick slide and
being able to control things but you
move him down inside now there's
somebody on either side of him he
doesn't have to do nearly as much work I
think this is a good one I'm gonna go
ahead and go I'm gonna go b-plus there
we go and also say this Jake Matthews 31
years old yeah some big cap hits look at
their depth chart right now to just
think where he slides in you have a guy
who you know if you drafted someone like
Cody mock who I said he's an interior
guy only actually Bergeron in a pinch
can now give you that guy to kick out at
left tackle if needed yeah the only
other thing I'm seeing is uh Matt
Hennessey is going to be a free agent
after this year but this could be the
Jake Matthews replacement and also if
we're being honest every team has
offensive line injuries every single
year yes it is just a fact of of life
and you need to invest in the thing that
I've Loved about hearing about Bergeron
is I hear that he just wants to just
smash people completely and there's a
toughness that comes with that but
congratulations to Mr Bergeron we are
now to the Carolina Panthers coming up
at pick number 39 overall eighth in the
second round they've taken one pick it
is Bryce young do they build around
Bryce or do they go to the defense and
it is going to be Jonathan Mingo on the
defensive side of the ball
Jonathan Mingo wide receiver excuse me
wide receiver uh Aaron look at this guy
going up athlete
excuse me Mr Mingo uh is this where you
thought he would go I did I I he was I
got a late riser in the process a guy
who really didn't break out until his
senior year he's been playing since his
freshman year at Ole Miss never really
productive until this past season people
had questions about us athleticism and
he goes to combine he runs a four four
six at six two two twenty wow these are
the guys I was talking about yesterday
we're talking about Emmanuel Forbes who
he's gonna have to guard it's guys like
Mingo because you see him when he's
running down the football field like
right there when guys try to get their
hands on him it doesn't affect them
there's a lot of shrimps in this draft
class A lot of guys in the 170 pound
range we talked about a few of them
yesterday Mingo is decidedly not that he
offers something that not a lot of guys
do which is that yak ability with some
size to turn into a running back after
the catch as you see there comp I have
for him is levisca Channel who's on the
roster of Carolina Chanel never quite
made that next step as a route Runner
with Mingo we're already starting to see
that we're already starting to see more
Nuance the only question I have with him
is kind of the stop start suddenness at
that size it's difficult to be you know
quite as quick as a lot of the receivers
we're seeing come off the board here
probably the only question I have with
them but he's a good building block type
of number two wide receiver uh great
we're gonna go a minus with it one of
the bigger wide receivers in this draft
class six one two twenty biggest hands
in this draft class 10 and 3 8. they got
to replace DJ Moore what kind of a
versatility does he bring for I think
this guy here's the thing why here's
what I love about Mingo okay is who
coached him
um
who's coaching the NFL who's coached
plenty of NFL guys who's coach receivers
in the NFL like this he he understands
what he wants to get out of his guys oh
I love this play too the fake skip toss
to down the field and I love I mean come
on let's go so this is one of those
things when you look at me and go he
does not look like he weighs 220 pounds
yeah he doesn't run like he weighs 220
pounds but he does I think there's good
bend I don't think that he has you know
the yeah
all of the sort of the moves that we saw
at a guy like Quentin Johnston but there
certainly is a good ability to run those
routes he understands what's being asked
him he understands where he's going to
come open that's the part I really like
about him I'm gonna go b-plus here
because I really was interested I
thought Jalen Hyatt might have been the
guy that comes off the board but I think
getting Mingo around Bryce young that
gives you an opportunity to really build
up that offense and find ways to make
Bryce more comfortable and find a guy
that understands where he's going to
come open the only thing is I probably
would have leaned more towards a Cedric
Tillman type Tennessee wide receiver
who's like a true possession kind of guy
whereas Mingo is much more of a after
the catch to deep threats let me ask you
let me go through the wide receiving
core they go and sign Adam feeling they
have DJ shark Terrace Marshall Jr we're
seeing if he can develop in anything you
said leviska Chanel when you look at
that wide receiving Court how does Mingo
fit into that it's it's tough because I
I don't love that wide receiving Corner
no like yeah I think he sees the field
early though you almost have to in that
wide receiving core but I still do think
the veterans are probably outclassing
them at this point in time okay but they
do get a wide receiver to grow uh with
Bryce young in their careers New Orleans
Saints are on the clock Brian brezie was
their first pick 29th overall we're now
sitting here at 40. uh there were three
guys that I had mocked to them will
McDonald who went at 15 Michael Mayer
who just came off the board and the
other was adabaroy now yeah they dig
O'Brien brzee so I don't know if they
want to go back to back other other
needs tight end I don't know if there's
a tight end and then offensive lineman
there are a number of offensive linemen
still on the board that I'm surprised
have lasted this long I think it was
Cyrus Torrance here with kind of the
struggles they've had at guard Andrus
Pete Cesar Ruiz and James Hurst are all
free agents after the year for the New
Orleans Saints I think that would be a
great pick for them great fit as well
for what they want to do in their Duo
heavy Run game at I think that's a guy
that I would love here and he's coming
he's coming from a super heavy Run game
like Keith They that's what Florida did
I mean that's why that's why Anthony
Richardson had 600 or something yards
like they they were in the football and
they ran it well and he's a guy that you
can plug in right at that guard spot and
he's going to be able to give you some
production so I wonder if that is going
to be the pick um so you guys like
cyborg
what that is Nick then yeah cyborg is
his nickname yeah yeah we like cyborg
cyborg and then his mom also called him
sibo we'll have more when we break down
he's a unique dude apparently he didn't
even want to walk for senior day he's
like you know I think I might come back
next year and then he had to be told to
leave to go to the NFL draft like hey
buddy you're too good you're too good to
come back next year just because it
seems like this pick has taken a little
bit longer why do we think now as we
look at the wide receivers it seems like
Jalen Hyatt is the one that hasn't come
off the board yet I think that there's
probably a question of his route running
and what he can do for you if you're not
going to play that true speed and space
offense if you're not going to give him
those kind of the double routes where
he's able to uh those option routes
where he has to pick to go down field
and Heather drops it off or keeps going
if you're going to ask him to do a
little more complex things I think folks
are worried about that yeah people like
to see what you're going to do at the
next level people like to see you in
that role I mean it's why Justin
Jefferson fell in the draft right that's
because they're saying that role I don't
know if he's going to do that at the
next level that's the same with Jalen
Hyatt as he's playing slot off the line
of scrimmage versus off coverage
offensive line in terms of Mickey Loomis
by the way if you look at how they built
their offensive line Trevor Penning
first round pick in 2022. Andrus Pete
first rounder in 15. Eric McCoy second
rounder in 19 Cesar Ruiz first rounder
and 20. Ryan ramchick first rounder in
17. they take offensive lineman towards
the top of the draft and this is pick
number 40 and usually they say
20 to 40 is where a lot of the meat of
the draft is let's see if they do go
offensive line here they're going Isaiah
initial thoughts what are we thinking
it's a guy I put to them a lot in the
second round of the draft because they
have a type whether it's Cam Jordan
whether it was Marcus Davenport whether
it's Peyton Turner guys they've drafted
highly it is long 260 plus Pounders who
like to collapse the pocket that's just
their MO on the defensive side of the
ball Bosque as you see right there six
foot five 264. four five eight forty
that is built that is tailor-made to
just walk back offensive tackles now the
issues I had with him he's a little bit
stiff what is he going to do when guys
can match his power when he gets to the
NFL level and they can kind of just sit
on that bull rush what's his secondary
move but he's the guy that gets off
blocks really well you saw that by him
setting the Notre Dame career sack
record over the course of his career
there and I think just has a really high
floor I just think his ceiling may be a
little bit limited but if you're the New
Orleans Saints right now just need guys
who can see the football field after
losing what they've lost in recent years
great we're gonna go with a A minus for
that one a minus for foskey uh here's
the thing about foskey first team
All-American a very accomplished player
with a ton of stats he is the first
player Notre Dame history with multiple
seasons of double-digit sacks you said
most sex Notre Dame history more than
Justin Tuck which is pretty darn
impressive what do we think of him
though as a prospect I think I
I don't see that the 458 that you're in
I don't I don't always see it on film oh
God that's the thing that's the thing
for me like there's some guys who play
faster and he's the guy that I think I
don't I think it's whether it's because
he's trying to make sure he's following
all the rules or he's trying to make
sure he's contained or but I don't see
that that get up and go speed I don't
see it from his takeoff I don't see it
from the like I just don't like the Ohio
State tape is tough he couldn't get off
those tackles exactly those are NFL
teams those are and those are both of
them are NFL tackles we're going to see
Delon come off the board here pretty
soon right so for me I look at this pick
I'm gonna give it a B I think that yes I
love the Marcus Davenport comp obviously
but hey this is the guy that he's got to
go he's
I don't know I want to see more I know
he's got a great motor I know he's
obviously got a knack for getting to the
quarterback I know he can collapse the
pocket but I for me I'm going I'm going
b-plus I think that the key for me is
gonna I need to see that four five eight
on the field not just not just in your
straight line speed so Isaiah foskey to
pick double defensive line for the
Saints with Brazil and then foskey it
makes you wonder are we preparing for
Life After Cameron Jordan right drafted
in 2011 it's that would be the end of an
era and one of the best dudes on that
team Isaiah foskey uh the pick there for
the Saints Arizona now on the clock uh
they of course traded back from 33 uh
when the Tennessee Titans moved up to
get will Levis so Arizona again getting
a third round pick next year and now
they are officially on the clock Arizona
their only pick has been Paris Johnson
the offensive tackle out of Ohio State
and I feel like there's a number of
players that are available because he's
all been good players but I feel like
you're Big Board hasn't been touched
other than the mayor yeah I mean so guys
that just came off the board from pick
33 till now that maybe would have made
sense for them Steve Avila you can get
it Osiris Torrance I don't see them as
too different of a prospect uh probably
you know not one of the tight ends they
just drafted one last year maybe
Jonathan Mingo but I don't think wide
receivers that desperate another number
so they're not available
pick us in oh and the Arizona Cardinals
with their second pick on the draft okay
B.J agility okay we're getting a little
bit of a pass rusher run right now
uh we just had a pick Isaiah foskey and
now BJ ojalari First Team all SEC team
captain he was the third defensive end
coming out of Georgia between behind
will Anderson and Miles Murphy uh Scout
says he is an unreal character guy four
over four pressures per game the last
two seasons he gets in the backfield and
the Arizona Cardinals able to pick him
up with their second pick here at 41.
yeah and he's the brother of azizo
jalari former Georgia Edge now New York
Giant second round pick himself and
they're very similar as prospects I mean
they both use their hands extremely well
he probably has as many pass rushing
moves as anyone in this draft class and
that I talked about yesterday he took it
to Broderick Jones He took some of the
better tackles he faced the worry with
them 248 pounds he's kind of below and
lighter than you'd like and I think you
see that in the Run game he can get
worked off the line you see it with him
trying to work speed to power just
inconsistent in that regard are if he
can put on some muscle mass because he's
still a young guy coming out still only
a true Junior who's been playing since
he was a freshman there at LSU he can
put on some muscle mass get into the 250
range work some more power moves to his
game you're getting the impact type of
pass rusher but I do just think that's
the thing that's missing from his game
right now and you may see it get
exacerbated once it gets to the NFL
level so I'm gonna go with an A minus
for this one a minus from Runner Felder
yeah I I think he's a heck of a football
player you know what 18 means right no
that's LSU's number so oh you only get
that if you're special yeah like not
just special good but like special on
and off on and off the field okay that's
that speaks to the that what somebody
mentioned about the character yes so you
only get to wear 18 if you're that dude
like Jacob Hester
um what's what's his name that played
for played for the or played for the
bills corner Trayvon Trayvon uh no
Traders white like you that too gets to
wear 18 at LSU so he's earned that
number it says a lot it means a lot yeah
it's so that's the one that's the thing
that stood out to me and then you see
the effort it's not just that he gets
pressured it's that he get he's giving
you effort he's going to give you effort
look at the violence right there too
trying to knock them sideways so I love
the fact that you're gonna get some
effort look at this that's effort
running through run through run through
keep going he doesn't stop I love the
motor I love the pick I think this is a
great one and again you get one of those
guys that's wearing that number yeah
then you're getting somebody that
absolutely knows what they're doing I'm
going a plus I thought he could be a
first round pick wow uh BJ ogilari
what's so interesting is the Cardinals
traded down for the Texans to move up
and take Will Anderson now they use one
of these picks that they got for ogilari
so they do get their pass rusher and
Jonathan Gannon now taking over in
Arizona or they had when Gannon was with
the Eagles 70 sacks you know they're
going to want to rush the passer uh
Arizona and aljalari and now it is the
Green Bay Packers all right this is your
team here we go just let everybody know
what do you think of the Green Bay
Packers your team getting Luke Musgrave
they had to leave this draft with the
tight end I think everyone and their
mother knew it was going to happen at
some point in this draft passed on the
first round because they obviously like
the valley of Lucas Van Ness but not
here Musgrave is the biggest swing at
the tight end position in this draft
class to me he's the best athlete on
tape you watch that route right there
right there's not another tight end this
draft class that can run away from
safeties the way he did goes down on the
Senior Bowl had the fastest GPS speed of
any tight end in attendance broke 20
miles per hour faster than I think all
but like three wide receivers in
attendance there and he's a well-built
dude six foot six over 250 pounds
linebackers just kind of melt off of him
when he dips a shoulder but my Lord this
dude is raw I think only 47 catches his
entire collegiate career got injured
this past season after two games but in
his first two games over 80 yards in
both a touchdown I just love his
downfield ability if you're drafting a
tight end especially in this Packers
offense with how they use them it's can
you work the seams can you get open on
over routes this is a guy with his speed
with his sort of yak ability which that
is not speaking to whatsoever he can he
can he can win at those areas of the
football field the turf monster gets
everybody sometime what was the uh grade
for that so we're going to go with an a
for that when I had him as the 48th
player on the board he obviously goes
42nd that's right in the range I would
have drafted him uh by the way if you
know if you recognize a last name
Musgrave he is a nephew of Bill Musgrave
uh has played seven years in the NFL
offensive coordinator for 25 years so
football's in his blood what do we think
of him going in the top 45 here makes
sense he's a good football player he's a
project excuse me I need some water
you can take mine I'm good let me get
through this then we get some but no
he's a good football player I'm gonna go
ahead and give it a B plus
I think the key for me in watching him
play is he needs more reps and he's
probably gonna get those in Green Bay
because they need to have him one thing
that's interesting is looking back he is
the first Oregon State tight end to ever
be drafted in the top 100 picks forget a
hundred he's going top 50 but what's
also interesting is no Aaron Rodgers
Packers finally go and they get a weapon
but this is going to be the guy that
Jordan love leans on I would imagine
this is going to be his this is going to
be his favorite Target and it's going to
be easy and fun and good for him to grow
with Jordan love because Jordan love
still has a Long Way to Grow oh yes he
does I will say the one thing that I'm
wary about with this pick yeah you have
Christian Watson Romeo Dobbs both kind
of inconsistent hands-wise Luke Musgrave
had the highest drop rate of any Titan
in this draft and now obviously it's not
such a small sample because it was only
you know 56 I believe catchable targets
but nine drops in this career uh we have
some bad hands there you like this pick
but I like the pick because that's such
a small sample that when you went to the
Senior Bowl I didn't think his hands
were nearly as much of an issue I think
he is strong at the catch point just
some concentration drops and a lot of
those drops were earlier in his career
before kind of his breakout of late
we're at a point too where Darnell
Washington is the next title that we're
waiting to see uh so what's interesting
too is Green Bay that pick that they
just took I believe was it was from the
Jets uh but I believe that was part of
like the Elijah Moore deal so on the
Browns yeah and now now we are up to the
Jets the Jets are on the clock so they
took Will McDonald 15th overall
offensive line they could use just with
all the questions there and there's a
number of tackles uh the chat weighing
in I'd be happy with a wide receiver
here I bet it's a cornerback uh D
lineman they already went Edge
the Arkansas linebacker is also still
there if the Jets wanted to do that but
I think the big question for jets fans
is are we going to get Makai beckton are
we ever going to see what we saw in that
first year right because there's some
other monster tackles available and we
have not seen a center come off the
board and I think it's there's three
guys I really like in the center class
Joe titman from Wisconsin John Michael
Schmitz from Minnesota and Luke whippler
from Ohio State I think three big all
three
tomorrow they can start for you and for
the Jets right now they obviously signed
McGovern he brought him back but a guy
that if you draft one of those three I
think you're probably starting I wonder
if they asked Aaron Rodgers who he
wanted with this pick and they are going
to go wow you nailed it Joe tipman A
Center is gonna come and take and give
snaps right away to Aaron Rodgers in his
rookie year 22 starts for Mr Joe titman
he was a high school stud in Indiana
Indiana Mr Football 102 pancake blocks
and when you go and play at Wisconsin
you are ready for the NFL a weight room
Warrior squats over 6 30 benches over
450. he never played center before 2021
and then he picked it up immediately the
new center for Aaron Rodgers yeah at
that size I think he has guard
versatility six six is huge yeah it's a
big Center not a lot of centers that
height in the NFL but you see him get
off the line with leverage plays low and
his best work is on the move and that's
a fit with what the Jets want to do now
obviously with new offensive coordinator
there Daniel Hackett they run a lot of
stretch zone game he is fantastic at
that and just a guy that's a heck of an
athlete I mean you watch him pull out in
space he's so easy at locating
linebackers I have a little questions
about his balance can get a little top
heavy when you are six six you can get
push pulled by some squattier nose
tackles probably my only concern with
him but I had him as the 50 second
player on the draft board this is right
where I would have drafted him so I'll
probably go with an eight and do you
think he's starting right away I do
think he's starting right away okay what
do you think of this guy I love him the
height is again is a concern because
most guys are six three yeah he's six
six that's three more inches that's
three more inches that somebody can get
up underneath your pads and walk you
back but
this guy's got technique he's got the
ability you see it right there like
that's out there quick that was and that
was a you see how he sold it though yes
he sold it and then went and that's the
way he triggered I love that like that's
we talked about triggering with DBS all
the time yeah you see him right there
working up underneath keeping that pad
level low and then being able to get the
other guy stood up and then use his
Superior strength to put him on his back
here he is on the Move remember you
talked about this when he gets on the
Move he's just clearing the path and now
all of a sudden we get a guy walking
into the end zone uh for me the big key
for me it's not just the value of where
this guy gets picked it's also that
you're getting a starter day one boom a
plus Joe titman and I think I agree with
both of you six six three thirteen and
having that Wisconsin pedigree whether
it's Center whether it's guard they're
gonna be able to play him wherever it is
as the season progresses for an
offensive line that has a lot of
questions in New York but insurance for
Mr Aaron Rodgers for at least the next
two years while Aaron is playing Indiana
Indianapolis Colts are now on the clock
this was part of the trade from 35 I
believe back to 44. I believe that's
where we're at my draft board is that
correct what was that trade what did uh
Detroit went up there that was Sam
laporta yes so they've traded up for San
laporta now Indy they're looking for
their second pick since Anthony
Richardson so what are we thinking here
they could go guard I mean they have
that right guard position burning a hole
in the middle of that offensive line
they could get his teammate you can get
Anthony Richardson's teammate Oh I
thought you were saying Joe titman I was
like cyborg yeah yeah oh Cyrus Osiris
sounds like a guy that was on Conair
Cyrus the virus Cyrus the virus Cyrus
the virus yes sir
they definitely have holes on their own
line they also have holes at cornerback
if we're being honest this is a team
right now starting Isaiah Rogers and
Dallas flowers at corner we know they're
Nickelback Kenny Moore one of the better
nickelbacks in the league and there's a
number of Corners here uh that I think
are are pretty spicy and available that
haven't come off the board yeah I'd be
intrigued by someone like Julius Brent's
here too the Kansas State Corner we'll
see who it is
okay I didn't actually see it I did not
I swear you promise yeah okay because
I've had I've worked with people man
that have lied to me no that one for
years they'd be like I just got a
feeling so you promise I promise okay
because I'm not going through that again
because of what like this back end off
zone is their calling card and Julie's
Branson off Julius Brent's AKA Juju
First Team all Big 12 32 starts 16
passes defended he was at Iowa for three
years and then he went to Kansas State
and when he got to Kansas State that's
where he had his production five of the
six picks Kansas State 11 of his 16 past
defended and he's a large Corner six two
two hundred will work great with Kenny
Moore in the middle yeah with 34-inch
arms wow and this offensive lineman yeah
he's a unique athlete he doesn't have
great speed right
but six six threes three cone yeah but
he can explode in the short area
quickness he's the kind of the inverse
of what you'd expect from a six foot
three Corner usually those guys take a
little bit to build up and then once
they do they have high end speed no with
him he gets there in a hurry so he gets
a lot of ball production simply from
being able to click and close at a
really high level uh
that was the South Carolina Corner who
came out a couple years ago went to the
Dallas Cowboys okay six foot four not a
lot of guys that big though at the
cornerback position so not a lot to
choose from when you're thinking of guys
with 34-inch arms at corner but again
for this scheme he's going to be able to
play through wide receiver to the ball
and that's when he was at his best he
really wasn't that great in press
coverage okay watch him against Quentin
Johnston against the two match-ups they
had this past season and Johnson kind of
ate his lunch a little bit at the line
of scrimmage but when he's off when he
can see what's in front of him he can
make a lot of plays on the football so a
great scheme fit there for Indy we're
gonna go with an a I like that it one of
the hardest workers on the team since he
got there Felder that's what they're
saying listen I'm glad that you
mentioned the Zone part of this because
that is what he's going to do Gus
Bradley that's where he's playing well
here's the thing this is this is the
beauty of it right they play zone at
Iowa three years of playing Zone in Iowa
they play zone to Kansas State because
they don't have the horses to match up
with guys but I love the way he
triggered their little slippage but he
still got there and stopped the first
down not afraid to make a tackle the guy
that I was gonna uh that he reminded me
of a little bit especially when you talk
about seeing through the receiver to the
quarterback was Kevin King and um maybe
not the most favorable one no it's not
the most playable struggles are solid
you talk about a guy that's six foot
three with long arms I know he didn't
pan out but coming out this yes I've had
a lot of those same feelings I just need
he just needs to get it put it together
and have it worked out so I'm gonna go
b-plus here
what I like is I'm just looking at the
two guys they've taken
big physical strong players Anthony
Richardson Julius Brent's uh great
measurement and again second the combine
the short shuttle and in the three cone
the trade the lions are on the clock
that means we have an intra NFC North
interdivision trade the Packers were up
here Packers had 42 and 45 part of it
was because of the Aaron Rodgers trade
so the Packers are trading with the
Detroit Lions who have been insanely
active uh thus far they went Sam laporta
they trade they they went up had had him
in 34 and then they move up from 48 here
to 45.
what could it be for you I don't want to
keep bringing them up but I love Osiris
Torrance here he was a guy that the
right guard position
yeah but if you put him next to penne
Sewell that is a mess Mammoth right side
that is a crushing double team every
time they want to get together for a
baseball so
that's the one that I I thought you know
if they were at pick 18 and moved back a
little in the first round was in play
for them there
I'd be excited if I'm a lions fan and
that's the Picker but we shall see yeah
we'll see I think that I I think
Torrance is a great choice I'm looking
at this and I'm also wondering when
is going to go because I know that a lot
of people had him as a possible first
round pick yeah yep so it was Brian
branches so was Josh down yeah so this
is going to be interesting all right the
pick is in hey there we go that's
interesting
this is a team that went out there and
they got
um
CJ Gardner Johnson and now the Lions go
and the value was too good that they had
to go up and get him Brian Branch the
pick for the Detroit Lions here trading
up to 45 the safety out of Alabama
I know that you had him top 20 I believe
yeah 18th on a draft board I think this
guy is just a super high floor and I get
safety being devalued an especially a
guy that runs a 458 like Branch where
he's not your center fielder that can
really shut down Windows on the back end
but around the line of scrimmage or from
the slot where he played at Alabama
there was not better tape that I saw in
college football last year this guy is a
tremendous tackler only four missed
tackles on 174 attempts his entire
career I mean that rate 2.3 percent was
the missed tackle unlike anything I've
seen it and not like the prototypical
tackler either he's only six foot he's
only 190 pounds he's nothing too special
physically imposing but the way he plays
the game of football at such a high
level the way he sees it now the Lions
have a loaded defensive backfield that
they got options you know they got
flexibility on the back end with who
they can put out there different
Personnel packages Lions had a little
slow start on day one but they're making
up for it on day two here in my eyes a
plus pick uh let me read a few of this
filter but before you go he allowed only
one catch of over 20 yards All Season he
only had three fewer tackles for losses
than Will Anderson he had a 68-yard punt
return so he's going to do it on special
teams as well he played that star role
for Saban that make a Fitzpatrick role
and he's the only player in all of
college football last year with over 90
tackles over 14 tackles for losses and
two interceptions he can do everything I
know you love him I love him he was my
favorite player in the draft he was my
number one favorite yeah wow yeah he's
the number one he's my number one
defensive back I've said it already on
the show yep he's not the best corner I
call him Tyrion Matthew I think he has
the ability to be a gadget player if you
want to like don't use this guy like
you're going to use some sort of
traditional Corner don't use him like
you would use a traditional safety move
him around as a piece use him to create
your own defensive mismatches and I
think that's what Dan Campbell wants to
do let him create the mismatch let him
be the problem that they have to solve
let him be the riddle that they're
working on and I think that's going to
be the interesting make it be said that
the offensive line
the wide receivers the running backs
quarterback especially they got to look
around and say 14's right here 14's
right here that's what you have to do
this is an A plus pick for me no doubt
at all I love this kid I think he's
super special I mean we've seen guys
that come out of that we've seen
obviously Mika Fitzpatrick do it we've
seen uh going all the way back Lynn
Landing College started his career as a
star yeah and like these got that
position teaches you a lot about
football I I we have the next pick oh
this is a good one my only question was
I just hope they don't use them at
corner because Detroit does need Corners
they better not and that's the only
thing I'm worried about uh Patriots
taking Keon white the pick for the Pats
that's another guy that I think was
mainly seen to go earlier they go
Christian Gonzalez in round one and now
they're going Keon white uh third Team
all ACC 11 sacks seven and a half last
season this is a kid that came out of
high school had no offers and was like
I'm gonna go to the military and then he
ended up playing tight end at Old
Dominion
[Music]
and now he's going to the Patriots Yeah
a unique Prospect in a number of ways
like you said two a few years old
dominion transfers uh pandemic year
comes back hurts his foot in 2021 so you
really only got like one year of major
college ball from him and he's up and
down I mean he's his production was just
okay he is a power player though 285
pounds that's the New England brings it
every snap High motor physical dude
his GPS signs at the Senior Bowl were
off to charts as well he's a guy who can
legitimately track down and Hawk running
backs in space that's not why you're as
you see right there that's I didn't
actually even know that was gonna happen
but there you go but that's not why you
draft a guy but he has unique athletic
gifts to grow into the only worry I had
with a guy like that and why he was
lower on my board I had him 77th on the
board is because he's 24 years old
already how much development are you
going to get out of a guy at that age
and then when he did go test at his pro
day did not live up to the freak moniker
that everyone kind of had build them up
to be all season so with that being said
I'll probably go with a B I believe he
was so well regarding this draft that he
was invited to the draft but also that
6-4 285 I mean that's a New England
Patriots defensive end all the time
bingo that's what I love about him he is
he can play a true five tech and if you
can play two five tech you can play for
Bill Belichick this is a guy look at him
here
Crashing Down On The Edge violent hands
get off of me and then you see the
effort the effort I mean that's Trey
flowers yep Bingo yeah that's what you
want to see you want to see that effort
and he gives it to you every play and
look at that he's still got to work on
his long legs but he gets it you can see
you can see he's almost there he's
almost there and that's what I love
about him is he's almost there and
that's a good thing to have in a second
round pick he's almost there he makes
plays he almost makes plays and then he
helps other people make plays that's
what you want out of this guy so for me
and look shout out to Georgia Tech how
about that they got two guys basically
they got two guys got that for as bad as
they were I'm gonna give him an a they
got two guys because I'm gonna count
Gibbs for them they got two guys picked
in the first in the first two rounds and
I don't think anybody saw that coming
when they watched Georgia Tech play this
year unbelievable uh this kid's story
too I just want to add one more layer to
it so no offers out of high school uh
goes uh hey I think I'm gonna join the
military then he goes to Old Dominion
Place tight end a little bit goes to
Georgia Tech gets covered messes him up
like you were saying Renner why while he
was at Old Dominion though he delivered
pizzas for dominoes for an entire year
and now he's going to play from for Bill
frickin Belichick he's going to be
motivated Christian Gonzalez is going to
be motivated the Patriots are loading up
I worried about him going to a spot
where they saw him as like a a true end
a 403 defensive end this is the correct
spot he is going to be a plug and play
run Defender that you hope develops as a
pass rusher but if he doesn't it doesn't
really matter in New England with how
they treat their defensive lineman those
four or five texts usually he's
perfectly what they want for that
defense we are officially a pick and a
half ahead of the television broadcast
so they're doing Brian Branch we just
got done the next one and now we're
doing the Washington Commander second
pick they shocked Everybody by going
Emanuel Forbes in the first round they
go back to defensive backfield jartavius
Martin the pick here renner's face was
that of a little bit shock why is that
he was a late Riser I mean similar to
Devin Witherspoon in that slow start to
his career but then this past season the
tape was just different and he is a
high-end athlete four four six forty
there as you as you see over 40 inch
vertical explosive and he's a guy you
want around the line of scrimmage played
slotted in Illinois and I think that's
where he slots in here with the
commanders he's a guy you want
shutting down screens like that taking
on offense alignment in the running game
taking on running backs in the hole he's
very physical tackler one of the best
tacklers at the safety position in this
draft class and again for the team we're
talking about that's playing more off
Zone more where a guy can see what's in
front of him yep great fit for that
defense maybe a little higher than I
would have gone just for the value
perspective because I see you know big
difference between a guy like him and a
guy like Brian Branch who just came off
the board in terms of certainty with
which I know they're going to be good
players in the next level but still the
potential for this guy really high and
if you're looking for a slot not too
many better prospects in that role in
this draft class so I'm going to go with
the B plus here uh 14 passes defended
last season uh 30 passes defended for
his career his combine numbers were all
number one for safeties in these regards
a 144 10 yard split a 44 inch vertical
an 11-1 broad jump the kid can fly he's
great he's I love him like to me some
people might look at him and think he's
a little bit undersized but the reality
for me is I when I watch him play I see
a guy that's violent there is true
violence in his game he gets there with
bad intentions he does want to make you
hurt he does want you to feel it he does
want you to remember his name this guy
is really really good like I mean come
on he'll bang on you and I think that's
the beauty that's why Iowa excuse me
that's why watching Illinois was kind of
was kind of fun this year because this
is a team that hey they figure something
out and what they figured out was we got
some good guys in the secondary that can
make plays look at those ball skills
that we saw right here that's hard to do
for me I'm giving it an a I like this
player I like the way that he plays he
is so hyper focused on doing what he's
what's being asked of him he doesn't
make many mistakes he also doesn't take
bad steps and that's the part that means
a lot because if you don't take bad
steps and you run a 4-4 that means
you're gonna have an opportunity to get
a pbu or get an interception uh by the
way he goes by Quan his first name is
jartavius but he goes by Quan two other
notes about him that I like trade bucks
are on the clock kid was dunking in
middle school and it makes sense because
he got a 44 inch vertical the other
thing
he was the team's Barber which means
everybody trusts you trust you like you
reliable
because you ain't touching my hair no
quad no unless you got the skills with
the Clippers yep but it's interesting so
they go Forbes and then jartavius Martin
secondary secondary for Jack Del Rio's
crew we know they invest in the d-line a
few years ago now they're doing it on
the back end Tampa Bay moving up yep why
what are we thinking so they jumped
Pittsburgh here that was all they moved
up yeah they moved up they moved from 50
to 48. I'm intrigued I wonder if
I gotta stop
there we go wow you know what and that's
a guy that I saw could be possibly going
in the first round and they need it
because their offensive line has been a
mess North Dakota state has been
producing a ton of offensive line
prospects these recent years and they do
it right now one more time Mr mock the
big time Maller out there in North
Dakota State Cody mock first team
All-American the offense of lineman of
the year for FCS a True North Dakota
this kid was bailing hay look at his
face okay on your screen is he missing
teeth oh yeah
I incred I just look at that picture
Cody mock what are they getting in Tampa
Bay they're getting the most athletic
interior offensive lineman in this draft
class uh watching him locate linebackers
in space is a joy to watch and
especially against the competition he
was going against once he got his hands
on him he was Barrel rolling over the
top of them they obviously have the knee
drafted Luka deck in a similar range
last season to be your left guard this
guy I think slots in at Right Guard and
you got a nasty interior line pairing
him with Ryan Jensen is unfair because
Jensen's going to teach him the ropes
about how to get away with that little
extra at the whistle not get flagged for
it and this guy I think the sky's the
limit in terms of potential on the
interior for him obviously played left
tackle only at North Dakota State but
the way they run their offense with so
much power so many tight splits and so
many tight ends attached to him it
really is close to what he's going to be
doing at guard in the NFL so not a
massive transition the Bucks are in a
place where they can wait two or three
years on a guy to really figure it out
because his work and pass Pro bit of an
issue saw the Senior Bowl even saw that
on tape at North Coast State needs to
use his hands a little bit better needs
to get a Little Bit Stronger because he
gained 80 pounds over the course
tight end 10 more pounds of muscle on
this guy and you're getting a guy with
Pro Bowl type of potential at guard
great we're gonna go with an a for that
one I saw you had Danny Pinter as a comp
love it this guy can play he is super
talented the big thing I love about
watching him and when you throw his tape
on what you're going to see is dominance
at his level and that's the part that's
important when you're going down and
getting a smaller School Prospect you
want to see them be absolutely dominant
at their level and there we just saw
them lined up with that tied in on the
outside of them that's like having
another that's like him moving down the
garden but he's dominant at his level
look he's just violent and he wants to
finish the off look at that
like these guys no one wants him to be
on top of them yeah like would you want
him on top of you I wouldn't you're
right him next to Jensen is two ugly
dudes that are just gonna be gnarly yeah
dude it's gonna be fun so for me this is
a this is a no-brainer uh this is a guy
again you said you've seen people have
him go in early I think that this from
for me let's go ahead and go let's go
and go a plus he's he's a heck of a
football player and again he did the he
he understood the assignment when you
are coming from a smaller school you
have to be straight up dominant yeah to
go early in the draft and we've seen
kids from North Dakota state made the
transition by the way
um our cracks production staff went and
got an even better picture take a look
at this man the Floetry is effortless
and the Gap is wide Michael Strahan is
jealous of that I don't think that's it
that's a two teeth right there that
looks like it might be three teeth
missing I actually that might be the two
front one and the right one I knocked my
two front teeth out and I looked a lot
like that could you pull him out right
now no they're veneers now thank
a little side action here I knocked him
out and had him get him replaced right
before the pandemic I had to do the
draft show during the pandemic with no
front teeth I put a retainer in I put
gum in to make it look like I had two
front teeth but I was walking around
looking like Cody mock for about a month
so all the dentists were seeing that cat
right there takes me back takes you back
he's the kind of guy that's going to
move the needle in terms of Jersey sales
I mean he truly will uh Pittsburgh
Steelers they got jumped just now for
Cody mock but they're staking Keanu
Benton I thought he'd be a good fit with
the Jets okay Connor Hughes listen
you're breaking news
I know that you don't even realize that
what you're doing but they go Broderick
Jones they go Joey Porter Jr and now
they're going the D lineman out of
Wisconsin Keanu Benton uh what are we
thinking of this pick I like it yeah I
I'm a fan I I didn't think he'd last
this long because of how weak this DT
class is I I had him right in this range
on the draft board I had him at 50 five
on the draft board obviously goes 49 so
I the value is right there I heard his
Senior Bowl practices were insane the
best DT at the Senior Bowl in my opinion
he can win with Quicks he can win with
power he plays a little loose have a
little questions about his balance can
end up on the floor a little bit but
Pittsburgh Steelers had done an
excellent job of developing defensive
linemen over the years but they've kind
of not invested enough in that position
obviously after Stephan Tuit has injury
issues has to retire haven't found that
other guy to put next to Cameron Hayward
tried last year with the Marvin Liao
who's a similar type of interior player
that's kind of a developmental Prospect
this guy's a little bit more NFL ready I
think his power is his calling card and
it's something that's going to fit in
really nicely with how the Steelers have
built their defensive line over the
years so with that I'll give it an ah
I like him this kid can play the big
thing for me is where do they play him
at because you see 64 309 where do you
play this kid he played nose at
Wisconsin but he's really truly more
nose and eight those are the big thing
for me I want to know where you're going
to play them that's the only question
mark I have you see him there trying to
work this Stutter Step doing a little
stutter step dancing out there showing a
little bit of balance so
I like him I think that this is one of
those picks where when you watched him
play when I watched him play at least I
always knew I was always knew he was
going to generate push you weren't going
to be able to get stuff done in the
middle of that Wisconsin interior and
obviously between him the linebackers
then you have what herbig uh coming off
the edge like this is one of those
things where they were built they were
built solid up front and he was a big
part of that situation so for me I'm
gonna go ahead I'm gonna give it a B
plus I love I like this pick I think
it's a good one
um and the Steelers are gonna so they
got to continue to build up we hit on it
yesterday or we'll hit on it again today
I'm sure we're gonna hit on again later
this team they got a lot of work to do
they got to catch up with the Bengals
yes and I know Mike Tomlin hasn't had a
losing record but that also they hadn't
been to the Super Bowl in a minute
either uh the Steelers came in I had
with three major needs offensive line
defensive line and Corner Broderick
Jones Keanu Benton Joey Porter Jr they
addressed all three of those and all
three playing high level football I
think could be impacts in week uh number
one Green Bay Packers are now on the
clock I feel like they have been part of
a number of moves thus far the Green Bay
Packers chat they're one pick that far
that they actually made in this round
Luke Musgrave the tight end and now
oh
Jaden Reed so they go another weapon on
the offensive side of the ball Aaron
Rodgers don't get jealous it's okay
Jaden read the pick for the Green Bay
Packers here in round number two Jaden
reads uh two times second Team all Big
Ten averaged over 14 yards per catch uh
looks like he's got some size there as
well yeah so Jaden Reed
511 187 he's one of the best route
runners in this draft class he's been
productive ever since early on his
career was a freshman starting at I
believe Central Michigan and their
leading receiver that season transfers
obviously to Michigan State which
probably wasn't the best spot for him
considering Michigan State's quarterback
situation he was missed a lot on tape
had to adjust to a lot of off-target
passes but at that size he's great in
contested situations as you see right
there his ball skills are tremendous but
does have some concentration drops on
tape that I worry a little bit about as
we're talking about last pick with Luke
Musgrave being concentration drops kind
of guy not a lot of reliable wide
receivers there but a guy who can
separate on his own I think he was a
better slot probably Prospect than he
was outside where he worked at Michigan
State and considering now what the
Packers have all around jobs outside I
think so that's where he goes still the
value for me I had him more as a
borderline day two guy so because of
that we're going to go a little bit of a
B minus here but they address they give
weapons to Jordan love had to do it and
they go ahead and I watch a lot of
Michigan State football my wife went to
Michigan State her cousin was just
starting left tackle at Michigan State
I've I've seen this kid play a lot of
football I like him he reminds me a
little bit of Steve Smith plays with the
chip on his shoulder listen he's a he's
a shorter guy at 511 but look at these
catches up in traffic I can do it he
plays with a little violence in his game
but don't worry about me I got this over
you against Ohio State yeah like this is
good against Maryland's defense he gets
an open he gets finally gets a good ball
but this is one of those guys that for
me great body control the reason I say
Steve Smith is because when you watch
him play and I'm gonna I'm gonna go
ahead and give this an A but the big
thing for me when I watch him play I see
a guy that plays bigger than he is
plays with a little bit of violence
plays with a chip on his shoulder and
that's the thing that made agent 89 so
good was playing with that chip on his
shoulder and I see some of that in Jaden
Reef all right so Jaden Reed so two
offensive players for Green Bay at this
part of the draft we are now up to the
Miami Dolphins this is their first pick
in the draft losing their first rounder
pick because they were trying to get Tom
Brady and Sean Payton uh and that
happened but this is their first pick
I'm just looking right now can we see
the big board and just see who are the
best players available uh on Mike
renner's big borders we're getting to a
team of the Miami Dolphins who have not
selected anybody thus far uh Josh so
we're starting to get rid of the elite
guys Brian Branch I feel like was the
big one uh but we got some wide
receivers I'm a little bit shocked that
Osiris and Dewan are still on the board
at this point I thought they would go
and of course out of borrower anybody
else that you're a little bit uh
stunned by I'm I'm not stunned but in
this spot I'm a little intrigued by Josh
Downes I think for Miami losing Trend
sure Fields just completing this
receiving core with dynamism all around
I mean that's how they want to build
that's how Mike mcdano wants his offense
to look like is just three guys that you
can't stick with any of them and you got
two already Josh Downs would make that
three just give to a option after option
that's funny the first thing I thought
was draft one of those offensive lineman
and protector yeah you can do one of
three things
get your defense offensive line get a
weapon they already have Jaylen waddle
Jalen Ramsey chiming in Detroit is
having an MF is having an MF and draft
I that was what was so interesting about
Micah is these current players that are
really like watching every single pick
and know every player yep
crazy yeah it is
who would you go here if you were Miami
probably Osiris Osiris yeah I go Cyrus I
think that um the big thing for me you
gotta you gotta Shore up this offensive
line
they've got I mean nothing on here makes
me think that they can't he can't beat
them out is there a tight end that would
make sense right here they lost
Darnell Washington kind of fills both
roles as a blocker and a tight end
Tucker craft from South Dakota State
also makes sense but
cam Smith you love this guy they did
lose Byron Jones and so that makes sense
to go I love this guy cam Smith the
first selection for the Miami Dolphins
they are going cam Smith the cornerback
out of South Carolina uh cam Smith
started 19 games 24 past defended uh he
had 14 passes defended uh in 2021 just
six in 2022 has played nickel has played
outside only issue a lot of flags double
digits in 2022 but he's a physical dude
that fits what Vic fangio is going to
want to do down there precisely I mean
this is a Vic Van Gogh pick through and
through the comp that I had for him was
Kareem Jackson who just was you know one
of the better safeties in the league
when he was in Denver with Vic fangio
and a corner to safety convert and
that's what I saw in cam Smith I just
didn't think he had quite the elite
twitch that you want of an outside
corner to really do a stick with the guy
man coverage dude but he plays the game
at a really high level when they face
Tennessee they put him in the slot to
try to deal with Jalen Hyatt knowing he
was their best defensive back
instinctual dude 15 pass breakups and
four interceptions the past two seasons
there's only 70 targets so he gets his
hands on a lot of footballs I think you
put him around the line of scrimmage and
he's going to be a guy that you are
going to love in that role I think maybe
he could even be one of your two high
safeties uh on that back end you're just
loading up now on versatile defensive
backs in that secondary this Dolphins
defense is going to look a lot different
than the one that's a little bit of a
liability last season uh great a pick
zavian Howard Jalen Ramsey and cam Smith
as three defensive backs back there in
Miami
yeah of course I mean playing in the
playing in the slot he's good the guys
got quick great quick touch great quick
twitch and he has the ability to make
every play I Don't Mind penalties of
aggression I truly don't there's a
humongous difference between penalties
of aggression and penalties of the
inspiration desperate thank you that's
the word I'm looking for penalties of
desperation where you're grabbing trying
to hang on because you're getting your
behind whoop so I love the fact that
he's able to trigger come downhill stop
this first down make a play get him down
on the ground
so that's what I love about this pick
that's what I love about this guy I
threw in JC horn said well you guys two
guys coming from the same physical
defense if you're talking about him
switching to safety I totally can
understand that I see where he has come
the link the link
so for me this is an A plus pick I
thought he was a first runner as a
corner if you're going to get him in the
in the second round and you're gonna
convert them to safety I still think
that's a good move all right cam Smith
another versatile defensive back
Seattle's on the clock Devin Witherspoon
Jackson Smith and jigba and they're
picking the second round was Derek Hall
they've gone two defense one offense and
now you love this guy I don't know if
they need this pick but Zach charbonnet
the running back for UCLA is headed to a
Seattle Seahawks team that just took
Kenneth Walker last year in the second
round Chardonnay First Team all Pac-12
lead Pac-12 and rushing nearly 1400
yards 14 touchdowns uh this is a kid
played two seasons at Michigan school
record for rushing touchdowns as a
freshman then he went to play for Chip
Kelly and his work ethic according to
chip is second to none I just don't know
if Seattle needed this pick yeah that's
that's a head scratcher they do like a
back like a multiple backfield yeah I
mean they draft a Kenneth Walker when
they still had Rashad Penny now they
draft him but these guys I mean you're
gonna have a two-headed backfield for
the next four years the thing I think
loving about Chardonnay though and why I
was so high in him and why have him you
know Army three in this draft class is
his Bell cow ability I don't think he
needs to come off the field on Pass
Downs I think he can play all three
Downs some of the best Vision some of
the best contact balance short area
Quicks for a bigger well-sized running
back weighed in over 220 pounds at his
pro day and he's gonna run hard snap
after snap I I think now if you're the
Seattle Seahawks you have a two-headed
monster once Kenneth Walker comes off
the field defenses can't just relax and
say oh they're going to pass no Zack
sharp and I can beat you too so we're
gonna go with a c though because I just
the value at this point there's still
other solar picks that you could go with
like stroller positions you could go
with on a roster that could need them so
they could have bolstered that offensive
line they could have gotten picks
otherwear Chardonnay you talk about Bell
cow reliable Felder 565 carries two
fumbles so he's not putting the ball on
the turf he doesn't put the ball on the
ground the thing I love about him is he
runs hard everything is downhill
everything is downhill and he's going to
make you hurt and you see it here look
brakes tackles breaks tackles breaks
tackles and then you see a little bit of
that speed that he's got to go all the
way to the end zone like I love that
about him great balance too balance
after contact balance when he gets
turned around even great balance in that
little stutter step and he gets to the
nose for the End Zone ran a four five
three I'm not worried about his his
speed because at the end of the day once
you get sucked up in there he's going to
be able to get away from you because
you're going to be too worried about
what angle you take to tackle him so
that he does not Bowl you over so for me
I like this pick a lot I know it's not a
position of need in theory you like the
player but I like the player a lot so
I'm gonna go b-plus I like what he did
at Michigan I like what he did what do
you go to Thousand Oaks High School
maybe yeah like I've liked him for a
long time charbonne ain't mentored by
DeSean Foster at UCLA one of my favorite
running backs Seattle literally I love
that guy from Carolina Panthers
Seattle's like the dude in your fantasy
league that drafts like a lot of tight
ends and then after the draft is like
who wants one like as an Eagles fan I'm
like you didn't need that pick we could
have used that running back uh Chicago
they've had one pick thus far and it was
offensive lineman Darnell Wright and now
they're going defensive tackle Javon
Dexter so they are going in the trenches
thus far this was the pick that they got
as part of the roquan Smith trade and my
guy here Mr Dexter uh higher higher
ranked recruit out of high school than
Jalen Carter which is insane because he
didn't start playing football until his
junior year of high school very durable
38 games in the last three years for the
Florida Gators it makes sense for
Chicago given their needs they need a
three attack desperately for that
defensive line and they need anything on
the defensive line truthfully he has the
potential to be an impact dude in that
regard six six three ten you see the
four eight eight four eight at that size
moving and he can get off the Linus when
he gets off the line of scrimmage he has
dominant dominant reps he was a guy who
a year ago you know when you do those
way too early mock drafts he was the
first rounder his sophomore tape was
pretty darn good Junior tape not nearly
as good his get off the line of
scrimmage is probably the worst get off
I saw on this defensive line class it
truly like you see there just waiting he
just does not time the snap well at all
there was a rep against Kentucky where
they didn't even block him and he still
didn't even get to will Levis holding
the ball three seconds he just does not
have that killer instinct that I like
that's why I had him a lot lower down
the board but the potential in this
athlete is high and if you're Chicago
you got to take some swings like this
some swings for the fences so I don't
hate it but I'm gonna go with the B
minus just because I really don't think
his tape this past year warranted this
high is he run stopper what is his best
ability I I want him to be a run stopper
because they were 31st against the run
last year and 32nd in sacks how is he
going to help fix that I think he can do
both here's the thing this is what I
wrote I want to make sure I get this
right he's a quality light pick as a guy
with an athletic enough to take to kick
to five but I wanted to play two to two
or three that's what I wanted to be two
or three inside he's so tall yes but it
reminds me a little bit of a Sean
Robinson a guy that could go out and
make plays he could play the five for
sure he could play the five but he has
to get stronger at the point of attack
as you mentioned his get off has to get
better and we see him right here like he
just you can't have your feet stop that
long when the ball is snapped and that's
the thing that makes us a little bit of
a lower value pick for me even though
the ceiling is so high the potential for
what he can be is so high we've seen
flashes of it now we need to see it all
the time because he's got the ability to
really go out and make plays so for me
when I look at this and it's time for me
to give this pick a grade I'm gonna go C
plus because you're betting on potential
but at the end of the day the reality is
is you got to see it more you got to see
it flash more you got to see it more
often and that's what we got that's what
we're waiting to see out of our guy uh
Dexter and he also has a weird belt so
he's so tall six six when you're playing
as you know close to the ball as he does
it's hard to hold up against double
teams when you're that tall but then he
has short arms he has 32 and a quarter
inch arms so he's not like a six six and
I can just keep you at Bay he's like a
six six and I gotta get under you or
else I'm in trouble so that's that's why
I have worries about him that even if he
does improve his get off even if he does
improve some stuff you still could see
issues with him in his size yeah gervon
Dexter by the way I was looking his 10
yard split just that get off a 1-7 and
you know the elite athletes are in that
one five one six so one seven goes to
what you guys were saying but part of
that roquan Smith trade here is the
recent picks uh I'm seeing 2D lineman
and an edge so again we're still seeing
that run on front seven a safety and a
corner a Cody mock I think was the one
there that we were waiting for but
Chardonnay I believe is the shock of of
these here mainly because the team I
think the value makes a little bit of
sense the team is the shock yeah not a
lot of like guys where it's like oh they
all have a role immediately all these
guys until you get to charbonne and it's
just like wow he might play he might get
like 50 carries actually you know just
what we saw at a walker I mean
especially in the playoffs uh Chargers
are up
they uh their first round pick was
Quentin Johnson the big wide receiver
one of your favorites from TCU they have
knees at defensive line they still have
needs at tight end do they go with the
big man out of Georgia here which would
fit some offensive line blocking needs
as well as a pass catcher what are we
thinking here for the Chargers
doesn't matter don't think it's coming
at you live the pick is in
USC defensive tackle Thule tuyapuluto
I'm gonna have to get that right on the
second try
Tui Tui poodle there you go
defensive lineman USC
going to a Chargers team that has really
needed to add size up front for years
truly Tui pulotu what do we think here
Renner he is very productive at a young
age right 13 and a half sacks last
season going kind of on the outside to
the interior only 266 pounds though is
kind of the problem there because a lot
of his interior reps at 206 pounds just
aren't going to come to fruition in the
NFL he has to be an edge and he's not a
super high-end athlete but the guy gets
rushing the passer as you see right here
he can knows how to set up offensive
lineman knows how to Pace this rush and
then when he gets into contact knows how
to use his hands to give him a little
space to get to the quarterbacks and he
finishes so well love has been for a big
dude see him there walking guys back in
the pocket because he can sink into
contact the way he does and a note on
him won't turn 21 until September one of
the youngest players in the entire draft
class I think he's ascending I do just
think he gets to this point in draft
because he's not a high-end athlete but
a guy who probably has a high floor
because of the way he plays the game of
football he a grade we can go with an A
minus for this lead college football in
13 and a half sacks 22 tackles for lost
Felder second the nation let me just
read you his family members okay his
brother Marlon was a defensive lineman
at USC sixth round pick by The Eagles
his cousin telenoa hufanga just was an
All-Pro safety for the 49ers his cousin
fili mawala a second round pick at
defensive tackle it is in his blood and
now he is going staying in California
and going to Los Angeles Chargers yeah I
think the cool thing here uh Juan very
incredible yeah but the other part that
I really like the thing I like about his
game because I don't know where the
Chargers are going to play him yes
because I don't think he's really a five
technique I don't think he is so what
are we looking at we're looking at him
realistically he's going to be backing
up but abosa abosa Mack which that's a
great spot for him to be in that gives
him a chance to rush with his hand
standing up or if it's a passing down he
can come with us and they just lost Kyle
Van Noy so maybe he takes a little bit
of that role bingo so I look at what
he's able to do
I it's not that he is it's not that he
isn't a high-end athlete he said he he's
a big time motor guy that makes up for
it and he plays with such great
anticipation
anticipation and the setups that he has
are great so what he's doing and we saw
it when they rolled the b-roll for years
we saw him set up that Washington State
guy guess what he didn't have to be the
best athlete if what he's going to do is
set that guy up and then make him look
silly with his head down in the dirt
like he's an ostrich so for me I look at
this I think it's a B plus a little bit
early but certainly someone that at the
end of the day he's going to be a
contributor like third down third and
seven plus third and eight plus put him
in the game with the rest of those guys
enter your little racer package and
let's go all right so Thule the pick
there I believe Detroit had the next
pick they've traded it to Kansas City
the Chiefs are on the clock right now
Kansas City their one pick was uh Felix
the pass rusher and now they are going
is it Rashi rice yeah Rasheed rice out
of SMU they lost a lot of wide receivers
in Kansas City this off season and
Rasheed rice is going to have to come in
a second team All-American First Team
all AAC and a team captain for SMU you
said oh yeah Felder with the fist pump
what do we know about this guy
productive bigger a little bigger dude
you know I'm talking about a class
that's a lot of small guys he's six foot
one over 200 pounds with a six foot five
wingspan and his body control is his
like calling card trait the guy can make
plays outside of his frame with ease he
can run after the catch for a bigger
wide receiver
go up and get it 41 inch vertical 10
foot 8 bra jump doesn't have great
straight line speed not a pure separator
at the position but there are high-end
reps on his tape that I'm just like this
guy can be a dude at the next level it's
just the consistency aspect you see reps
where he'll get locked down at the line
of scrimmage by some you know Army
Corners there some lower level of
competition Corners that I just wanted a
little bit more consistency from them
but he has the traits he has the
physical ability of a number one or
number two type of wide receiver he can
start in the NFL and especially for the
Chiefs team that's really kind of
piecemealing It kind of going you know a
bunch of different options in that
offense no real number one guy outside
of Kelsey I think he fits right in that
rotation of what they've done in recent
years so I'm going to go with an A minus
for that yeah Felder that was gonna be
my question for you they lose Juju they
lose me call and right now the starting
three wide receivers are Valdez Scanlon
cadarius Tony and Sky Moore is this kid
going to see the field right away yeah
absolutely he's incredibly productive
huge numbers and he has the ability to
just I think he can I think he can run
every route he has the ability to get
separation he has the ability to
realistically make sure make contested
catches and I just think that
yes the system helped him get open yes
the comeback routes to the back shoulder
Fades and all those things they're not
going to work as well in the NFL he's
not going to be wide open like that like
he is against North Texas but at the end
of the day what I see in reishi rice is
a guy his I see a guy who understands
the assignment who knows what he's
supposed to be doing who
work to carry that team at SMU he was a
he was like I mean he was most of the
offense with what he was able to do from
a number standpoint from a from an
ability standpoint I'm going to go with
an A minus here he was one of my
receivers that I really liked a lot and
he was one of my guys that I thought had
an opportunity to really be like to show
up huge as a big part of your team early
I don't know if I'm allowed to say this
so I'm texting with Mahomes right now
and it's like you like this guy and he
says I threw with him in Dallas and he
said you know I put my input on all
offensive guys I know you do that's
that's part of the reason why I love my
homes is he's not one of these
quarterbacks that's like I'll see in the
off season he's in there talking to
vichko and this is the guy that I want
similar thing that happened with Sky
Moore if you remember that yeah probably
also why he was throwing around with Zay
Pat worked out with this guy threw with
him in Dallas and he said I want this
guy and you get him he's going to play
very early on Rasheed rice the new web
weapon for Pat Chicago who did Chicago
just trade with
I believe Jacksonville so Chicago moving
up about five spots six spots uh with
Jacksonville
Tyrique Stevenson why did you put your
hands up like that that's a good pick
because they needed wide receiver or
excuse me cornerback here the Bears kind
of hitting through all their needs kind
of just doing the tour to need here uh
take me through Tyreke Stevens so he's
the guy who uh
press outside corner I think he was the
best in my opinion Corner that we saw at
the Senior Bowl his kind of ability to
re-route from a pure man alignment is as
good as it gets in the draft class he
sees when wide receivers are going to
break off the routes he sees when
they're going to Throttle Down and he
matches them accordingly now I think he
has some versatility but he started his
career off at Georgia and he made a
little bit of a miscalculation shall we
say because after the 2020 season he was
a starter there but he was starting the
slot and wanted to play outside
transfers to Miami misses out on two
national championships but gets his
chance to play outside corner there a
lockdown type of defender on the outside
uh
how he fits into this defense obviously
they're trying to load up on Corners I
think he starts day one on the outside
for them that's what I saw from him on
tape I did not think he would last this
long I thought he was going to go early
in the second round I had him as the
44th best player in this draft and I
think he's a better Prospect than Tyler
Gordon who they drafted a season ago who
really struggled as a rookie so if
they're debating between the two to
start I think he might usurp him so
what's the grade we're gonna go with an
A plus grade there wow part of the
reason he transferred so he's from Miami
and then he ended up going to Miami he
got homesick he didn't like what was
happening down there with Georgia his
mom his mom told him I want you to get
out of Miami because I think you're in a
bubble right now right and then he went
and he was like yo I don't want to be
here they kept trying to play him at
safety and he wanted to play Corner yeah
where do you think he plays with the
Bears
I hope I hope they leave my corner yeah
I mean after all that yeah but I
remember him coming out of high school
big deal and him going to Georgia
another one of those things that helped
him get one of the best recruiting
classes in the country and then
ultimately everywhere is not a good fit
for you all the time and he gets to go
back home he gets to do this and now
he's going to Chicago so let me tell you
something my man
uh I worked with Dion Bush's wife and he
those two people from Miami they were
not ready for that so really get ready
for that cold it's gonna be really fun
to watch him play though this is the guy
I think if they play at this at The
Corner Spot and let him play outside he
does have the size and the strength to
fit into what this defense wants from
him I think he can play a little bit his
own coverage we saw him there a couple
times in the Clips in cover two we saw
him play a little bit of that off in
three so he can do some other things but
I do think he's at his best when he gets
to play some press man I'm gonna go with
a I'm gonna go with an A on this one
yeah you talk about just him coming out
of high school the number three
cornerback recruit in 2019 behind only
Derek Stingley and Andrew Booth both
very highly drafted players uh now the G
man speaking of Corners they went
Deontay banks in the first round wide
receiver I know that there's a wide
receiver that you both like still on the
board offensive lineman a number of
massive offensive linemen still
available and Joe Schoen is going to go
a set interior offense of Lyman the
second Center goes and I think this is
something that a lot of Giants fans are
going to like John Jacob John Michael
Schmitz first team All-American First
Team all Big Ten 35 starts at Center the
kid is a vet only missed two games the
last three seasons and he's got a
wrestling background coach Fleck said at
Minnesota he's their best player and
their hardest worker and speaking of
hardest worker a blue collar dude dad is
a carpenter mom's an electrician and now
he's in the Big Apple John Michael
Schmitz the interior offensive lineman
now go to the gym look at his face too
doesn't look he's running for for
treasurer that's it that's a uh that's a
face for congress right man I'm in a big
city that's what he's gonna say no one
would have bat an eye if anyone if the
Giants drafted this guy at 25 I think
he's probably the most NFL ready Setter
in this draft class sixth year guy
coming out of Minnesota's played a lot
of good ball there and maybe he's not a
high-end athlete the way titman is but
they ran stretch Zone almost exclusively
at Minnesota got him out on the move and
he plays with great balance and engages
so well in the move that even if he is a
little limited as an athlete compared to
others I don't think that limits him on
the football field and what he can do I
think he's NFL ready in a ton of
different ways I would like him to get a
little stronger I think at the point of
attack maybe the only thing I would
worry about with him but at this point
in the draft you're getting a day one
starter at Center at a position of need
we're going to give that one an A plus
and you just gave Daniel Jones all that
money yes and you allowed you were 27th
in the NFL and sax allowed 49 you got to
improve the interior yeah I can be quick
on this one man I I like this guy as a
player I'm a big Tanner Morgan guy so I
got to watch the guy he was getting the
ball from and he was always even you
mentioned the stretch Zone but what I'm
going to mention is a lot of those those
quick rpos that they ran he was able to
make sure that he got to that got to the
tackle protected it to help clear a lane
so that Tanner Morgan could make that
throw because he's not a tall man so he
helped clear that lane to make that
throw I'm going to give it an a this is
a great pick he's going to come right in
he's going to make a play he's gonna
he's gonna make the plays that you have
to have to make an offense function in
the NFL starts he's the he's the he
touches the ball every single play I I
everyone starts with him I also like to
think of it like this we're at pick 57.
and the Giants may have gotten the best
player at a position in a draft and I
think that's very rare especially for a
position of need we stay in the NFC East
we go from the Giants to the Cowboys we
saw the reaction yesterday from Micah
Parsons when they took mozzie Smith he
lost his mind I actually went and looked
at a bunch of the reaction online
Cowboys fans were like I don't know if I
like this I would trust Micah Parsons
and now they're going Luke
Shoon maker that man that's a Dallas
name right there Luke shoonmaker the
pick for the Cowboys tight end we know
they needed one he was high school
teammates with Will Levis before
transferring he had a lacerated spleen
in high school he's gonna be 25 years as
a rookie but last year 35 catches 418
yards will they forget about Dalton
Schultz because of Shoon maker I think
they will I think he's just safe plug
and play tight end one of the best
inline blockers in this draft class one
of the most reliable receivers in this
draft class may not do a ton to excite
you but at the combine he tested out a
lot better than I expected 46340 goes to
his Pro Day runs a six eight one three
cone those are high-end numbers for a
tight end so there may be a little more
meat on the bone as a receiver that
wasn't utilized at Michigan because only
637 yards is his entire career there
five years at Michigan not featured a
ton that offense but I think in Dallas
there's going to be a lot more
opportunities for him to catch the
football and I think he's going to
deliver he's a guy that just is reliable
at this point in the draft Darnell
Washington
offense he's much better much safer as a
pass catcher in my opinion great we're
gonna go with a A minus for that one I'm
a little bit shocked I didn't go uh Mr
Washington yeah I am too um but here's
the thing looks good he's a heck of a
football player I mean I'll go easy on
this one and just say that uh reminds me
to Jake butt like and if you play if you
play tight end at Michigan you're gonna
block your behind off yeah you're gonna
have to earn these catches you're gonna
have to earn the right to run down the
field and make a play so they went
double Michigan in this draft
yes mozzie and now
Shoemaker yeah so the big thing for me
he's blocked in line a ton that's going
to translate he's blocked from the
backfield as we saw in the clip earlier
he's lined up as a fullback essentially
and come downhill and open up on an ISO
he can do all those things I'm going to
give it an a I would have rather had
Darnell Washington but you know what you
can't always get you get what you get
you don't get upset and I think nobody's
going to be upset with this pick
all right uh so the Cowboys they get
their tight end the Buffalo Bills are
now on the clock they went tight end by
jumping Dallas in the first round and
getting Dalton Kincaid they need some
defensive line help but I I if you
remember in the first round I said what
if they take Drew Sanders here has Drew
Sanders come off the board yet
now could he be the Tremaine Edmonds
replacement that's a name that I have
not heard I just think athletic
linebackers like that uh what do we
think here for buffalo
I I would love DeJuan Jones there I I
know they've had an issue at right
tackle the past couple of Seasons I with
you know Spencer Brown being a project
but thrust into action I think DeJuan
Jones is much safer in terms of past
protection and what he brings to the
table and just gives you some insurance
if Spencer Brown doesn't take that leap
in year three Cyrus the virus
that as well I think those are the two
that I'm most shocked by the two
offensive lineman yeah let's see if
either of them go here the Buffalo Bills
that pick number 59. there we go there
he is
here we go this is a heck of a draft now
for the Buffalo Bills going Dalton
Kincaid in the first getting arguably
the best uh Toyota and now getting
Osiris Torrance who some people said uh
the cyborg was going to be the number
one guard consensus All-American First
Team all SEC 34 starts at Right Guard 13
at left guard started off at Louisiana
and Then followed Napier to Florida zero
penalties in 2022 nice
this one's better in 1501 pass blocking
snaps zero sacks allowed Osiris Torrance
he was nicknamed Cyborg and then cybo
but Osiris Torrance this is a guy who I
remember watching a year ago coming out
of Louisiana Lafayette before he
transferred to Florida and I was like
you know okay do it again do it against
a better competition and then we'll talk
he goes to Florida and his tape was
legitimately better this year than what
I thought he was on tape at Louisiana at
that point I was like this guy's just
he's good he's such good balance for a
bigger guard was listed at 350. that
Florida obviously comes to the combine
in the 330 range but I think he wants to
play 350. I'm not too worried about it
because he doesn't get by in pure
athleticism he gets by on skill and
knowledge and that pure torque in his
upper body he can take a DT and pull him
get him out of that hole with just his
upper body and I love this Bill's draft
this is my favorite draft of anyone that
hasn't had like six picks already in
that they've given them options that are
impacting this year on that roster not
you know two three years down the line
their team is better this year and can
get over the hump this year because of
it this is an A plus pick in my regard
yeah I this is again I agree too I'm I'm
gonna say a plus when we get to the end
of it but I love that they were showing
Utah b-roll because Utah is one of the
toughest teams in the country and you
mentioned when you saw him coming out of
Louisiana you weren't sure if he's gonna
be able to hang with it in the SEC Utah
tape amazing then you go to this SEC
tape look at what he's doing right there
turn them around turn them all the way
around got him under control I love the
way that he controls people look at the
way he takes steps pass off a Twist he
can do those things too that's
athleticism and I love this this is
Georgia now look at that okay where you
go big man nowhere man I love that so
yeah we're gonna go a plus here you get
a guy that's probably their higher value
Talent you get them late you get them
for good value guys it's going to have
an impact for you immediately and man
he's he's he's really good I I also want
to say that he just blocked for Anthony
Richardson so he had a guy that could
run around and you have to keep blocking
that's what it's going to be with Josh
Allen yep so that's uh familiar as well
but they needed bigger guys because when
they played Cincinnati just Allen was
under attack speaking of Cincinnati the
Bengals are on the clock their first
round pick miles Murphy at 28 now at 60.
the Cincinnati Bengals select D this is
a guy that I've been waiting yeah so the
Bengals they lost Jesse Bates they lost
Von Bell and we've been talking man they
really need to get some more uh athletes
back there well this is a guy DJ Turner
the 22 starts 20 passes defended uh Rana
4-2-6-40 at the combine his 20-yard
split was a 232 and I think my favorite
nugget is since the seventh grade he has
been tutored by Ray Buchanan and if you
remember Ray that man was nasty DJ
Turner I heard him a lot of times mocked
at the end of the first and they get up
at the end of the second if he was 15
pounds heavier he's going in the first
178 pounds you know that and you see the
physicality show up on tape that he got
mossed at the catch point a handful of
times he would get kind of thrown to the
side at the top of routes but his click
and close ability is off the charts I
mean the 426 speed doesn't sometimes
when guys run that fast it doesn't
always show up on tape they're more
track stars than football players with
DJ Turner you see it every single snap
his ability to get from a standstill to
full speed in a blink of an eye and
that's what you want out of a cornerback
cornerback and this back seven
especially is a makeup position you are
not going to be deciding where you're
going ahead of where the offensive guy
is deciding where he's going so you have
to make up ground always and there's no
one better in this draft class than DJ
Turner making up ground I think he could
play safety even if he wanted him to if
he wanted a true back end single high
guy in Cincinnati there because they're
such a flexible defense in what they do
week in and week out Luana rumo and
their game plans that they do there so
this just adds another piece of the
puzzle to throw into that back end that
you're gonna have to have you want to
win the AFC so I'm going to go with an A
minus for this pick yeah I like him he's
heck of a football player obviously you
know I love defensive backs the thing
that and I'm you mentioned the safety
part because when I watched him play
even on those plays you know I thought I
thought about Earl Thomas and I thought
about a guy who could fly in the back
end and guess what if you're going to
take that 4-2 put it in the middle of
the high up high in the middle bring
some more pressures from your defense
let him Patrol the entire back in he's
fully capable of doing it we saw him
play inside we saw him play outside I
think he could absolutely get the job
done also he's Fearless he he's small
it's the personality of the Bengals yeah
he's he's small but he's not scared and
I think that's an that's an interesting
component when you add in the possible
safety element because that frees up
your defense to do a lot if you got a
guy like that just holding it down so
yeah for me this is a guy I absolutely
love love the scheme versatility love
what he brings to the table I'm going to
go ahead I'm going to drop that A Plus
on it because I thought he was had the
possibility to be an earlier draft pick
so this is going to be really
interesting all right Turner the pick
there for the Bengals they're trying to
make a run to the Super Bowl and he will
be a part of that Jacksonville is coming
to the clock they were originally
picking at 56 they moved back to 61
because Chicago moved up to get Tyreke
Stevenson and out Jacksonville is on the
clock DJ Turner going to Cincinnati the
pick is in
and the Jaguars are selecting Brenton
strange the tight end if we can get
programmed back on the monitor Brenton
strange the tight end for Jacksonville
uh
take a look at him here uh this is a
position that of need I mean I guess you
balance them out with Evan Ingram what
do you think here to me he's still just
an athlete playing tight end but it's
it's a developmental type of pick you
have Evan Ingram there already a guy who
himself is an athlete who kind of had to
figure out how to play the tight end
position but I love the high-end plays
from him as a receiver on tape only runs
a 4-7 maybe not thinking like that
Dynamic once he gets the ball in his
hands he turns into you know a glorified
running back uh with his after the catch
ability you're going to have to be a
work in progress as an inline blocker to
me I had him a little lower on the board
because of that but you're definitely
shooting for a little more upside here
when you can as the Jaguars right
because you don't have any open Real
spots for starters available so we're
going to go ahead and get a guy who's a
weapon potentially for the future for
Trevor Lawrence still going to go with a
B minus though Felder I will add this so
he's very much an h-back right only one
drop in 38 targets but that fits what
Doug Peterson has wanted this is the guy
in the tight ends they had when he was
with the Eagles he wants the guy that I
mean if you remember Philly Philly it
was an HVAC that threw it back to make
that throw he fits what they want but
not a ton of production at Penn State
overcome that not a ton of production
he's gonna have to get reps reps are the
only way you can overcome that lack of
production you have to get reps and
somebody's got to give them to and I
guess that somebody's going to be the
Jags so this is someone that again he's
not going to be the best blocker but you
see that athleticism right there that's
against Auburn that's against an SEC
team he's able to do that to them here
you guys coming out of the backfield
okay let's do it see what you got here
get off me okay he can do these things
he's got a very limited sort of Route
tree
which also limited his production and
then the other thing that you're going
to notice is he doesn't really block
that well and so this is going to be you
got to develop all those things I mean
this is great that you get in the
pancake but I think there's a defensive
piece yeah so that's not the same thing
as when you're playing against an NFL
defensive end right it's going to be
interesting to see how it shakes itself
out uh for me
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go C plus it
feels like a stretch okay he could he'll
he's gonna be around later but if you
like him you like him and hopefully he
becomes an A plus player for you uh to
me tight ends in that mold I would have
gone Tucker craft the South Dakota State
tight end like this is this is Doug
Peterson's new Trey Burton yeah there's
who he's trying to be uh please do not
if you have the pick I just want to like
think about this really quick the Eagles
are up right now I'm just looking at who
I would want them to take so please give
me a second uh Eagles are up uh again I
would love Drew Sanders they never
address linebacker so I don't know if
that's going to be a thing uh how would
Jalen Hyatt fit in as a as a third wide
receiver maybe replacing quez Watkins is
that a possibility Hyatt Downs both
those guys could fit right in there uh
Osiris is up he's gone uh any offensive
line what about the big Ohio State kid
DeJuan Jones just as a could he be the
Lane Johnson replacement yeah
that's not crazy okay so is the pick in
you can get in my ear
I'm like nervous I really thought it
they could have gone sharp in it
it's a what Detroit it's a trade all
that
okay so they trade with the Texans but
you know what
I had enough excitement yesterday you
can't win them all here come on they got
some third round picks they have a third
round pick I think they have the the
third pick in the third round because
the Cardinals uh decided to tamper with
our defensive coordinator the week
before the Super Bowl and so we got
their early third round pick but the
Texans are back on the clock
and they take
oh what a name juice Scruggs uh so CJ
Stroud Will Anderson and now juice
Scruggs uh the pick here uh as the
Houston Texans uh move up three spots to
get juice Scruggs offensive linemen what
do we think about this selection to me I
I'm a fan of this pick now I had them a
little lower on the board just
positional value-wise but I think if you
want a center there really aren't too
many better in this draft class in terms
of what they could be and the sending
player he goes to the Shrine Bowl
best day best we could pass protection
there of anyone I saw in attendance I I
think he's in a heck of an athlete I
think he has great balance for the
position I just worry about his play
strength you see right there 301 pounds
right a little on the small side but you
think about their offense they're
bringing in it's not a downhill punch
you in the mouth running game it is a
wide stretch Zone and in that sort of
scheme I think he can Excel so I'm going
to go with a B plus for this pick for
the Houston Texans kind of the missing
piece the last piece of that offensive
line that the needle was Center you get
that guy I think he can be your
long-term star there all right so it'll
be juice Scruggs likely snapping to CJ
Stroud is that something you'd like as a
Houston fan yeah I think I'd like it I
just have I'm worried about his injury
history he had a major back injury and
that's the thing that like he was out
for the year I had to wear like a back
brace like he wasn't this wasn't just
like he slipped a disc like it was a bad
injury so that's what I'm worried about
I wonder why him instead of uh the kid
from Ohio State what is it whippler yeah
I wonder why not especially when you
draft the quarterback from Ohio bingo so
for me I'm going to go ahead and go I'm
going to go B minus on this one I'm
worried about the injury history for
sure and then I'm also wondering why you
didn't get the guy who I thought was
just a little bit better not a lot
better just a little better okay juice
Scruggs uh the pick there for the
Houston Texans so Detroit is back on the
clock uh this another trade okay I was
gonna say so Detroit has now traded that
pick back twice they moved back with
Kansas City for Kansas City to take
Rasheed rice and now they move back
again so Detroit Gibbs Jack Campbell
laporta and then Brian branch and
they're also picking up a lot of picks
on their way back so Brad Holmes I think
it's a pretty good navigation uh Denver
I don't know if we've heard from Denver
we haven't uh so their first pick was
going to be the fourth pick of the third
round they got in a deal where Indiana
moved up to take safety Nick cross last
year but Denver now moving up with
Detroit who traded back with Kansas City
and I'm wondering where Denver and uh
Sean Payton are going to go with their
first place could this be the time
Northwestern DT comes off the board
obviously a high-end athlete in a d-line
with a lot of good athletes there now
but missing that interior presence with
Draymond Jones going to Seattle missing
that three Tech could this be where he
comes off the board here do you know
that no I don't I am saying that as
purely what if he took Hendon hooker
I'm just saying that what if like all
the rumors about Sean Payton maybe not
liking Russell Wilson came true and he
took ended hooker right now I wouldn't
blame him I'm actually like that is
interesting like I know head and hooker
is 25 years old and had an ACL injury
but he was projected to go a lot of
times in the first round and now we're
about to go to the third round yeah
I mean if he doesn't if he really
doesn't like him then yeah
but even if you do like him you have to
be scared right if you're a Broncos he
doesn't have to be scared about it
hasn't been good with the last year and
a half of Russell Wilson's look like and
this is not a position in the draft
either where it's like hey Russell
thanks for coming we're going to this
guy no it's just like saying addressing
that we need a backup quarterback too we
need to think about the future you just
weren't good enough last year maybe even
lights a little fire under Russell
Wilson even if you know he's the guy who
likes Zone Fire a lot so I do think this
is I'm a huge believer in the like the
fire Theory yeah Alex Smith had his best
year of his career when they drafted
Patrick Mahomes yeah uh you see it all
the time uh when quarterbacks uh get
that fire lit but Denver uh big
off-season acquisition of Mike
mcglinchey uh big off-season loss of
Draymond Jones those are the two that
jump out
um they do get Jared Stidham but I don't
know if that's going to protect anything
look this is a team that allowed the
most sacks in the NFL last year 63 they
were all also last in the NFL in scoring
at under 17 points per game and Sean
Payton is offense that's why I know you
like the defensive lineman there if I'm
Sean Payton my first year I either need
to protect my quarterback or I need to
give my quarterback weapons that's just
if I just took over this job so we'll
see and I do know that they need a pass
catching running back too now not a ton
of great options here but Devin a chain
is probably your best pass catching
space back the way that Sean Payton's
used catching space back uh over the
course of his career as head coach yeah
I like a chain I like him a lot
it's one of the most decorated high
school track stars ever yeah that guy
can cook it was an All-American in the
100 200 and 400. he ran a 10-1-4 in the
hundred yes that's what's so incredible
about doing the research is you see
their hundred scores and they're
incredible they're 1088 they're 10-7 but
when you see a ten one four you're like
oh that's another level oh like if you
worked at this that's all he did yeah uh
let's see what Denver does and they are
going a wide receiver they're going
Marvin Mims so they are getting a wide
receiver for Russell Wilson and another
wide receiver for the weapons for Sean
Payton Marvin mins Jr first team all Big
12 is career averages kind of nuts 19
and a half yards per reception probably
because he caught wide open bombs like
that Marvin Mims the new wide out in
Denver yeah he's got legit deep threat
speed 438 40. they mentioned that yards
per reception figure the highest in the
entire draft class been project ever
since this true freshman year there
really the only concern the biggest
concern I have is just play strength you
see him easily knocked off his route a
little too much you see him not win a
ton of plays at the catch Point despite
that highlight right there but I just
worry about what's it going to look like
when he has to face NFL caliber strength
at corner because as We Know
and they already have KJ hammer in a
similar mold who really hasn't worked
out but as we know Big 12 Corners not
quite what you're going to see totally
once you get to the NFL showed you that
was an absolute poor wrap by the corner
there but but he's got a lot of fans
he's still young still a guy who just
turned 21 in March that
came out early because quite frankly he
produced enough to do so he earned that
right and so I think they have a loaded
wide receiving core now there in Denver
would not surprise me if they move a guy
out of that you know with with Jerry
Judy with AJ Handler with uh Tim Patrick
Portland like there's two there's a lot
of mouths to feed now in Factor all that
in and you're great so I'm gonna go with
a B
because I I just he is a little
redundant to KJ Handler like they are
similar types of wide receivers so
unless you're willing to move on from
one of the guys well you're kind of
giving up on them I like them I like the
TJ Graham comp as well but I like Marvin
Mims This is a guy kind of stepped up
into that that Hollywood brown mold that
they had out there at Oklahoma uh a guy
that he can kill you across the field he
can also beat you deep as we saw in all
the highlights I love this ability right
here on a play action guess what look at
me I'm way back here way behind you you
got sucked up against the against the
Run huh okay what are you doing now I'm
he will I make a contestant catch I
don't make them all the time but I can
make some so this is going to be really
interesting to see how they use them if
they use them if they move somebody but
they're getting them in at the end of
the second round
maybe they want to see how you mentioned
put your feet to the fire yeah you get
him in the second round
he's gonna make the roster somebody
Something's Gonna have to give and so
we'll see what that somebody is because
if somebody someone doesn't someone in
that room doesn't produce
goodbye I'll say this about mems he is
in analytics darling between his
production profile between his age and
between his combine testing so that
could you give a grade as well oh I'm
sorry no it's all good boom there we go
a plus okay wow the elite up there I
love this kid like I think he's I think
he's super special
I think that I mean
I just you're speechless like this guy
is he's a really good football player
for three old translate we are
officially into the third round these
picks are going to go quick on
television Roger Goodell is shaking the
hands of servicemen uh here we are going
to talk about the Chicago Bears they
went offensive line Darnell Wright then
they went Gerson Dexter senior defensive
lineman then Tyreke Stevenson the
cornerback where will Chicago go will
they support Justin Fields will they
build that defense with Matt eberfloose
we will see the third round is
officially going and I've got my eye on
the next two picks because the Eagles
are going back to back there's got to be
something nice about going back to back
yeah it's relaxing you get 10 minutes
you know you don't have to if I could
you could you not make one yeah and then
do it and then do you go you get the one
after that
yeah if you don't make the first one in
time in the first round you you just can
because you you technically jump
yourself so you're so they can just kind
of sit there yeah
what I would do is if I were the Eagles
is right now I'd be using all that time
on the phone who intended hooker
but all right Chicago Bears are up they
went uh tackle D lineman cornerback uh
which you know what those were their
Three Needs coming into this draft and
they addressed all of them yeah they
were 32nd in terms of passing in the NFL
are there any other wide receivers maybe
that you would like first Jones is still
on the board right yeah Cedric Tillman
still on the board yeah they need a
little something they don't have they
don't have a true possession
no no jail Hyatt off the board just yet
but that's truthfully that's where I had
him I had 78th on the draft board I was
worried about the route running so he
this is where I thought uh you know is
it crazy for them to to double down go
Darnell right and then DeJuan Jones and
just add a ton of huge people that
probably is a little crazy but I do
think interior line they're not good
they're not out of our that would be
people in Illinois that you go gervonne
Dexter thinking maybe he grows into your
nose tackle in the future and then
adabari he grows into your three Tech of
the future to just high-end athletes
because they're dealing everyone's
talking about DJ Moore but to get
Tremaine Edmonds Demarcus Walker and TJ
Edwards you added a lot of Veteran size
and speed to the front seven they still
need that edge rusher though and there
really isn't unfortunately at this point
in the draft a great fit at Edge so they
may have to reach on one if they do
because they do Zach Pickens so they do
add size with the first pick in the
third round Zach Pickens defensive
lineman will be going to the Chicago
Bears Chicago one of Michael felder's
favorite cities in the world uh South
Carolina team captain South Carolina Mr
Football this guy was the number one
defensive tackle in 2019 ahead of
Trayvon Walker okay third ranked recruit
to ever sign with South Carolina it went
Jadeveon Clowney Marcus Lattimore and
then back with two C's yep I know that's
incredible that extra C is for crash in
the pocket what do you think of your
first pick of the third round his
high-end reps are to me the second best
in this class after Jalen Carter for
defensive tackle wow like his ability
when he throws it all the explosiveness
that he can put into contact is rare
like it is what you saw making him one
of the highest rated recruits they've
ever signed is that the hind reps are
special they just are so few and far
between so this is a swing another guy
where it's like if you hit on him they
drafted the two DTS in this class that
are really kind of the Boomer bus DTS
you know they can be something really
special if they really figured out but
they also may not want them to in the
football field against the run right now
there are motor concerns with him he
runs a little hot and cold but if you're
Chicago it's it's a forward-thinking
draft on the defensive side of the ball
it's saying that right now we're
probably not going to get impact dudes
on our defense we're not going to turn
this thing around overnight but but I
got a little bit of a leash here with
Matt eberfles I think I got some years
with Justin fields that I'm going
thinking about the future still going to
have to go be though it still is a
little earlier than I would have gone
for him I'd like this kid a lot like
since we like since high school like I
remember him coming out of high school
and it was the same level of hype it was
a battle between Alabama and Clemson and
South Carolina and South Carolina's like
we got to keep this kid home we got to
keep this kid home we got to keep this
kid home and they were able to do it and
he was he's he's a tweener and you don't
say that much about someone that weighs
291 pounds but he is someone that
because of his length he can play a
little bit wider and that's going to be
interesting to see where they play him
like is this guy going to be your nose
is he going to be your three what is he
going to be in that defense that's going
to be the part that's interesting and
I'm glad you mentioned that his good
reps are great reps he just doesn't have
enough of them but you can see here when
he decides I'm gonna go he goes and I
love that about his game uh for me I'm
gonna go ahead and go I'm gonna go B
plus because he has the ability as a
player to become remarkably special and
we've seen flashes of it we just need to
see him put it together yeah I like the
fact that the varus took gambles on two
guys that could be Boomer bus I like
taking risks especially at this point
all right Eagles have back to back here
I'm not surprised that anything after
round three this is when Howie really
starts working well who is it pick is in
real quick back to back picks I would
like to make my guesses okay before we
do this
I think number one one of these picks is
going to be Kelly Ringo okay if we're
keeping the Georgia picks that are keep
coming to Philadelphia okay I think they
need a corner so I'm going to say Ringo
is one of them and I'm going to say the
other one all what I want is the Ohio
State uh I want DeJuan Jones okay those
are the two picks if they went Darnell
Washington I'd be happy if they went
Drew Sanders I'd be happy but I just
think for hilarity's sake a corner from
that Georgia defense would be great do
we have any of them in
we do not
okay dwan Jones on the opposite side of
Jordan my lotta would be biggest tackle
Duo NFL history it's got to be out there
looks like folks like Hyatt
yeah so tell me about Hyatt so high it's
like a better version of quest walk in
my opinion like that that's who he is
he's a pure speed guy Purity after quest
dropped that ball in the Super Bowl I'm
sorry quiz we need another guy but
Hyatt's got very reliable hands oh it's
the ball extremely well I I like I said
I I didn't love him as a first rounder
this was the range I had him going in
but if he goes to the Eagles here it's
the perfect fifth
okay
I didn't like your reaction well I
didn't like either of your reactions
there I wanted DeJuan Jones and they go
Tyler Steen okay God's played a lot of
football okay
all right Tyler Steen Philadelphia
Eagles they do go tackle and there is a
chance that look there he we don't know
where he's going to play this guy is
versatile Tyler Steen 34 starts at left
tackle 12 starts at right tackle oh my
gosh I forgot about this kid okay four
years at Vanderbilt before he goes to
Alabama was originally a defensive
lineman but here's why I love this kit
okay his dad was a marine that is a
marine his grandfather won the Medal of
Honor for jumping on a grenade
that is the kind of character that I
wanted the Philadelphia Eagles Tyler
Steen could he be the guy that replaces
Lane Johnson what do we think of the
value here I think they end up kicking
him side to guard actually I think he's
probably he goes in the Right Guard spot
yes he's probably your you know
Brandon Brooks rub the replacement from
me obviously a couple years ago but left
tackle at Alabama I thought this was
easily his best year it was not really a
top prospect by any means before he
transfers from Vanderbilt but quick beat
for a guy like that but shorter arms
probably why he's going on the interior
I think he's a great developmental
prospect on the interior you really see
him mirror so well a little bit of
balance concerns gets out over his skis
a little too often for my money but but
he's going to the place that develops
alignment better than anyone else better
than anybody and so as far as guard
prospects at this point in time in terms
of pass protection who am I looking at
this guy can profile to a high-end pass
protector okay at the next level level
so not a lot of spots you know on this
Eagles roster where you're even going to
see playing time guard could easily be
one of them great we're gonna go with an
a grade I I like his tape I truly do and
and I will say this we had Jason Kelsey
on the show last year he helps them
Scout Eagles have Jeff stoutland the
number one offensive line coach in the
NFL if he picked this he found Jordan
myalotta in a Rugby scrum if he thinks
this is the guy I instantly have
confidence I gotta calm down I gotta let
you do your video okay it's hey no
problem for me I think I think Sting's
really good too and the big thing for me
you wonder about okay you started at
Vanderbilt you started at Vanderbilt you
started at Vanderbilt and then he goes
over to Alabama and he was dominant this
is a guy that plays strong he I love the
fact that he does play pretty low and he
does that pretty routinely play with a
low Center gravity even coming out of
that two-point stance you see him get
down get low and get up underneath and
push so I think this is a great pick I
think this is a pick where you have an
opportunity to develop this guy if you
development as a guard fantastic he's
probably gonna need to get a little bit
bigger okay but if you develop him as a
tackle I think you have to worry about
those arms but maybe it is a guy that
you kick over to the other side or you
figure out what you're going to do so
this is going to be an interesting one
for me I'm gonna go a because I do like
Steve Steen for me he's one of those
guys where can you do it you can you oh
you can you start a Vandy okay cool but
but can you start at Alabama yeah like
if Nick Saban is calling you on the
phone right after playing against you
after watching you play I think you're
doing something right no doubt look at
that dude's legs too I mean those
highlight reels that's a guard that's
that's how you put together a guard so
this is the situation for the Eagles uh
they lost some aloe cam Jurgens who will
eventually replace Jason Kelsey they
were thinking maybe he goes over to
Right Guard now you can put Steen in
there if he's already Jurgens could
start and then if this really is the end
of Lane maybe he could go over to right
tackle like he's six six through twenty
yeah I know those arms aren't 34-35 I
know they're 33. okay you know it I got
it am I going to be happy oh I see it it
is a safety sorry I'm sorry
they go safety this is another position
that the Eagles really needed and they
are going to that super aggressive
secondary of Illinois that has output
three prospects into this draft it is
Sydney Brown I'm having a little bit of
PTSD because of Sydney Jones that didn't
work out that well but Sydney Brown is
the pick from Illinois I don't know
anything about this guy Renner tell me
about it I love Sydney Brown you do I do
okay for my money he's the best pure
deep safety and strapless now he didn't
play deep safety though it was the only
thing he played box safety at Illinois
extremely well built 5 10 211 the guy is
brick wall built out of granite over
there with how much work he's put in the
weight room tackler he wants to get
after it gets a little over aggressive
reminds me a lot of guy like Tylenol
hufanga and that once he sees himself
that he is not gonna stop until he goes
and gets it that works to his detriment
at times but I think he'd turn into a
different player this year uh from what
we had seen in years past he's so smooth
as an athlete and his ability to cover
the slot really shined at the Senior
Bowl so why is he available now I I
think it's some one part the size 510 is
on the shorter end for safety and not
everyone loves other part is just safety
position you know okay people are
looking for whether it's a slot Corners
like we've seen uh come off the board
already to me Sydney Brown's much more
of a box deep guy that's not everyone's
cup of tea so I I'm a fan it might also
be that he's a productive late in his
career a late bloomer like a lot of the
guys were saying here from Illinois but
could it be that they're late bloomers
because they went through a coaching
change yeah like what are we talking
about here yes yeah come on this guy can
play he's really good I'm glad I'm glad
you mentioned he's a box safety this
guy's a hitter he's a bulldog man I love
the way that he's able to come downhill
make you pay look at him he's on the
line of scrimmage takes on takes on the
Titan gets off of him and it's just one
of those things that you can do like I
think this is fantastic look at the way
he's gonna track this cope up oh go make
him pay and that's his big thing he goes
and he makes you pay you're gonna get it
buddy
get him on the ground there you go what
I love about this down the Eagles
defense they just lost CJ Gardner
Johnson but this is what they've always
wanted the Malcolm Jenkins the safety
that plays in the box that they can use
in all these different sets yeah I love
it this kid can play he's very good I'm
gonna go ahead and give it an A2
especially because of the for the value
you're getting this guy you're getting
him in it's in the third round good it's
in the third round you guys are making
me thrilled okay well one guy that I
wanted the Eagles to maybe go for he is
the Athletics uh linebacker out of
Arkansas he is going to the Denver
Broncos we are going to pick up the
speed right now uh Drew Sanders the
linebacker from Arkansas who did
everything uh in his career Drew Sanders
uh to Denver Denver went Marvin Mims and
now they are going Drew Sanders he was
the Mike linebacker at Arkansas the
number one athlete in the 2020
recruiting class two years at Bama then
Arkansas uh non-stop energy son of a
coach the second FBS player ever other
than Khalil Mac with over 95 tackles 12
tackles for loss eight plus sacks three
Force fumbles a thumb return and an
interception in a season
his best blitzing linebacker in this
draft class hey who was he started at
Edge at Alabama before transferring to
Arkansas still has that natural pass
rushing ability but a heck of an athlete
just needs to learn how to play in space
he's still adjusting to the off ball
game too many missed tackles on his tape
too many misreads on his team for my
liking that's why he falls this point in
the draft but this is where I had him
right on the draft board so I can't
really complain I was going to complain
when he was a first rounder but this is
where I take a guy like that and with
such a desperate need at linebacker for
the Broncos I Gotta Give it an a yeah I
I dig this I think he's a heck of a
football player um when I watch him play
I see some good anticipation I do see
the fact that yeah this guy did start
out as an edge Defender but man I gotta
go a plus because I thought he had the
ability to be at least high in the
second round
uh Drew said I think about Denver
linebackers and I think about Golden and
I think about Wilson and I think about
all the ones they had over the years
that fits I'm going to be honest I
didn't know he was white
it doesn't impact anything
I mean it does a little bit okay Detroit
Lions uh they've been trading down a
bunch why oh that really hurt
the Detroit Lions get hendin hooker in
the beginning of the third round Jared
Goff the quarterback now but the value
of getting Hendon hooker at this spot
has to be enticing for a Detroit Lions
team that has made a ton of interesting
picks Brian branch and now Hendon hooker
led the SEC in completion percentage he
had 45 rushes of 10 or more yards over
000 yards of offense and they get him
here in the top of the third yeah I I
the lions are redeeming themselves on
day two here I I think this is a
fantastic pick I'll say I'll start with
the negatives first with hooker he's 25
years old he's playing hailing from an
offense that is probably the most
gimmicky one you'll see in college
football in terms of translatability to
the NFL and he's coming off a touring
ACL yes outside of that though he's
about as good a prospect as you can see
at this point in the draft in that the
man was productive as heck and he got
better every single year year of his
career I love the Poise he plays with
from the pocket he stands tall he's
confident he gets from one to two to
three with quickness with efficiency
with his footwork and dude's got a
cannon dude has one of the strongest
arms in this draft class he's an athlete
can get on the move can be a value add
in the running game and we're talking
about this Lions offensive line we're
talking about a team with Samir Gibbs
now that could be one of the dominant
rushing attacks you've read some option
game to it I mean they're right up there
with the Eagles in terms of who I think
to be the best rushing offense in the
NFL but obviously it's year two year
three that you're hoping for it much
better in my opinion drafting this guy
then than anyone you're going to get at
pick six initially for them so with that
a plus Lions redeem the draft right now
yeah great value I just want to say
before you go because sometimes the
notes are funny the first word was ball
which I love the idolized Randall
Cunningham good we all know the
negatives about this guy is he a is he a
Felder guy yeah okay does he from he's
from he's from where I'm from he's from
North Carolina yeah he's from North
Carolina yeah come on and raise up come
on now let's go no he um I love what he
does right speed and space that's what
hypo's all about love the way he stands
in the pocket love how you mention that
he's got a very strong level but control
over that arm this is not Anthony
Richardson with just a strong arm this
is a strong arm with control over it
look at that motion that's a beautiful
throw and I love the fact that he's got
some athleticism so I would rank him up
there with a lot of these uh kind of
quote-unquote air raid
quarterbacks right we're used to seeing
these guys but the difference is he
brings some athleticism to the table
right he brings the ability to run 45
runs of 10 plus yards yeah you're not
getting that from a lot of guys I know
you're not getting it from will love us
Jared Goff can I get it from Jared Goff
either yeah so I think I think that's a
that's critical air and you're getting
them for good value I think that he
doesn't have to play early which means
he allows him better more time to
recover from that ACL yep it allows him
time to learn yep and allows him time to
grow into the NFL and I know I
understand he's 25 so he'll be 3
when the contract's up but at the end of
the day guess what
he's going to still be there for you and
I think he's got the opportunity now
yeah well they they they can because
they don't you're not allowed to touch
them what's the grade for this cat oh a
plus oh a guy that we thought might go
when we did pre-pro we all thought he
might go in the first round absolutely
only concern about him 39 fumbles in
college 22 in the last two years I want
to spend a little bit more time on
Hendon hooker here
when they're in training camp
and they're watching the two
quarterbacks throwing next to each other
well the members of the Detroit Lions
will hand and hooker will some of them
go man his ball looks better than golf
because that's how I think about
quarterback battles it will what do you
think Runner is that what will it look
like to the lion well one you're hoping
he's better uh you hope he's his knees
better by then but two he's got a
stronger arm the golf like he's got an
aesthetically pleasing release that's
beautiful easy to fall in love with that
I do think though you'll see a
transition period for him with the
offense like that's the biggest thing is
that that Tennessee offense it is you
almost make up your mind pre-snap you're
counting numbers you got too wide on
each side did they put only two over
there well then we got numbers I'm going
that way and there's no real second
option you know on a lot of plays there
and there's not really diversity of
throws that he's asked to make in that
often so it's going to be a lot of new
stuff for him so this is a really good
situation he's when people are talking
about going first round people had a
mock top five or whatever that's putting
them in a situation where there's two
high expectations this is just come in
get better and we'll reassess probably
year two year two training camps when
it's like do we want golf do we want
hooker now that's when you'll be making
that decision
by the way his real first name is Alan
that one kind of threw me oh lame right
abandon would have been great so you
think maybe year two it's a true
quarterback battle yeah you just got to
get healthy
all right
we have a trade Texans trade again man
you know what Nick acerio is making
trades like his job is on the line and
it is yeah it does seem like that so
they trade up and they take tank Dell
that's an all-time name whoa Nathaniel
Dell the hair is incredible Houston wide
receiver 449 little guy five eight uh
but this will be a wide receiver so they
went and they got juice drugs Scruggs
for CJ shroud and now they go they
drafted juice and then tank yeah all
name team here for the Houston Texans
tanked out I I love this dude he led the
FBS in receptions receiving yards last
season he had 10 career punt returns at
Houston three of them ended up with him
in the end zone yes he is electric he
has the best footwork of anyone in the
entire draft class in my opinion the
quickest feat he is impossible to stick
with on an entire route tree we saw that
Senior Bowl he didn't really lose a
wreck in the 101s the entire week the
only problem is he looks like a soccer
player he's five eight one sixty five
right what's that going to look like
when he gets the NFL we've been talking
about that size all draft long but the
thing I love with him he's small he
doesn't play small right the catch point
he is acting like it's his every single
time he comes back to footballs he
attacks it in the air you want it to
him so all that like I had him as a top
50 player I love this it's something
that the Houston Texans don't have
especially after trading away Brandon
Cooks and I think he starts right away
for them and you pair him with CJ Stroud
and you're profit and it's an A plus
pick wow he's good this guy I mean just
a production machine
everybody knew he was going to get the
football and he still caught the
football
that's what you want to have happen
right so for me when I look at take Bell
or tank Dell excuse me he is someone
that you mentioned the footwork I love
that footwork also translates to his
route running because he's able to give
look at that don't you you can't put
hands on he's coming out of that slot
you can't put hands on him you can't put
hands on him he's going to show you some
speed with that 4-4 so I love that
obviously boom and he's running to the
interior I like that it's not just all
outside outside outside he's also still
running to the interior to make plays
you make catching the ball in traffic
catching the ball through the rip
holding on to the football securing the
feet inbounds as you mentioned the
footwork again so yeah for me this is an
apic a guy that we that we all thought
was gonna go in the second round ends up
in the in the in the what are we in the
Middle top of the third yeah so that's a
good one uh I mean they have Nico
Collins they have some size so he will
be the Speedy wide receiver but those
numbers good I don't know not really but
none of their receivers are good I just
wasn't a huge fan of his when he was at
Michigan yeah by the way so this is
becoming an all-name team forget will
okay you have juice you have tank and CJ
Stroud's real first name is Coleridge so
Coleridge juice and tank here we go love
it that's the Coal Ridge of juice tape
Nicole oh it's the old Coleridge juice
tank uh that Raiders are now on the
clock Raiders uh if you look at their
draft so far studs Tyree Wilson Michael
Mayer they really have had some studs if
I I'm going to want I don't know why he
hasn't been drafted yeah you can get a
true Juwan right now Dewan right now
feels like Josh Jones when he fell to
Arizona in the third round a few years
ago an offensive lineman where you're
like he could slip in the end of the
first round but we'll see uh I can see
that horror love it Raider Nation uh
what do we have do we have the pick do
we have the pick
we do not okay
wow for the first time we're lockstep
with the broadcast don't like that don't
like that the Raiders
Josh Downs is still on the board wow
a rough one for him I'm most shocked I
think by out of borrow away even more
than totally yeah
they did get picked and Nick Herbert's
not from Florida but the rest if I were
them yeah the Dewan pick makes the most
sense to me I'm not sure if that is it
but
Byron young is the pig make sure we get
the right one there's two Byron there
are two Byron young there are two they
didn't both go to Alabama no one went to
Tennessee
okay so that is a note uh for everyone
back there Byron Young from Alabama we
know that Vegas loves to take uh Alabama
players Byron young is the player here
second team All-American uh played in 54
games in the last four years uh Scouts
say he has the drive needed to be
successful in the NFL last year he had
28 pressures in the three seasons before
he had 28 pressures and he was a 3-4n
for Saban yes does that fit that Patrick
Ram defense yeah this feels like I mean
it feels like a Belichick pick right
okay is sort of Josh McDaniel's coming
over it feels like the kind of guy you
would plug into Bill Belichick's defense
and that is a pure two gapper over
34-inch arms you love him against the
Run High floor low ceiling though this
to me was the biggest reach on my board
so far just because I I don't think he's
ever going to be an impact pass rusher
so because of that we're gonna go with a
c on this one and I love this player uh
honestly I wish we I wish we had
collazon again to talk about it because
he plays kind of in a similar style
where he's someone that absolutely can
be a two gapper this is someone that
really does he'll get both hands on guys
and he's ready to rock and roll look at
that get off disengage and go make a
tackle he's amazing against the run I
love the way that he's able to squeeze
the pocket so for me this guy I mean you
can't I I see another especially with
how the long how much football he played
at Alabama and at a high level and when
he turned it when his number got called
finally after that they lost some guys
his number got called this year to
really step up a little bit more he did
it so for me I look at this pick and I'm
ready to give my grade we can shut the
b-roll off now I'm ready to get to the
next one let's go I'm I'm good this dude
is a really good player so I am going to
give it an a this is a thing for me like
he is someone who I I love watching him
play I love the fact that he rose to the
occasion so I think this is a really
interesting picture for them it's a
really interesting piece and someone
that can be as we saw in Alabama from
his freshman year he can be an early
contributor Saints on the clock and
they've made their pick we know that
they've had some issues with Alvin
Kamara they are going running back
Kendra Miller he did miss that national
title game with an MCL surgery so we'll
see how he's doing health-wise but the
most rushing yards in a season for TCU
since LT LaDainian Tomlinson One season
as a full starter nearly 1400 yards and
17 touchdowns in 14 in 12 of 14 games he
had a play of 20 or more yards electric
he'll be in that Alvin Camaro role This
Guy's in every down back yeah I mean he
can really do it all really Dynamic
great in space for a 215 pounder Shifty
I think there's even even more to his
game than I think he's given credit for
and that he can really do it all like
there's not a lot of every down backs in
this draft there's a lot of smaller
speed guys 511 215 is that good size
this guy he really is your kind of Heir
Apparent there to Alvin Kamara I think
that's like Alvin Kumar's exact size too
uh in that offense so I'm a fan of this
pick I'm not super high on running backs
but they kind of just got the same guy
they got in Camaros truthfully a very
similar skill set so I'm gonna go with
an A on this one and of course there is
the legal issues facing Alvin Kamar from
I believe Vegas uh your pick I love him
I don't need to say much you said
everything that I was going to say
anyways this guy's he's a stud he's a
heck of a football player thought he was
a big reason why TCU was in the position
they were in to get to the National
Championship so I'm gonna go with an A
plus I love it yeah the fact that you're
up there with LT is pretty much all you
need to know Arizona Cardinals are now
on the clock they traded up or I believe
they traded back when Tennessee made one
of their moves to come up and they are
selecting Garrett Williams we got a fist
pump over there from Renner what was the
reason that you had to uh show that I'm
a massive fan of this guy did not expect
him to come off the board at this point
draft but a Syracuse score because he
tore his ACL against Notre Dame this
past year but if he would have stayed
healthy this is a guy who is taped is
just a little different than any of the
corners in this draft class he has
incredible feet his ability to stay on
balance and mirror throughout the entire
route tree it's really second to none in
this draft class it's just they towards
ACL it's just that he is a little
lacking in the physicality Department
got beat by Charlie Jones a few times in
that Purdue game this year but man his
makeup speed his ability to match and
mirror the Cardinal's a great position
to draft a guy like this because they
don't need him right away they know this
year is not going to be their Year yes
year two year threes of the year and
this guy in year two year three could be
a lockdown outside corner copped into
Christian Fulton there he's turned into
one of the better Corners in the league
I think he could be that so we're gonna
go with an A plus for this one wow A
Plus Runner I love it I mean this is a
guy you see him there trigger and then
look at that mirror and you mentioned
the mirroring that's exactly what we're
talking about is all that mirroring the
mirroring the mirroring he's doing it
and he's making it work and that's
really awesome to see because here he
comes I'm coming to take it
he's Maddie fell down but yeah no I'm
gonna go ahead and give him a this is a
guy I watch a lot of because of the ACC
ties and listen Syracuse kind of like
Illinois
quietly is they're creating some quality
defensive backs right where people
aren't really paying attention to them
uh that was the pick Garrett Williams
Arizona right now Paris Johnson B.J
ogilari Garrett Williams and a lot of
moving down and accumulating picks in
next year's draft uh next pick 73 it was
the Texans but of course they moved but
we do have a trade Giants moving up from
the Rams so the Rams had moved back and
they're going to move back again because
if there's one thing the Rams needed it
is draft pick and the Giants are taking
Jalen Hyatt and if you're a Giants fan
right now they are checking off all of
the boxes Corner Deontay Banks Center
John Michael Smith and now the wide
receiver that has fallen Jalen Hyatt the
pick out of Tennessee who was catching
all those passes from Hendon hooker the
Speedster going to New York team where
he might play right away Runner yeah
they got gas in this Giants receiving
corn now Paris Campbell Darius Slayton
Jalen Hyatt those are legit 4-3 guys
even though I know jail and I ran a 4-4
flat at the combine but his speed on
tape fastest GPS times of anyone in this
draft class when he got behind guys no
one was catching up he tracks the ball
extremely well something you don't say a
lot about speed wide receivers is that
he knew where to get it his hands
plucked it out of the air you're never
gonna have to worry about those drops on
those big plays that are so infrequent
in the NFL nowadays he's going to
capitalize on him it's just are you
getting a complete Wide Receiver right
and that's the question with him but in
that offense it's a lot of crossers
there's a lot of overs they're not
asking full route tree to be successful
it is a speed route tree that they run
there why they're stocking up on speed
this off season and obviously if you're
stocking up on speed in this draft
you're not going to find any more of it
than what Jalen Hyatt has so at this
point in the draft that's where I would
have taken him so a minus for me his
stats this year are staggering 67
catches nearly 1300 yards 15 touchdowns
that's a School record for Touchdown
catches five of them Felder in that game
against Alabama yeah I know unreal I
know it's on it was unbelievable great
performance he played a heck of a season
so I'm going to go ahead I'm going to
drop that April we can get to watch him
a little bit more I'll take it so you
see him there on the slant I love that I
know he's a little bit thin I love this
here you see the confusion that this
offense creates that's how they know
where to go pre-snap they know where to
go he knows what he's where he's going
to get because he knows he's got that
guy bringing the guy across and though
he knows he's wide open in the to the
corner this is a really it's an offense
that's built for quarterback success and
I guess we can go use a little bit of
time to go back look at hinden hookers
ball delivery it's so beautiful I'm
going eight plus this is a guy Jalen
Hyatt a lot of folks had going a lot
earlier this is something where you see
yes he's gonna have to work on his
routine yes that's something that
everybody has to do and here's the thing
people don't realize about the NFL it's
not just a route tree
it's the team's Realtree it's the way
the team once Rouse ran there are some
coaches they're very old school they
want you if they want to if you want a
five yard out they want you to go to
five then they want you to go out there
are other teams that ask you to climb
you get one step two-step then you climb
to five on that out so he doesn't have
to just learn running all these these
other different routes it's also gonna
have to learn how these coaches want
their routes to be around and if there's
one coach that's going to find a way to
get receivers open it is Brian dayball
Jalen Hyatt is a monster big play guy 20
catches last year of more than 20 yards
seven catches last year of more than 50
yards the thing about him is 90 of his
snaps came in the slot that's where he
will likely play but this is a team that
needed wide receiver help for Daniel
Jones yeah if you're asking how's the
guy with this production in the SEC who
I believe won the bltnikov he did how
does he fall to this point in the draft
well it's because he had one catch
against press coverage all season it's
because and when you watch this
highlight tape a lot of it was busted
coverages and that's just things that
NFL battery is looking at not
necessarily translatable look at this
well Brian daball is going to make is
going to find a way to get you open
another wide receiver comes off the
board this time it's going to be for
DeSean Watson uh Cedric Tillman the pick
here uh Four Seasons in the NFL for his
father who played college with Steve
McNair he did Miss six games with an
ankle injury but he had 16 catches of 25
or more yards another Tennessee wide
receiver coming off the board this time
going to Cleveland I love this pick
there's a guy who dealt with injuries
unfortunately this past season because
Junior tape was much better he is a true
possession type of wide receiver six
three two thirteen four five four speed
not gonna ever be a real deep threat not
necessarily going to wear you at that
point in the football field but that's
what they got Elijah more for that's
what got Amari Cooper for this is the
guy that can move the chains on third
down basically what they wanted dpj to
be what they wanted David Bell to be
this guy can be that guy in your offense
the best contested catch receiver in
this draft class too I believe it went
over 60 percent in his career because he
has to catch opportunities which is just
the missing link in her wide receiving
core that was pretty Barren last season
all of a sudden looks like it could be a
completely different animal now in year
two of John Watson era great we're gonna
go a for that one yeah I know you like
Toman a lot and I do too this is the
thing for me with him when I watch him
play I did see a guy he reminded me a
little bit of Jahan Dotson a guy that
couldn't could make some big plays but
leaves at his best making sure that they
got a first down and that's what you see
with him he makes sure they get first
down there's a Joel Milton player huh
wow look at that ball contested catch
let's let's go up and over him so I love
that about him this is someone again
fantastic catch there we go that's what
he's good at that's what he's that's
what he's there for he can catch the
jump ball he can catch the Run he can
make he runs good routes and he's gonna
he's someone I think probably has a
little better route running route tree
than Jalen Hyatt so when you look at
this and look at what you're getting and
look at when you're getting it I
certainly think Cedric Tillman Great
Value a plus he is someone that you're
going to love because he can step right
in and be a Target and help you get
first downs first downs turn into
touchdowns yeah and the difference in
that Tennessee offense Hyatt playing the
slot Tillman on the outside the way
teams played Tennessee they would press
the outside guy not press the slot guy
which meant he had to do things you're
going to do in the NFL press coverage
perspective where Hyatt was not
necessarily doing Deshawn Watson came
into this off season had the highest
contract NFL but he had Amari Cooper and
Donovan people's Jones they make the
trade for Elijah Moore now they go out
and get Tillman you have a full wide
receiving Corps in Cleveland Falcons on
the clock and they take Zach Harrison
the pick here Zach Harrison the pick for
the Atlanta Falcons who went Bichon
Robinson then Matthew Bergeron and now
it is going to be Zach Harrison your
initial reaction when you're here though
to me it's just a little bit of a reach
it's it's a need on the roster obviously
the Falcons need a power defensive end a
guy to set the edge because they got
they got a bunch of kind of undersized
guys that they've drafted in recent
years was Arnold abbaquetty
um whether it's audio gandashi like they
brought in class Campbell to maybe help
out with that but this is a guy in that
similar mold that can really set a hard
Edge that can be your run Defender first
that can maybe push the pocket a little
bit item quite a bit lower down the
board because he's stiff this guy trying
to turn the corner trying to get back to
quarterbacks I worry about but he was a
10 800 guy coming out of high school
that guy can cook he's got a little
linear straight line explosiveness to
his game I think that's something that
again he can learn from Bud Dupree who's
a similarly tooled guy
how to be effective with that sort of
skill set so with that I'm still not
super enthused about I'm gonna go C plus
Felder one thing about him I mean they
signed Calais Campbell this off-season
mountain of a man this guy Zach Harrison
longest arms for defensive ends in the
draft 36 and a quarter I've never heard
of that before his wingspan was nearly
86 inches 11 career breakups five Force
fumbles and he's not 22 yet
I remember him from high school okay I
he was higher ranked than Garrett Wilson
yes he was I was underwhelmed with his
Ohio State Career okay I had he like I
was expecting something close to what we
got from Cheshire or the bosses or or
the bosses he was supposed to be the
next of mine he was supposed to be the
next guy and so for me when I put it in
that context I am going to go with the c
because I don't think that it's your
lowest grade I think of the draft it
might be I think I'd do a c minus one
time maybe maybe but anyways point being
I just I think it's a reach as you
mentioned but when I when I look at it
through the lens of what you were
supposed to be yeah it does become a
little bit disappointing I don't know if
that's how they used him because I know
they changed defenses over the course of
that time but the reality of it is is
that we see teams change defenses
like Illinois and people get better and
then we see teams change defenses and
people kind of stay the same so it is
what it is the potential is there same
as Zach Pickens great potential right
you just don't and this is when the NFL
goes well if we coach them maybe we can
get the most Bingo New England's have
one of the best drafts thus far
Christian Gonzalez the first key on
white in the second and now Marte mapou
is the pick uh in the third round for
the New England Patriots uh mapu
defensive back what do we think with him
Renner yeah I think he ends up playing
at I mean so they got a guy in Kyle
Duggar who's kind of like that safety
linebacker whatever hybrid similarly to
a guy maybe not as quite a high-end
athlete but he played Safety more
overhang in that Sacramento State
Defense but he plays with an edge this
guy gets after it 216 to 220 pounds he's
gonna be undersized for a box player but
I think he's in the mold he's in the
mentality where it doesn't matter
fantastic tackle wasn't Duggar an FCS
kid too he was to D2 or D2 kid it
actually says don't check to stress
these guys to show you how good he is
and he just takes guys who play the game
the right way right mapu is that guy he
probably would have gone higher where
not for a torn Peck in the pre-draft
process that he suffered so his rookie
year may not be you know even ready to
play at any point but he's a guy where
year two year three I mean he's starting
on this roster and I think he's with
Bill Belichick's tutelage I think he's
gonna be a good one you think he's gonna
you think he's gonna move up to
linebacker I do think so I think that
like skill set wise you would be wasting
him and the way he plays six three two
twenty one he's got that size you just
would be wasted he's the first guy
drafted Felder that was not invited to
the combine and his nickname was the
Silent Assassin there we go solid
assassin
let's go e minus
okay boom Sacramento state does that
worry you at all
he was dominant he was uh he was uh
first team All-American Big Sky
Defensive Player of the Year First Team
all Big Sky 27 starts 22 passes defended
it's Belichick loves to do this
those are his kind of guys yeah I mean
he's he doesn't he doesn't draft away
anyone else drafts right no he is not
strange
he is looking at
how they play more so than who they are
what they do and the ram select the
other Byron young I am very thankful for
Felder for uh fixing it because I would
have absolutely gotten them confused uh
Byron young out of Tennessee is a whole
nother ball of wax he was a zero star
recruit spent two years at the Georgia
Military Academy because of that he's
already 25 years old but double-digit
tackles for losses in two seasons for
Tennessee combining for 23 and a half
very productive yes this is a unique
Prospect for a number of reasons that
you touched on already but also because
he runs a four four three at 250 pounds
just get off wow his electric his motor
is one of the highest in this draft
class he does not take plays off but he
also does not know what he's doing as a
pass pressure just yeah he is a true
true work in progress the flashes are
sweet they are too few and far between
though to get you too excited and from
year one to year two at Tennessee I
didn't see too much of a progression but
the twitch is really off the charts and
he is jacked to the gills there is not a
lot of fat on this dude so with LA and
how they kind of utilize their Edge guys
I think it's a good schematic fit uh and
it's a good fit in that wow you know
he's a project and you're a team that
can afford that because this is this is
not your year you know your life cycle
and it's two or three years from now and
he's a guy could be an impact guy in
that realm so I'm going to go with the
b-plus for this pick I like this player
a lot like watching him play you see
like you mentioned you see flashers you
see the quick twitch you see that he's
rocked up you see that he's listening
he's not afraid to take it inside he's
not afraid to hang on the outside I love
the fact that he's still learning how to
work on that bin that's going to be
really important for him going forward
but you see that inside move right there
blowing that play completely up yeah
he's got that little quick dip to the
inside on that little slant move he can
do that here look at his tracking it
down from the back side it's faster than
the running back he can he knows what
he's doing like he he doesn't know what
he's doing he knows he knows what they
tell him to do right yeah those are two
completely different things because I
don't think he has a backup plan if the
first thing doesn't work then he gets
caught up in the wash but when he when
they Point him in the right direction
you get going and that's what coaching
is for to point you in the right
direction until you develop a skill set
where you can do it by yourself yeah
dude is a cannonball you just need to
put him the right way yeah let's go
b-plus yeah
uh one thing that I really liked about
the Byron young Story part of the reason
he's 25. before he went to the Georgia
Military Academy he was an assistant
manager of a dollar store for 18 months
that's insane and now he's in the NFL
yeah you know you know damn well someone
was like man you're just you're working
at a dollar store and now he's on the
Rams uh the pack did you look at the
pick already we have the pick do you
want to guess it oh let me guess gosh
I'll guess Luke whippler
okay and the the pick is
I mean maybe they took the wrong guy
earlier and they were like regreted it
well let's fix this uh we don't know
about this Oregon State kid so we're
gonna go with Tucker craft just to be
safe but hey they didn't draft weapons
for Aaron Rodgers but they sure are for
Jordan love third team All-American uh
born in South Dakota population
500. uh you know we have seen kids from
this school from the jackrabbits Dallas
Goddard was taken at 49. he was the last
San Diego State tight end to get drafted
and now Tucker Kraft great size for the
position 255 pounds and just smooth he
reminds me a lot of Dallas Goddard and
that you know he's not a high end you
know four six nine there 40 is nothing
to write home about but when he gets on
the football field he consistently plays
a little bit faster than that and he's
tremendous after the catch bro tackles
left and right on his tape now obviously
FCS competition but still knows what
he's doing and how to evade tackles to
me he's much more NFL ready than Luke
grave I I think this is a guy who starts
right away and honestly he got injured
this past season ankle injury we didn't
get to see a Next Step from him there
could be more development to his game
I'm a big fan I'm gonna go eight with
this pick I like the back to back tight
ends I really do oh that's I think it's
cool I think Tucker craft is a heck of a
football player the times that I've got
to watch him what I see is a wide body
yeah and that's something that like
we're looking at tight ends as they get
a little smaller and get a little
smaller we're looking at that happen and
I'm telling you this is a wide body a
wide body guy who's able to go out and
make plays He's Able consistently left
go to go up and High Point the football
away from people and he's a lot he plays
faster than he ran and I think that's
going to be really interesting to see
how this takes so I'm looking
forward to watching him play looking
forward to watching his growth but this
is a wide body Guy this is one of those
guys where I say this as a defensive
back yeah
if he's if he's in the same and you're
closing in on him and you hit him in the
back you're gonna hurt yourself and I
like that I like tight ends like that
this guy's almost 260 pounds I'm gonna
go ahead and give it my grade I'm gonna
go ahead and give it a B plus I don't
know if you should be going tight in
back to back but I think it's a good I
think I think he's going to be a good
foot so they went Musgrave then Jaden
Reed and then Tucker crafts right so a
lot of weapons right now for Jordan love
after going Lucas Van Ness in the first
round uh Colts are on the clock right
now all they have done by the way
renner's taken a dump
that's unconfirmed I don't have sources
we've been waiting for this guy to go
off the Colts take Josh downs we can
start looking at it but I kind of want
to wait for a runner for the video man
that's tough uh this was the pick by the
way uh that the Colts got from the uh
Carson Wentz trade so you trade Carson
Wentz and you get Josh Downs wide
receiver from North Carolina a guy
that's been waiting to come off the
board second Team all ACC UNC season
record for catches and yards and 21 went
101 for 13 35 90 of his snaps in the
slot normally I go to Runner first but
the kid took a piss and I got to make a
punishment and this is North Carolina
yeah talk about Downs I love Downs this
kid can play great body control I mean
he played with Sam Hal and that was
crazy productive and then obviously
Drake May comes on the scene and he's he
remains productive this was this is a
player that when you mentioned he played
90 of his snaps in the slot that's where
he's gonna have to be he's not big guy
but 94 catches come on crazy numbers
over a thousand yards he can do he can
get the job done obviously he's one of
the best that we've ever had and I look
at him in the way that he runs his both
his routes are crisp and I love his body
control at the back of the end zone
constantly watching him catch the ball
at the back of the end zone Great throws
from the quarterbacks but watching him
catch at the back of the end zone has
been beautiful he doesn't drop the ball
three drops 116 targets what's the grade
for this oh let's go man you get this
guy yeah let's go a plus wow now the
wide receiving Corps for Anthony
Richardson big old Alec Pierce big old
Michael Pittman and now Down's right in
the middle Runner to me he is the
anti-paris Campbell and I say that yeah
what do you mean by possible in that he
knows how to run routes like it's his
job because his job but I mean he's just
um exactly you see it right there he has
that ability to set up guys at a really
high level I on tape they just gave him
that freedom they just said hey just get
open and when it did it was at will I
mean he had over 2 300 yards over the
past two seasons 19 touchdowns and yeah
he's five nine 171 he's a little on the
smaller but he has a bigger wingspan
than Chris olave like he has long arms
for a guy that's five nine you saw him
consistently make plays outside his
frame
this is what was missing from that wide
receiver core it was a guy that could
separate on the interior they were so
predominant on the outside had to Target
outside the numbers now this gives you a
guide that can work inside the numbers
that you can be consistent with and I
think he's NFL ready I think it's year
one I love it this guy makes an impact
that's an A plus pick to give to Anthony
I love that all of these teams that
drafted a rookie quarterback are
drafting a little they're helping rookie
wide receiver to grow with them uh the
Steelers were on the clock at 80. they
have traded the pick to the Carolina
Panthers speaking of another uh rookie
quarterback Bryce young Jonathan Mingo
the two picks for the Carolina Panthers
uh the Panthers were recently sitting at
around uh 93 and that was the pit they
got in the CMC trade so they must have
given up a little bit to move up here to
move up 13 spots there's someone that
they must want to get who do we want in
Carolina let's see
they got their quarterback they got
Mingo got quarterback they got me we
have a chance to look at the big board
real quick
we're watching a safe flight commercial
on TV but the pick is in and it is
DJ
DJ Johnson the linebacker from Oregon is
the pick Felder your response
okay okay
uh this is let me ask you so is there a
soul in this ring yeah
yeah and you they went with him
yeah yeah I uh interesting I had DJ
Johnson outside my top two other players
I'll just say it right now I mean he is
a he's a guy who was top 10 freaks list
Bruce Feldman like really he is an
explosive large athlete who just did not
know what he was doing on the football
field in my opinion he just this this is
a Richie he's a linebacker he's an
engine
260 runs a 449 but you know I said when
DJ Turner 426 he saw it on tape
consistently as you see here you don't
see it on tape too consistently with DJ
Jones that is not what Byron young even
looked like running a 4-4 it's just the
hesitancy to his game what he's doing
with his hands didn't block him he's not
he's is a pure project and like a
project that I wouldn't even put on a
football field right now Tom Carolina
Panthers kind of looks like the dude
that was the Power Ranger
exactly Zach uh so what's the grade I
feel like I feel like you're
disappointed this is to me the biggest
reach yet of anything that I've seen and
now we're deep in the draft like it's
not like you're passing up awesome
players at this point in the draft but
I'm gonna go C minus here I thought you
were going to go D for the first time I
got you don't worry thank you so you're
you're upset by this pick not upset I
don't like here's the thing
you can get a pro you could have got
this guy could have gone Yaya diabi you
could have got this guy anytime you
could have got him probably as a udfa
it's written up they traded up for him
too they traded up 13 picks to get this
guy yeah I don't get it
you really think he could have gone
undrafted
that's a very that's how bad the tape
was
he just did there was a lot of things I
hate great on them wow yeah like there's
a lot of stuff that's left to be desired
I'm not not a knockout because look I'm
the guy that hasn't watched and I see
six four 260 with a four four nine and I
go that looks pretty darn good but then
you guys watch the tape and you go he
doesn't do anything again we can watch
it again let's take a look watch this
I mean that was nice
okay just keep watching roll it
this is uh Eastern Washington oh that
was a little slow
oh no oh no that's a highlight yeah
I'd love to know how long canvaser had
to look for this
yeah that's a chain okay okay
all right so you so right now at this
point at pick number uh 80 this is
easily the biggest reach of the draft
yes okay it's very pure number I'd
rather have no assault that's why that's
why I asked if he I was like did he did
he is I think what's really interesting
in this Scott fitterer draft is
obviously everybody likes Bryce young I
think you guys kind of thought Mingo was
a little bit of a reach as well and now
DJ Johnson is a huge reach yes he will
this draft will always be judged on
Bryce young but right now we're also
seeing a lot with fitterer in terms of
the other picks in this draft okay all
right uh 81 uh I believe the Tennessee
Titans have traded up with the Arizona
Cardinals uh so the Tennessee Titans are
making the pick here you go okay uh
Tennessee Titans they have gone Peter
scaronsky and then they went will Levis
so if you're looking at Value it's a
pretty good draft if Levis ends up being
a guy from where he was projected to go
uh they also could use a wide receiver
uh to help will Levis out as well as
their wide receivers are trailing Burks
um Westbrook Aquino and Kyle Phillips
I love Diane Henley here I know they
lost David long yes off season could use
a off-ball linebacker to be you know
basically fill his shoes and to me is
the best cover linebacker in this I also
say why not load up a more offensive
lineman for an offensive line that
allowed 49 sacks uh and the scoring was
under 18 points a game and you won't
have a rookie Luke would make a lot of
sense right now is Aaron Brewer and he's
super undersized I mean he's a liability
and pass Bros he's like 270 right so
okay fall Center in the NFL
would be an upgrade for sure there okay
let's see who the Titans build the
o-line in one draft would be with
whippler and scaronski would be quite
the draft in my opinion
I mean that was what Tennessee was for
all those years too
was just an offensive line that that was
maulers and I'm still kind of floored
about that DJ Johnson pick that that
reminded me of what was it a couple
years ago when the Cowboys drafted uh
Nation Wright in the third round I was
just like whoa that guy was just just
not even didn't even think until the
sixth round I even expect to hear his
name call and then it comes off pick 80.
and pick 80's a big like you were upset
that the Titans gave up a third round
pick for will Levis and they're using
one for that guy exactly and it's not uh
I mean it's not just me right and it's
Felder it's you look at the consensus
draft board of just like media and he's
outside the top 150 which is just the
amount of guys who teams have drafted
that have been kind of like that and
succeeded there's just none when you're
that big of a reach it really rarely do
you know more than everyone else about
one Prospect
maybe they owed a favor to the Johnson
family yeah
all right Tennessee Titans on the clock
uh seven and ten uh they of course still
have Ryan Tannehill they took the draft
pick of Malik Willis and that's looking
like a wasted pick now because they've
come back with Will Levis uh it feels
like though this off season
Mike Vrabel was like I'm done I want to
turn this around I've had enough that
isn't how I wanted to go anymore uh but
it also looks like they're trying to get
rid of everybody Derrick Henry there's
been rumors that he can be on the
trading block uh there were issues this
year with Kevin byart where he's not
getting a contract extension the former
All-Pro safety and they are going a
running back out of two lane so I just
mentioned the rumors about Derrick
Henley possibly being traded and they go
taijae Spears running back out of Tulane
by the look of him he is not the same
guy as Derek Henry no what do you think
Runner that's safe to say yeah just he's
barely scraping 200 pounds he is your
space back but there truly aren't too
many better space backs in this draft
class his acceleration short area Quicks
off the charts I love his contact
balance I love what he can do as a
receiver down at the Senior Bowl in
Mobile like the running backs really
aren't supposed to shine it's not a
great sort of Proving Ground for them
you can't get tackled you can't uh
really run between exactly the same way
and he shines you know him getting to
and finding space he's a lead at it and
it's just can he hold up to the rigors
of the NFL game because he has some
injury uh history he is undersized and
really come from coming from his level
of competition will that all translate
but man the dude is electric not a lot
of guys with his sort of dynamism in
this draft class so scored a touchdown
once every 14 carries and he averaged
four and a half yards after contact so
he's not big but he handles contact well
what was the grade so I'm gonna go
b-plus for that one Tajay Spears is the
correct way to pronounce it uh he was
the AAC offensive player of the year and
it was an RPO style in college if it was
with Malik Willis I'd go oh that makes
sense I don't think they're going to do
that with Levis no I don't think they
will but the big thing for me with what
he's able to do what he brings to the
table is an explosion and I love the
thing I really love about uh Spears is
his acceleration deceleration
re-acceleration and what I mean by that
is he sees a hole recognizes danger
slows himself down so he doesn't run
into the danger then he lets the danger
pass finds it takes a side step and then
he gets back up to speed exceptionally
fast for me I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
with the B on this pick uh especially
because it's not the pick that was a
couple before or right before him yes
the value is a lot better Tajay spear is
the pick to Tennessee uh the Tampa Bay
Bucks are up and they have drafted Yaya
diabe who is a guy that I was just
talking about as a possible option uh
Louisville no stars no offers worked at
an airport for two years and then goes
to the Georgia Military Academy added 50
pounds in Juco and then he gets to
Louisville nine sacks 14 tackles for
loss
third Team all ACC now that they've gone
and they got kalijah can see in the
first round and now Yaya diyabi a lot of
new faces on that bucks defensive line
and a lot of athleticism I mean at 263
he ran four five one and we're seeing
the athletes along the defensive line
starts come off the board which is
surprising why adibare hasn't been
picked yet maybe some injury red flags
there because you're not drafting these
guys over adabari in my opinion but I
will say it says batiyabi the effort is
there the guy wants it he just doesn't
quite have the tools to do it just yet
now he's not he wasn't put in a great
position to succeed at Louisville on the
interior a lot there when he's not going
to be an interior guy in the NFL at 263
pounds but you're getting effort you're
getting athleticism this is the point in
the draft where you're taking some
swings to Hope a guy figures it out
comparing him to the guy and DJ Johnson
I think there's a much better chance of
diabe figuring it out than a guy like DJ
Johnson
and then kalijah Clancy a lot of weapons
yeah a lot of weapons on defense the
ability to get to the quarterback where
they play him is going to be really
interesting you mentioned at Louisville
they played him towards the to the
inside a little bit more because they
didn't have a lot of size and here you
see him playing more as a true five
technique and you see him work that slow
twist he's got to see he's an effort guy
but I want to see that speed show too
because that's where you got to get
faster there unless you got to make that
sack earlier but effort again always
effort he wants to be long I love how
long he is too with that length playing
on the edge you've got the ability to
hold guys off and keep your outside on
free so that's the cool thing but here's
what we're talking about right playing
them to the interior yeah and it's one
of those things where yeah he makes this
play but that's a really tough play to
make really hard you should have to ask
him to do that you should have left them
out there so for me I'm gonna go ahead
I'm gonna give this one you know what B
plus they are they're they're building
something and you can see the vision and
that's the part that I really like about
the thing I like when teams do the
things that remind me of their child
when I was a child the Tampa Bay Bucks
getting monster on the d-line is what I
want yes Broncos trading up with the
Seahawks those two teams love to trade
with each other apparently so the
Broncos are moving up Broncos have
gotten some athletes Marvin Mims was
their first pick third round pick four
Speedy wide receiver then Drew Sanders
at linebacker and now they trade to take
up Iowa cornerback Riley Moss again Noah
Noah no offense Jeff I don't care about
your stuff uh Iowa cornerback Riley Moss
is the pick for the Denver Broncos who
have now gone back to back defense in
this draft Mister uh Renner what do we
know about this guy ton of ball
production over at Iowa I mean over the
course of his career got his hands on a
ton of passes picked off a ton of passes
and he's a high-end athlete white Corner
going to be the first one in like 20
years since Jason seahorn
hold on you keep going I need to process
this and he he can move this guy can
stay at corner he has makeup speed he
has the quick twitch he has the feet uh
I I love him in his own scheme we're
gonna see what Vance Joseph obviously is
going to bring to the table there but
you're pairing them across from Patrick
certain and I think as a guy that you
can rely on on an outside football is he
ever going to be a lockdown man-to-man
type of corner that certain can be no
but I think he has a really high floor
he comes up he wants to tackle and the
running game wants to tackle in the
screen game he just maybe isn't the most
physically gifted dude in terms of
physicality in terms of play strength in
terms of length four four five of the
149 yeah splits pretty good the guy can
move the guy really can move and he was
very productive in a super off Zone
heavy scheme though so uh I'm a fan of
this I'm gonna go a minus with this pick
but this is wow
he's good he's real he's very good now
this is a very scheme specific thing
when you talk about Iowa right yeah same
thing with Jack Campbell right we talked
about that on night one
scheme specific thing what that what I
mean by that is he's going to be a guy
that needs to play in cover two
and he has to be all from cover three
those are the two things that he can do
right but he triggers really well
he tackles very well and he plays very
tough when it comes to being playing
against the run in that short screen
game too he's a good football player I
can tell you that like there's nothing
there I know you're speechless but yes
he's good this guy is very good
get him on the ground there we go
all right he's not big or excuse me he
doesn't play as well okay Riley okay
then that happened then that was great
he he's a lot of he's a rap tackler more
than he is a natural hitter all the time
right right he's a rap tackler but he's
a good rap tackler so for me I'm gonna
go b-plus here this is a guy that's
going to bring some value he's going to
fit in as long as you play the style of
Defense he plays he's going to be
successful I have read articles on the
internet of how there is an epidemic of
non-white Court there has not been a
white cornerback in the NFL since Jason
seahorn in 2000 that's how long it's
been
I had people edit my podcast when I
talked about this because they thought
it was inappropriate this is Monumental
this is a this is a change after two
decades right this is not a guy that
earned his way this is a third round
pick
okay I'm enough I'm sorry this is this I
I never thought I'd see the day I never
thought it would happen again I need
Jason see her on the phone I know his
reaction don't move him to say yeah bro
that's exactly what's going to happen
Miami Dolphins go and they take the
Speedster running back at a Texas A M
Devon a chain First Team all SEC one of
the most decorated high school track
stars in the country he was also the
2020 Gatorade track and field athlete of
the year a
10-1-4-100 he okay ready
he ran a 2020 200 for perspective these
standard Olympic qualifier for the 200
is a 2024. if he wanted to this guy
would be in the Olympics and now he is
going to the Miami Dolphins that has
Tyreek Hill and Jalen waddle I don't
know how the rest of the NFL let this
happen this is when I mocked a ton but I
just thought you know he's going to go
higher someone else is going to take him
because that speed in that backfield and
he can catch this guy has soft hands out
of the backfield can really get out on
Wheel routes and stuff like that we have
moster too and he's 188 Pounds obviously
going to be on the underside side of
things but he runs between the tackles
he's not afraid of contact he has
tremendous contact balance as well now
he's probably not going to be a high-end
tackle breaker at the NFL level it's
just difficult too at that size when you
know everyone's bigger faster stronger
but he broke a lot of tackles at Texas A
M he has that to his game and not a lot
of guys are catching this guy from
behind wow and in that offense now you
have her hemost you're probably the
fastest running back in the NFL entire
kill you have jail and waddle if you're
trying to face that wow you just have no
options if they want to really throw all
that speed on the field at once so this
is an A plus pick in my opinion Mike
McDaniel kid in the candy store right
now yeah I love I love a chain he's so
good I remember not this past season
season ago they had a nice Aeneas uh
Smith and him and I had to try to figure
out which one was the running back and
which one was the wide receiver because
he catches the ball so well out of the
backfield and he catches it well from
the slot so you can move him around this
is a gadget piece this is a pick where
you you decide you they have decided
that they are going to put the pressure
put the onus on the defense to find ways
to slow them down now they've got to
make sure that they can keep they can
keep two upright wow gotta make sure you
yes that's him for real like he is
really him for real this guy is he's not
a joke a 4-3-2 Felder 432 and he show it
shows
a lot of we talk about play speed we
talked about guys not being able to get
it done his speed shows you give this
kid a crease he's going to take it from
you a plus is this like when you go to
Miami you see people renting Ferraris
the only difference is they're not
renting they bought they got Ferraris in
Miami averaged 30 yards per kick return
as well Chargers were up they just took
a linebacker day on Henley who I think
you actually wanted them to take a few
picks ago when they took Tui palolo so
they go dayon Henley grew up in Crenshaw
was the ball boy when D Anthony Thomas
was playing on that high school team
five years in Nevada then goes to
Washington state did everything wide
receiver nickel linebacker
um man 630 special team snaps as well so
he can do everything yeah that that
highlight that we just showed is why I
had this guy linebacker one in the draft
class linebacker one how many
linebackers you see making plays on the
football 30 yards down the football
field like that it was a former quarter
back in high school wide receiver at
Nevada and he understands the passing
game because of that he knows how route
Concepts flow together and he runs a
four five four and the interesting thing
about him and why I'm so high on him is
that you know only about three years of
playing linebacker usually guys who
transition from offense to defense they
don't play with physicality they're bad
tacklers it's the opposite look I missed
five tackles on 97 attempts all last
season wants to take on blocks between
the tackles it's just 225 pounds a
little on the other side to me that's
not even undersized by a lot of NFL
standards nowadays I think this dude's a
baller and I think the Chargers got
themselves a good one this is an A plus
pick one of my favorite picks the third
round him and him and Derwin James are
running around there that's crazy yeah
Diane Henley is a player that he like
that first clip I absolutely love to see
it I'd love to see a linebacker not just
in coverage but comfortable in coverage
being able to move side to side being
able to move backwards he moves in all
directions equally well and that's
saying a lot about him you see him out
here wide okay so let's trigger I'm
going to get you let's go beep it's one
of those things where you want to see
this he can Rush the passenger he can do
all those things he's able to get look
at that so I don't have effort effort
give me okay now I got the ball out
it's one of those things where the
experience all over the field the
playing multiple positions the
experience of playing all that time at
Nevada then moving up a level and not
again he's very good at Nevada yeah now
he moved up a level he's also very good
in the Pac-12
this is a this is an a pick for me
wow uh I got a story so his father was a
music executive this his nickname
was big uh he worked with Snoop he
worked with nipsy hustle he also kind of
got into trouble okay so he ended up
being the Kingpin of a gang and they
ended up being in a drug bust where he
was with an undercover cop kind of tried
to steal a lot of stuff he shouldn't
have stolen went to prison for 12 years
but he came out and he started a program
called developing options so he went and
he served his time now in that area of
Crenshaw he's all about trying to get
youth to pursue their dreams the right
way yeah this is a guy that has seen
some things daon Henley he is from La he
is staying in La he will be a legend in
LA from youth football now on the
Chargers yeah the Chargers got
themselves a person who is a fabric of
the community and that is a pretty
pretty cool story Baltimore Ravens are
up now as well uh the Baltimore Ravens
have had some interesting picks they
flowers and now they go Trenton Simpson
the inside linebacker from Clemson is
the pick so back to back linebacker
Trenton Simpson AKA Trent uh third Team
all ACC was High School uh teammates
with Jordan Davis kid ran a four four
three 40-yard dash he's got burners can
play nickel on one play and then go to
Edge on the next and his dad an Army
Ranger so the discipline is there as you
can tell by him wearing a bow tie Runner
yeah Simpson is a high I mean it's truly
all there this guy could be the best
linebacker in the NFL Sunday he has that
wow physicality he has that level of
athleticism so him and roquan together
but now he gets to learn from some of
the best linebackers in the NFL he gets
to learn from similarly to a guys like
roquan Smith like Patrick Queen when
you're a project like Simpson is because
he played in the slot back in 2021 as a
sophomore was utilized as a Blitzer
that's probably his best thing he's put
on tape so far when he was between the
tackles linebacker this past year it
just the game moved too fast from I
think he's only broken up two passes his
entire career which with that kind of
athleticism is always kind of a sticking
point always kind of worrisome but he
doesn't have to go in and start right
away when you're a project he gets to
have that learning curve and it's a
great forward-thinking play for the
Baltimore Ravens because of what he
could be but he's not forced to be that
right away like they found out the hard
way with Patrick Queen and his struggles
early on in his career you get to kind
of bypass those by not forcing them on
the football field or maybe just
utilizing him as a Blitzer where he's
comfortable early on and then
flourishing into a full-time role once
maybe you know Patrick Queen's contract
gets re-up for negotiation so I'm a big
fan of this pick I thought he was going
to go a lot higher than this false to
here A Plus pick in my opinion yeah he
took the words right out of my mouth I
thought he was going to go a lot higher
than here I thought he was probably the
second best linebacker I thought I
thought day on was probably the third
best behind obviously Drew Sanders we've
seen all three of them get picked this
is someone you mentioned the game was a
little bit too a little bit too fast on
between the tackles but when he sees it
he can go and here he is as a Blitzer
come on let's go because you ain't
getting away from him that 4-4 he shows
that on film and he's got the ability to
run backwards as well that's the thing I
like about him and then he can come off
that and go make a play and that is not
a slow person
that that quarterback is not slow so we
can watch this like here he comes all
the way around the formation oh
[Laughter]
you gotta wrap up but that was again
that was he we put the paws on it I'm
gonna go a plus this guy absolutely like
um
pick's not in yet I will tell you
something do you know who the resource
officer is at my mom's school no Jordan
Davis's dad really yeah
man so like my mom knew Jordan Davis
like way before man uh 49ers by the way
they have not made a pick they have
three of the comp picks so they've used
one of them to trade up with the Vikings
287. uh one other thing uh on Trent
Simpson If I was a linebacker
go for it if I was a linebacker that
could attack and then I got drafted by
the Baltimore Ravens that's like the
dream scenario there's something about
like putting on the Baltimore Ravens
helmet uh but they are going the San
Francisco 49ers with a safety from Penn
State jair Brown is the pick the only
FBS player with four more sacks and four
more interceptions we knew that there
were some special players in this Penn
State team we had Micah Parsons in here
yesterday and I asked about jair Brown
and he said that's a guy that you want
on your football team he's not going to
go on day one but on day two he's a stud
and he's going to San Francisco and they
got some studs in the safety uh room
already he plays the game the way like
kind of those other 49er safeties play
the game like Cal no hufango he plays
with no fear and now he's not again the
most physically gifted only a four six
five forty only a 32 and a half inch
vertical at the bra at the combine just
not really a high-end athlete it's going
to range on the back end but he's
versatile he wants to hit you he wants
to make plays he he is not going to
hesitate when he sees something and they
obviously they lost Jimmy Ward this off
season they have kind of a need at
safety for versatile dude I don't know
if he steps in right away and starts for
them but he's a guy that uh
I think of In Time can be a starter and
I think can be a plus starter I think
instincts at a position like safety is
at Paramount it is a processing position
first and then a traits positioned
second
I'm gonna go B this is this is like I
love Calvin Pryor I cover Calvin Pryor
at Louisville uh Jr Brown's nickname was
TIG he's the only player in this draft
with double-digit interceptions over the
last two years he had ten he won the
Iron Lion award at Penn State which you
get for being the hardest worker in the
weight room and Manny Diaz said this is
the type of guy that you only get once
every five years and he called him an
absolute Warrior again Micah Parsons was
in here and he's like this is the guy
you want on your team he just fits the
style of San Francisco doesn't he yeah
him next to tell no who founded they're
like carbon copies to a degree in terms
of just like how they play the game and
obviously town no hufanga took that all
the way to In All Pro season this past
year hopefully you're getting that same
sort of Potential from a guy like jaira
brown so interesting that they traded up
the draft with all those picks at the
back end though they're probably getting
a little antsy you've seen everyone else
get in the mix 49ers get the first guy
off the board I think they still need to
o-line though Jacksonville uh with the
pick now and of course we know that they
have Travis etn they are going a running
back in tank Bigsby the running back
from Auburn is the pick so Anton
Harrison was their pick in the first
round at tackle tight end then Brenton
strange and now tank Bigsby is the pick
we've seen a lot of running backs come
off the board in this third round where
does this guy Stack Up Runner to me he
was a just outside my top five backs in
this class I think real name is
cartavius oh man why doesn't he go by
cartavius because he can go by the tank
I mean they're both they're both hot
nicknames two tanks today I'll I'll say
tank at Auburn that offensive line was a
nightmare he had the toughest sledding
of any of the backs we've talked about
so far so for him to average even 5.4
yards per carry was an uphill climb it's
got a unique running style he's kind of
got a little Shifty Shimmy Shake to him
and he puts his foot in the ground and
he changes directions real quickly in a
hurry I question his top end speed he's
not a true burner I see there once he
gets out though it's not too much of an
issue he's just not really the high-end
guys that we've seen with maybe like a a
chain maybe a Jamir Gibbs right but I
think he's in every down type TJ yelled
he's the guy that I know the jugs he's
the guy that kind of spells Travis etn
when you need someone who can come in
and pass protect so uh yeah I think you
know Jax maybe had other needs I I don't
think he's going to make a massive
impact for them so we're gonna go B
minus but as a player this is right
where I had him in the ranger coming off
the board tank Bixby uh Felder led the
SEC with eight carries of 30 or more
yards what do you think of him on the
jet I really like him I I like him for
the Jags I like him for the reason that
Renner mentioned too the pass protection
that's going to be important and because
we can do that and again I love the way
he runs it's not like he doesn't he's
not he's not he's not um tipping he's he
just he runs hard every play every play
every time he every every single time
and this is what I'm talking about right
here every single time his foot goes
into the ground yeah there is a violent
Force accompanying it and it's just so
it's awesome to see you see it right
here boom it's not stomping but he runs
so hard wow it makes him hard to tackle
he doesn't look fast but he just keeps
getting by people yeah he's so he's good
I really like tank Bixby this is a great
spot you got to have some depth there
this is some quality depth that you're
getting later on after you've already
addressed some needs yeah all right
tanks Bigsby also by the way uh one
other note about him that I thought was
interesting uh 1300 yard rushing
performances so he's carried the team on
his back a few times yes and I like
backs that come from Bad offensive lines
because when you're just like I like
quarterbacks with weak wide receiving
options yeah because it makes you it
makes you struggle right and you get
better when you struggle you know know
how to overcome you give yourself
answers whereas you know when it's you
know Trent Richardson coming out of
Alabama and he's got gay thing hole
after gaming oh you don't have to
necessarily improve your vision you
don't have to improve the skill sets
that are necessary to succeed at the NFL
level so Bixby already comes in ready
and allowed those regards Rams are on
the clock uh they had traded back with
the Giants uh the Giants uh had gone up
earlier and got Jalen Hyatt these are
the best players available a number of
those especially Jones and adabaware are
kind of shocking that they haven't gone
yet the Rams draft thus far they went
guard Steve Avila early on Renner saying
that was his favorite car in the draft
and they went Byron young out of
Tennessee that Tennessee well no out of
Alabama they went Byron young out of
Alabama they want the Tennessee one they
got the Tennessee one okay so they went
they've gone trenches both times this
pick that they moved back was originally
the Jalen Ramsey pick that they got from
Miami and now they're moving back back
uh what are we thinking here for the
Rams I I would keep going line right
like I don't think with how bad it was
last year you might as well just build
it right back up to what it was you know
when you were Prime McVeigh years so
adding someone like a Luke whippler here
I think would make a lot of sense even
at Chandler Zavala from what are you
doing out of baware and add some help
for Aaron Donald so if you're gonna have
him learn from someone
that's the guy you want him to learn
from I mean all right Rams 89 they're
going to go Kobe Turner out of Wake
Forest the defense of lineman out of
Wake Forest Cody Turner is the pick
man it's just crazy to think that there
are some other guys that are out there
that they didn't go with Kobe Turner
um Wake Forest 6-2-293
I have this I'm really high in this guy
you are I am now I think audubar at this
point it's safe to say there's got to be
some injury concern or something that's
going on for him to fall this far
because this is a three Tech yeah I mean
he is a pure three Tech started his
career four years at James Madison
transfers to Wake Forest
and was a monster unblockable on tape
this past year but now he's 6'2 short
arms 288 undersized kind of pigeonhole
into three Tech but this guy had a
really good three cone just over 7.1
seconds which at that size is Elite he
moves really well and he plays with a
tenacity that is uncoachable he does not
quit you see his hands there always
moving to me on a snap or snap base is
as productive as anyone not named John
Carter
Donald that's the thing this is your
transition plan for Aaron Donald they
are the same
they're not same player they're they're
the same type type of player they're
going to play the same role in your
defense he's never going to be like
Aaron Donald never gonna be that good no
one is but this is a good transition
Plan Three Tech and he can see the feel
on third down so that's the great part
about draft and defensive lineman they
will always get 300 plus snaps in a
rotation no matter how many of them that
you have so with that like I said 71st
player in my draft board I'm a massive
fan of this guy I gave it a plus yeah I
like Kobe Turner this guy he came into
the ACC and he wrecked shop like real it
was ridiculous what he was able to do
and you saw the Clemson clip down there
it was a big part of why why Wake Forest
was in the in the football game he's a
big part of why Wake Forest was in in
games with anybody because he was
disruptive up front this is someone that
came in and just blew plays up he has
and he's got play because he's six two
he plays underneath a lot of taller
offensive linemen he's able to go out
and make plays so I I dig him I'm gonna
go with an a
all right so that is the pick for the LA
Rams the Cowboys have just selected and
they went linebacker out of Texas De
marvion over shown 50 Games 33 starts
wow 30 and a half tackles for loss and
33 starts and he defended 20 passes but
one of my favorite names demarvillon uh
the pick right here yeah so this was a
guy who started at safety yeah and then
drops down to linebacker in his first
couple years as a linebacker you look
like a safety plane linebacker but this
past year you know with Gary Peterson
coming in kind of changing the tone
culture of that defense the light bulb
flipped on you started to see it and so
when he has a track to the ball carrier
he's as impressive as any linebacker in
this draft class massive wingspan four
five six speed hitter wants to come
downhill wants to be physical still a
little bit wow of a guy who you know
gets a little over aggressive can be
taken out of place by Playa you're not
gonna bang and be your take on guy into
defense but the traits to be something
special there and they have they got a
loaded linebacker
all over the place and so demarion's
just another athlete to add to the mix
that can be a little bit more versatile
than maybe like a lady
what's the grade for something like
we're going to go a B plus for this pick
yeah I think really quick uh Felder I
think about Dan Quinn I think about how
he used
um Keanu Neil in Atlanta that safety
linebacker hybrid and how they're going
to flex them around there well just at
Texas what did you think of him I again
I I Echo him he was a safety safety and
then he started to become a linebacker
uh if I'm gonna go with the cop he
reminds me a little bit of um like the
progression of Thomas Davis oh wow
Thomas Davis was a safety for real at
Georgia and it took him to get to the
NFL to make that transition and it took
him a little while to do it so I think
that's it that's it like that's the if
he can get to that yeah he's gonna have
to he's gonna have to put on more weight
he's still lighting but he's gonna have
to put on more weight but if he can get
to that get to that those instincts get
to seeing what he sees he can be because
he's going to be very good I'm going to
go with a b-plus here
um he is he's still going to be a
project but they've got enough guys that
he can be a project and I want to add to
what you said because you said got to
put on more weight and we're talking
about Diane Henley being 226 and being
good size it's because his frame is so
framed like he is such a lanky guy that
229 pounds on him is still skating
whereas 226 pounds on a six foot
linebacker like Diane Henley is pretty
stout the very still take on blocks
they're very different yeah we are in
the linebacker run four of the last
seven have been linebackers Dorian
Williams out of Tulane is going to
Buffalo who needs to replace Tremaine
Edmonds he led to Lane in their
incredible Resurgence from that two and
ten record to 12 and two 28 starts 27
tackles for loss you just saw that play
in the Cotton Bowl he was the defensive
MVP and he also added nine and a half
sacks this man also played a ton of
special teams you pumped your fist I
feel like you like him a lot for this
part I'm a big fan of him now now
but bills might have a type because
Tremaine Edmonds I think has the broader
shoulders of any linebacker in the NFL
absolutely loose and this guy has the
broader shoulders of any linebacker in
this draft wow look at him he does look
like Tremaine Edmond he has insane
shoulder width he has a six foot eight
inch wingspan at only six foot tall
because of those broad ass shoulders and
he comes look at him he wants to pop
dudes he is physical he ran a four four
nine at the combine he can really fly
this is some of the best footage I've
seen in the last 20 picks this guy I had
him as linebacker I believe five in this
draft class I was a big fan of him right
behind Trenton Simpson on my draft board
I I thought his tape and coverage was
tremendous it's just candy take on
blocks at that size against NFL level
competition because obviously a Tulane
is a little different than playing in
the lead but he goes to a great spot for
him to develop yeah he put linebackers
in a great position there to succeed I I
think you truly can step in and run
tremaine's role a or a plus we're gonna
go a plus wow are you as high as an
A-Plus
yeah you are good I walk listen I watch
a lot of Tulane okay
you're the guy they're yeah their
defense was for real Okay the reason why
Tulane was good yes they had good
offense yes they had a good running game
but the reason why Tulane was so good
is that was that defense those guys hit
you see it like him yeah these guys hit
they are not playing with you they when
you leave the game with them you feel it
and it's one of those things where you
want when you watch them play I don't
care if this is SMU boom let's get him
on the ground it's one of those things
where you see that this look at that
effort look at that effort come on
he's a little light in the pants but he
is all over the place yeah but he's
again like we just talked about right
his frame is built so that when he
attacks when he attacks he is able to
play at a lower level than a guy like
overzone because over show is
kind of top heavy this guy's got way all
the way through right right and so he
can play at a lower pad level which
allows him to make bigger plays right
there in the middle so what's the grade
what do I say I say a yeah
Dorian Williams the pick for Buffalo
they needed to replace the linebacker
they do that all right Kansas City
Chiefs the uh Super Bowl champions are
on the clock uh they went defensive and
Felix in the first round they went
Rasheed rice who I talked to my guy in
my homes he threw with in Dallas so that
was the wide receiver he liked offensive
line if they get to Juan Jones that
would be it would be the perfect fit and
I mean dwan Jones 370 pounds Orlando
Brown 350 like they're similarly styled
tackles you lose one gain another at
this point in the draft which is where
the this is where Atlanta Brown
came off the board right now and then if
you can pair him with Juwan Taylor who
they just signed those could be your
tackles for the next few years that
would make a lot of sense
well there's only one way to find out
Matt Nagy the new offensive line uh the
new offensive coordinator there spagnolo
obviously uh still the defensive
coordinator out of baware I agree with
you something must be going on
um that we don't know about I like CIA I
know he has Medical Red Flags too
medical will also drop as well gotcha
and uh we're getting to the point where
Tanner McKee might have to come off the
boards yeah so I got to Kansas City to
explain McKee and being 36 like QB is
again a very binary position you go
offensive tackle but it's not Dewan
Jones it is Wanya Morris okay out of
Oklahoma Wanya Morris out of Oklahoma is
the pick for the Kansas City Chiefs uh
to protect
the the franchise that is Patrick
Mahomes what do we think of about this
90 second player drafted he's 92nd on my
board right here so the value
spot on to me he's a project though he
was former top recruit
really hasn't didn't light didn't turn
on until this past year and even then
he's really up and down has the length
has the play strength but when he was
tested by like speed and pass protection
it got it got shaky at times but I'm a
big fan because you can't teach that
right there the ability to fly to the
second level cut guys off I think he
could use his hands better but he has
really long arms like he has built like
a first round offensive tackle just did
not have first round offensive tackle
tape and he was at Tennessee first right
yeah he was a Tennessee first transfer
to Oklahoma same time that I believe
Eric gray transferred to Oklahoma so
they went there together this is going
to be interesting for him because he
does have some development we saw him
there kind of basically bear hugging a
guy he's got to get those hands inside
but for me this is it's good value I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go with I'm gonna go
with B minus though because
you could have got the one just and I
think he's a better football player
all right well Orlando Brown Oklahoma
Houma so Freedom free Oklahoma so maybe
you know that is it's one of the guys
from Boyz II Men
what do you mean any more is one of the
members of Boyz II Men oh the name the
name Oh I thought you know like that was
his son no I don't think so well he's
probably named after him I would imagine
wine is cannot be that yeah comment of a
name stealer oh my gosh sometimes
players go to the team they're supposed
to go to and that just happened the
Pittsburgh Steelers take the biggest
bruising tight end that you'll ever see
in your entire life that big zero right
there yeah that's Darnell Washington and
him Yahoo baby he is going to be joining
friarmouth out there in Pittsburgh
Darnell Washington look at those numbers
six seven two sixty four could it be
more perfect this one is a culture fit I
mean he plays Steelers football he is
when he gets his paws on you like a
linebacker or a DB hey coming off it's
672-64 and truthfully like if this guy
wanted to he could be an All-Pro tackle
like that's the way he moves that's the
way he uses his hands
um but he wanted to play tight end and
truthfully in that role he can still be
an impact player after the catch
DBS make business decisions left and
right on this guy because he is so
physically impressive and like the
numbers don't really do it justice 66
264 but like you see him in person and
he looks like a man playing with
children you know that's how your dad
looks on a Pee-Wee football field and he
also had the third best short shuttle so
it's not like he's slow not slow not a
particularly like below average athlete
but he's not gonna ever look like the
way you know Dawn Kincaid looks Michael
they're not that level of Shifty that
level of Route Runner you're going to
have to scheme them open but 11 inch
hands when it's in his vicinity he's
home he just picks it up he has built
different truly and it would not
surprise me at this point in the draft
if they're able to convince them to play
offensive tackle actually like it
because he has high-end high-end
offensive tackle potential what's your
grade for this I'm going a plus okay my
second question tell her don't go yet
who was your comp
comprehend Mercedes Lewis okay who is uh
Felder who is your comp for Darnell
Washington LeBron James
talk about it how tall how tall LeBron
six eight yeah how much you weigh like
probably like 250.
bigger he's bigger than LeBron yeah he's
big he's not as tall as LeBron but he's
bigger than LeBron yeah this dude yes
LeBron James is the comp I don't feel
bad about that at all this dude he could
have played he could have played college
basketball right he came from Vegas went
to Georgia because he wanted to make
sure he got to the NFL
this is a big he's a monster I mean the
catch he made over Henry toad toes not a
bad linebacker
in the Alabama game against then was
insane so why did did this not happen
earlier
because I listen I don't know why Kirby
Smart does the things that he did that
he does are you talking about you're not
talking about his production
I get drifted earlier because every play
I'm seeing he just it doesn't look like
the same he didn't get his he didn't get
as many reps as these other tight ends
he got a lot of a lot of blocking reps
but he didn't get as many reps as guys
like Dalton Kincaid catching the
football uh they Brock Bowers was the
guy that was getting all the catches for
Georgia he got a handful as you
mentioned schemed open plays down the
field that really worked for him but
this is an A plus for me this is one of
my favorite players in the draft has
been for a long time I I'm excited
because I think he can be better in the
NFL than he was in college because in
college he was there realistically
sixth option right basically Bowers lad
McConkey Kenny McIntosh uh the Milton
kid cures Jackson like he was their
sixth option so he's gonna get a chance
to do a little more I'm thinking they go
they went Broderick Jones in the first
round if you lined up Darnell Washington
next to Broderick Jones that is so much
size I know that's what they did yeah
they've done it right he's done that
already wow he's done that's what they
this is good so Georgia offense lefka
what they used to do was they would take
Roger Jones on the end yeah Darnell
Washington lines up right next to him on
the line and then Brock Bowers lines up
in the wing and they would just power
through just destroy people and the
other two picks Joey Porter Jr Keanu
Benton this is a this is a tone setting
draft this is a throwback we're getting
back to who we are your ass play after
play sort of address wow that is the
headline Pittsburgh Steelers this is a
kick your ass NFL draft we are back oh
Baltimore Cincinnati Cleveland you think
you got it we just got some of the
baddest dudes they are undoubtedly up
for one of the best drafts okay Arizona
Cardinals are on the clock uh we are
getting towards the end of the third
round and the Cardinals draft Michael
Wilson at 94 overall we are into I
believe the compensatory picks right now
nope this was the Ganon tempering temper
uh temper flip so Michael Wilson uh the
pick here wide receiver out of Stanford
I love this pick yeah you do this is one
of my guys in the draft class 66 player
on the draft board I had him ahead of
guys like Cedric Tillman Jalen Hyatt who
have already come off the board why he
falls here though 14 games the last
three seasons the guy has been injury
plagued unfortunately over the course of
his career but when he's on the football
field when he's healthy he's one of the
best route runners in this draft class
and one of the best route Runners at six
foot two 216 with real NFL size for my
money he has the best release package in
this draft he gets off the line really
well clearly is good at 50 50. more of a
possession type of wide receiver but he
has a little juice and the kind of
nuance to his game to separate down the
football field
I I love this pick this is a obviously
it's going to be a need for them when
DeAndre Hopkins eventually leaves town
which is probably gonna be sooner rather
than later and he can fill in that X
role for them we're gonna give that one
an A plus wow I like this pick I like
him yeah I wish Stanford had been better
so more people would have seen I don't
know
[Laughter]
but no we um the cool thing about
Michael Wilson is and he reminds me a
little bit of um Drake London right yeah
guy that could High Point the ball wants
to High Point the ball uh kind of play
basketball out there on the football
field and I love that about his game you
see that on tape you see it consistently
on tape I'm gonna give this one an a I
think he's going to be a contributor and
listen he doesn't have to he he he can
come into this league and figure it out
he under he's we know he's a smart guy
yep you don't go to Stanford if you're
not smart right and so I think he's
going to be able to figure it out he's
going to go out and make plays give and
give the Cardinal some help he went to
the Senior Bowl down in Mobile and I
mentioned tank Dell it was probably the
most impressive guy there didn't lose
Michael Wilson a close number two not a
lot of dudes there could hang with him
um I I think he's I think he's Day One
impact guy truthfully I'm just this is
the last official pick of the first
round I'm just still sitting here
thinking about Darnell Washington on
Pittsburgh
it's just it
it's crazy how the two teams in the AFC
North Pittsburgh and Baltimore yeah I
feel every draft we sit here and go
that's a Pittsburgh guy yeah that's a
Baltimore guy and now speaking of the
AAC North the Cincinnati Bengals are up
they went miles Murphy in the first
round DJ Turner and the second round
again two guys that also fit that team
as well and now they have these 92nd
pick in the NFL draft before we get to
the comp picks as Felder said
this one better be Dewan right come on
come on the right tackle
can me with Lyle Collins and his ACL
that would
that would be the dream scenario for
them if they can secure him miles Murphy
DJ Turner you address three positions so
the only thing that I'm thinking about
with the one is the fact that he refused
to weigh in at the Ohio State pro day
and his weight could definitely be an
issue yes but this is a guy that was 68
374 the longest wingspan in Senior Bowl
history at seven and a half feet
seven and a half feet yeah
and this is this is Joe burrow all right
can we protect him please that's who I'd
like it to be but next to him at the
Senior Bowl and it's different the
standing next to a guy like that even
even you kind of got sucked in Darnell
Washington you know Darnell Washington
there too you stand next to to Juwan
Jones it looks to eat dwarfin guys like
that so 11 and 5 8 inch hands too not
just long dude that's like both of mine
built
all right Cincinnati Bengals are on the
clock uh this is pick number
95. uh so this originally came from the
Kansas City Chiefs this is when the
Kansas City Chiefs moved up to get Wanya
Morris which is interesting that those
two teams I would not trade with a team
that I faced off in the AFC Championship
that's just a little a little code but
Kansas City moved up to get an offensive
tackle which is also something that
Cincinnati could use so we'll see what
Cincinnati does after this we get to the
comp picks Arizona is next that is a cop
for when Christian Kirk went to the
Jacksonville Jaguars you see Washington
that is the comp pick of when uh Brendan
sherf went to the Jaguars Jordan battle
safety out of Alabama is the pick so
they go back to back secondary picks in
Arizona Jordan battle uh the safety from
the Crimson Tide Runner this is your Von
Bell replacement
they lost him and Jesse Bates yeah a
four-year starter at Alabama anytime
you're starting games as a true freshman
for Nick Saban that's saying something I
think just a really steady player one of
the best box safeties in this draft
class I'm not sure I trust him deep I'm
not sure I trust him in the slot but in
the Box he's willing to take on Blocks
he's going to wrap up in space he's got
long arms he's 210 pounds he's built
like in NFL safety I just questioned the
athleticism and it's Pro Day 29.5 inch
vertical nine six broad jump seven three
one three cone those are ugly numbers
and you see it a little on tape you just
don't want to catch him catch them
one-on-one but in zone coverage or in
the Box he can be a steady solid player
but again that's what Von Bell was in
that defense so I think it's a pretty
clear one-to-one replacement there with
Von Bell so I'm gonna go I'll go b-plus
for that uh there were three captains
Felder on that Alabama team it was Will
Anderson it was Bryce young and it was
Jordan battle Yep this guy for me my
comprehend is every Alabama safety ever
like he's this is this is what this is
the guy that Nick Saban wants this is
who he wants running his team this is
who he wants to be in charge in the back
and this is who he wants making
decisions and I think that's the part
that's going to get him he he plays the
anticipatory football and I love that he
understands what he has to do he knows
it right now if I don't make this tackle
that guy's gonna score a touchdown and
so he goes out and he gets the job done
every single play every day and that's
the thing you want he knows where he's
he knows where he goes and run fits he
understands run fit and I think that's a
huge positive for a guy like for for a
team like the Bengals to have somebody
back there who should be a pretty quick
Plug and Play because he has a pretty
good understanding of what's going on
you're not going to get me deuce Vaughn
I'm sorry you're the wheel I'm not
falling for that I'm not falling for it
so for me I'm a big fan I am going to go
hey you get a guy that I really like you
get him a lot later it's for more value
so here we go uh three pick sixes all
were over 40 plus yards so even though
the 40 and all that wasn't great he
still can get it going uh so Detroit
actually traded with Arizona before and
they are going defensively or excuse me
uh yeah defensive lineman Broderick
Martin is the pick here look at that man
that is a big Poor Man's Jordan Davis
right there he's really foot five 330
pounds with 35 inch arms this guy is
tape early on his career was it was not
draftable tape let's just say but this
year looked like a completely different
player really kind of bought into who he
was like he can be a Linville Joseph
type that he can just if he gets in a
phone booth goes forward and goes hands
first because 35 inches at a nose tackle
is unique and not a lot of dudes with
that kind of length with that kind of
size if he can just get off you needed a
guy like this and put his hands on dudes
put him next to a lean McNeil in running
situations and all of a sudden you've
got two guys that can two Gap and really
plug up those holes in the middle now is
he ever going to be a lot more than that
no this is a pure Silo space eating nose
tackle to it as a pass rusher space for
Aiden walk you back but again you said
it they needed this guy they needed
someone in this mold Broderick Martin's
that uh his tapes ascending enough that
he's easy to buy into I still think it's
a little early okay Adam a little later
on the draft so I'm gonna go B minus
29th against the run so you get a guy
that can plug some holes in yeah that's
all he's going to do big time space
heater I like him as a player this is
someone that's going to be pretty good
I'm gonna go B okay Broderick Martin uh
the pick for the Detroit Lions who now
have they already have six players in
this draft they are filling out I mean
pend and hooker Brian Branch very very
interesting solid draft for Detroit
after a questionable first day the
commanders are selecting a center Ricky
Stromberg uh
I mean I don't know this is the most uh
I'm not going to say it uh Ricky
Stromberg is the pick for Washington the
center there 6'3 306 out of Arkansas
Runner yeah he's probably you know so I
mentioned the top three centers here Joe
tipman Luke whippler who's still on the
board John Michael Schmitz this would be
fourth Center for me in this draft class
uh probably a little again I probably
prefer whippler but his tape is coming
against the SEC coming against the best
competition and I love how low he plays
this guy is consistently firing off the
ball with the solid base into contact
never going to be a people mover you
know he's just a shade over 300 pounds
he's not your big Burly Center he is
your guy who can play on the move but
he's a guy who's ascended every single
year of his career with four years as a
starter uh some at Right Guard but this
is a center pick that's where he's
playing on your football team so he's
probably a backup truthfully in
Washington to start off with but again
when you want to draft offensive lineman
before you need him so all that said
I'll give it a b-plus I think he's going
to be it's good solid Center in the
league so yeah I mean that's that's the
goal right this is somebody that he can
play in the NFL he played in the SEC was
good in the SEC he could play in the SEC
he could play in the NFL he's a coach is
all SEC selection obviously this is
someone that everybody else recognized
was had good value and I think that goes
a long way so for me I'm gonna go ahead
and go b-plus of course that was the
comp pick from losing Brendan sherf uh
Brandon Sheriff to the Jaguar so we'll
see how he can do uh now we are
officially into more comps uh the
Bengals this is because Minnesota hired
quesi adofu Mensa
um what are we thinking here for
Cleveland who their only pick thus far
because most of their picks went for
DeSean Watson was Cedric Tillman uh the
wide receiver uh that they got in return
uh for the Elijah Moore trade I know
siaka has the Medicals that may drop him
but like that's what they need their run
defense was piss poor last year 25th in
the NFL tough to watch at times and it's
because these don't have the horses in
the middle they added Dalvin Thomason I
believe to this to try to shore it up
but that in my opinion but they lost to
David and Clowney yep you need more
along that front so you know kind of the
medicine we just taught the Lions take
with Broderick Martin is maybe not a
limited upside guy I would love that
just adding a run stuffer to the middle
of this defense and someone like siaka
so we shall see where they end up going
but that's where my head's at
hmm and then of course DeJuan Jones uh I
don't think they really need that but if
you want to keep them in Ohio but that's
not now with that offensive line it's
the one thing they got going on
all right Browns what are you doing
come on man we got five left
five I believe it is Browns Niners
Raiders and then I think it's Niners
Niners unless they traded one of those
already to move up I think the Vikings
have it gotcha so a lot of these picks
these comp picks because something new
with the NFL is trying to do where if
you have a minority person on your if
you're a person of color pretty much on
your roster and then someone hires them
away from you you get rewarded with a
third round pick and it's really a
testament to the Niners who got three of
these the fact that they had so many
people of color minorities in power
position that got stolen ran carthon
Mike McDaniels Martin Mayhew they got
him and they did they went exactly with
who you said siyaki Ika the defensive
line
love it I mean this guy is truthfully I
just I think I said about Broderick
Martin I don't think applies to siyaki I
think he adds a little bit more juice
than Broderick Martin does to just not
you don't have to be a pure Gap eater
this is a big boy but he can be quick as
well he can swim a guard he can swim a
center he can nut stunt a center he can
get from one Gap to another with ease
off the line of scrimmage maybe he's
never going to be you know Vita Vega
right but you're talking about a
similarly sort of skilled type of player
um and just exactly what they needed
that if he wants to put anchor down and
not be moved he won't be moved they
didn't have that guy last year they now
have that guy I love this pick that's an
A plus fit for me two years at LSU in
those two years won a national
championship then goes to Baylor for two
years in his first year Big 12 defensive
newcomer of the year had a bigger 2021
than 2022 but I remember when the
Cleveland Browns took Danny Shelton and
this is a two gapper big dude can stop
is a heck of a football player like them
at LSU loved him at Baylor and I agree
with Renner he can shoot a gap he can
shoot a gap he can make a play or he can
make or he can eat up two guys so the
linebacker can make play but look at the
way he moves that guy around and still
makes a tackle like that's power that's
raw power that he's got in those Paws
throw this guy around back run he ran
him back into the ball carrier
to get that tackle for law so I love it
I think it's a great pick I'm going a
plus as well especially when you're
getting them here he played one he
played 2i he played three tech only
issue he was 12 pounds heavier at his
pro day than the combine which is I
don't know how you can put on that
amount of weight that quickly but that's
that's because it's all you can do
Buffet that's about all it takes for a
guy like that when you starve yourself
before the combine yeah that's the whole
thing like just you starve yourself
before the combine right yeah when it
you know when you're at 3 30 that guy
does not look 330. you tell me that on
tape right there was 3 30 I hey guys we
got our first kicker uh pick number 99
he makes his way into the top 100 the
kicker out of Michigan I have no stats
on kickers Jake Moody out of Michigan he
made 29 field goals in 2022 he led FBS
uh I think Felder is appalled
I mean uh what do you want me to do man
uh does he make kicks uh runner what do
you got on Jake Moody here you want 148
of 148 on extra points over the course
of his career but he went 29 to 35 on
field goals last season now a lot of
those misses were from 50 plus three of
seven from 50 plus but it's like
that's kind of where you make your money
right you better be damn good from 50
plus yeah that's going in the league
whole point that's kind of the whole
point this just seems early for a guy
that
I mean truthfully like kickers go six
seventh Justin Tucker was the udfa you
know you don't need you don't have to
draft these guys more likely than not
there's still guys like as we just kind
of saw come off the board that can play
snaps for your football team yep and
truthfully in today's day and age you
don't want to kick field goals anyways
so
um interesting pick interesting pick to
say the least uh I just still have uh
PTSD uh before about Robert Roberto
Aguayo uh Keely Ringo uh going to be the
pick for the Raiders and that is a
really nice pick for a guy that played a
lot of Big Time football uh Keely Ringo
will be going to Los that is not the
pick oh excuse me yeah Chris Burke just
chiming in and saying that you know a
guy like uh Ringo who was a second Team
all SEC LED Georgia and passed defense
the last two seasons you've won a little
stat about Ringo uh is it Ringo
no
is going to be Trey Tucker is the pick
damn I had a really good stat that was
interesting a Ringo he had three picks
uh he had four picks three of them were
Bryce young will Levis and Hendon hooker
uh but Trey
who did I say it was Trey Tucker the
Cincinnati wide receiver before the
other Cincinnati oh yeah Tyler Scott
that I think everyone thought was going
to be the dude this guy is um he's tiny
he is five eight nine on a good day 182
and like before tiny with small arms too
like he's never going to be
he's never going to be like a feature
focal point of the offense he's like an
Isaiah McKenzie where it's like here's a
Jet Sweep here's a Crossing route here's
something cool but my Lord with the ball
in his hands he's Dynamic he can be a
return guy four seven ten yards he's the
suddenness shows up on tape repeatedly
but it is just look at those arms I mean
he's not gonna make a ton of plays
outside his frame uh but he had a good
Senior Bowl I'm surprised he went this
High because I truly do think that it's
he's returned upside and Gadget play
Upside is all you're getting with a guy
like that but in such a role he's an
effective football player so we're still
going to go lower we're still going to
go like a c plus for that but not a lot
of not a lot of spots for receivers to
even play there after the draft that the
Raiders have had with Michael Mayer and
adding to that receiving core so he's
just kind of a gadget guy to add some
dynamism to receiving core that doesn't
have something that chocolate brings to
the table yeah he's super Dynamic
absolutely very fast Sky gets open he
gets lost a lot of times especially if
you work on him in Jet and then snap the
ball while he's behind the line of
scrimmage and I think the cool thing
about the well this is this is my
concern
if anybody gets their hands on him he is
going on to the ground
like he you touch him and he's on the
door but he Anders I think he
understands that I'm small yeah
let's get a ball
I'm saying is I think I think stands
like I could pick my spots yeah and here
he picks his spots right and he makes an
electric play but on other plays he's
like ah you know what I'm going to go
ahead and let take let this one go yep
yep so it's going to be an interesting
shot I like him though I think it's a b
right here
um he does bring some of that dynamism
that we mentioned and he's got the
ability to go out and make some plays
well Trey Tucker the Speedster so you
got Devonte Adams Hunter Renfro Michael
Mayer uh they do not have a guy like
that if they want to do the jet sweeps
and things to like okay Niners uh the
pick is in uh and the Niners are going
to go with Cam lotu
cam lot I love that one do you well then
I'm going to let you go first
we're gonna disagree I'll just say
that's fine go ahead that's okay Cameron
law two tight end Alabama what is it
about him that you like I I love the way
that he played for this football team
and I think that's something that for me
speaks to a guy that was both it was
pretty unselfish for most of his career
there he was someone that was just all
you do is block you block and then maybe
we give you the football every now and
then but when they needed him to step up
he was able to step up he had one bad
drop I think and then in in the national
championship game but other than that
this is a guy obviously can high point
the football I think he's a good blocker
yeah which is why they use them in that
capacity and he finds a way to get open
I I really do like him I think getting
him here for me that's gonna that's
gonna be a night like I do like getting
him here yeah I'm thinking about the
Shanahan offense and him and Kittle
like this let's go make a catch I like
it I like this one I love his hands
outside his frame I think he can pluck
the ball easily but then he does have
concentration drops on his tape yeah I
think his drop rate was over 10 over the
course of his Alabama Career but again
like not utilized a lot with only 56
career catches there what I worry about
is you mentioned him as a blocker good
blocker but 242 translated in the NFL
those aren't the guys that become good
blockers at the NFL level right like you
better be 260 to be the blocking tight
end in an offense and then as a receiver
dude ran a 4-7-8 he is not a vertical
threat he is not particularly Dynamic
after the catch he's just a kind of
reliable underneath guy so I don't see
how that necessarily complements George
Kittle so at this point in the draft I
had him as like a fifth rounder this is
just this is just early for me so I'm
gonna go C plus okay uh C plus uh 49ers
with some interesting decisions with
these last few picks uh kicker a tight
end when you know there's some other
options out there but we have now gotten
to the last pick of the third round it
is pick number 102 the Minnesota Vikings
they've only made one other selection
thus far in the draft it was Jordan
Addison the wide receiver out of USC and
now they are going back to USC to take
the corner Makai Blackman the Makai
Blackman the pick out of USC for the
Vikings double dipping
from the Trojans
what are we thinking here Runner this
guy had a heck of a year this past year
15 pass breakups three interceptions but
it's because he's so unbelievably grabby
penalties are going to be an issue for
this guy and especially at his size
though is the worry something is that he
is 178 pounds and sticks with wide
receivers because he gets his hands and
will not let go of wide receivers
unfortunately uh this past season he had
seven penalties
um four penalties the year before that
and a lot more that could have been
called but the feistiness you see again
and again on tape this has Brian
flores's sort of fingerprints all over
it because he can be the guy that
matches up with your smaller wide
receiver on the other team in man covers
because he will get after it he will
play a feisty brand of football and you
can rely on him when that's the case
it's just when you're going up against
maybe a six foot two more of a
possession type of wide receiver he'll
get bounced around he'll get just tossed
off toss out of the club so probably
your slot in that defense at this point
in time who you know like I said is
ascending played a lot better this past
season played a lot better at the scene
Bowl than I expected we'll go
Flappy for the pick
I like them he had a good year like you
said he did have a really good year he
is grabby him him and Joey Porter Jr
very grab handy guys but 447 yeah so
this is he ran a four seven four four
seven Oh I thought it was about to say
no way he was that slow
oh man but yeah he can he makes plays so
I think it's gonna be really interesting
to see how how he grows how his career
goes he's somebody that's done that's
played a bunch of football obviously and
I think the key of yourself was from
Colorado footage now uh but the big key
for me with him is going to be how he
tackles how he handles physical wide
receivers and where you play him because
if you play him outside on AJ Brown he's
going to be in a lot of trouble so I'm
gonna go with that same beat
I really think we're starting to see uh
the drop off in this point in the draft
yes we're starting to see that Talent
where I feel like in years past yeah you
know you get to the end of the third
round you're sitting there and you're
like man there's still some studs I'm
not hearing it out of you guys well the
kicker is always the inflection point in
anything yes right the kicker comes off
the board is kind of when you officially
have run out of players that you think
can start on your football team right
away so very interesting for the 49ers
so that is it for the third round uh all
three rounds are done uh and now we're
going to kind of take a look at at who
kind of the biggest winners are so while
you guys go uh and take a peek at that I
just kind of if if there's any way we
could bring up maybe the second and
third round and just like look over some
of the picks uh early on we were
wondering when will Levis was going to
come off the board he went with the
second pick in the second round uh Joey
Porter Jr was our first pick but Levis
Tennessee trading up to get him Michael
Mayer came soon after that the third
pick uh and then Sam laporta
early on do you have any early winners
Renner when you look at just today
second and third round I'll say this the
Lions we hated their first round yes
thought they did not get value they
flipped that on its head today you know
getting Sam laporta I think one of the
best Yak tight ends in this draft class
getting Hendon hooker getting Brian
Branch like they got culture dudes guys
that come in in that locker room like
they didn't have to fit in a Jalen
Carter they didn't have to fit in a
problem with this locker room because of
talent they got guys who are going to be
rah-rah who are going to buy in every
single day that they're going to love
showing up for work and that's a great
atmosphere that they're building now in
Detroit and so maybe you can complain
about positional value and I definitely
will complain about the positional value
that they got on day one what they did
on day two was spectacular and they got
head and hooker when they did yep the
guy that we thought might go first round
at that point in the third round was
pretty special you got a winner for me
yeah I got Illinois secondary I mean
again we talked about it yesterday with
Georgia right having those guys taking
they had more guys they had they had two
more guys go they got three guys out of
one secondary to go in the first three
rounds of the draft Illinois secondary
they're gonna I tell you what every
piece of recruiting material that they
send out yep is going to have those guys
names and faces on it so it's going to
be interesting second winner I got
left go how many years you've been doing
this this is my 10th year 10 years
let's do it
10 years dad
I appreciate you oh crap
wow bro
that's insane so many issues number one
don't shave your face looks crazy okay
number two Woody you have helped me with
my clothes for a very long time this was
the worst shirt that you ever put me
here we should take this and put it on a
table 10 Years bro you did it the year
before that I got here I did it the year
before you got here and then I then I
did it wow
stop this look at that look at your
clean shaven face wow hold on no you
need to put that back on right now wow
your your difference is wild with the
beard let me tell you something the
first year I did the draft
look at that that's incredible draft
they had me sitting in a box
underneath lights and you know I'm a
sweater yes and the first night of the
draft they would throw to me in like my
own little separate stage yes and I was
just pouring sweat and one of one of the
bosses said hey we got to get him out of
here we got to get him out of there
wow that's your first draft there we go
now I've been doing this my first one I
ever did oh was that this year was that
the sports illustrator but that oh that
was the spff one so now that was
yesterday you guys you guys uh you guys
have Quan Martin line you up there back
in the days you guys had some fresh cuts
back then oh man
um okay you know what I I listen you
guys you're very cute doing that for me
that's very cool uh I'm gonna pick three
teams this winter just because I've
literally been doing it let's do it of
course there's more I thought the Giants
were winners uh getting the best uh uh
Center in the draft and then also
getting Jalen high and I thought that
was a nice piece Tampa Bay getting Cody
Mock and then coming back and getting
Yaya after getting Clancy in the first
round all of those were Prime Time
Players I thought the Chargers Tooley
and then coming back I thought those
were really good uh and then my last one
is gonna be
white cornerbacks I never thought I'd
see the day Riley Moss but Riley Ma we
got a white quarterback in the NFL I
never thought it would be uh see the day
but uh truly this is one of my favorite
times of the year the NFL draft because
at this point we are all finding out
where our favorite players are going and
our new favorite players are joining our
favorite teams these two guys are going
to hold it down for day three tomorrow
that is the hardest part of this entire
process runs four through seven they got
it Felder you are always one of my
favorite humans I always enjoy working
with you you're the it you're the
man and I love you uh Renner it
has been an absolute pleasure to work
with you we have never worked together
before uh the way you prepped your
preparation I can see why you're great
and it's been an honor working with you
here are the big players still on the
board for tomorrow DeJuan Jones Tanner
McKee arabaware we could see these guys
is going immediately make sure that you
tune in it starts tomorrow at noon
rounds four and five Gridiron draft
night they'll keep you going uh love
y'all thanks for joining us in the BR
app and we will holla at you guys later
peace
foreign
thank you
[Music]